[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
for chess continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
welcome welcome welcome back to madrid
here we see the beautiful palacio de
centonia this is day two of the 2022
v-day candidates chess.com exclusive
coverage we'll continue of course
throughout all three weeks and the
paintings inside the palace are about as
hot as the weather outside different
type of hot the chest was hot yesterday
we got our first view of the playing
hall
players of course will be filling in
momentarily and we will we will be here
and watching them take their seats when
that action happens but right now we're
going to welcome you to the seats we
have of course we start all the way on
my left here the one and only
grandmaster young ludwig hammer from
norway the one and only almira
skripchenko international master and we
are here to bring you our coverage
starting with you hammer how how are you
feeling today for day two actually i'm
not feeling that great danny uh i'm
i'm uh a little
hot uh in this uh madrid weather it's 40
degrees outside have you noticed daily i
could not i i have not stopped sweating
all day okay i don't know what that's in
freedom numbers but it's caused some
serious problems for me so i'm i'm just
hoping to get it through this thing and
it's muggy
yeah how are you dealing with the heat
well i think that i started to tame the
heat a little bit i'm feeling a little
bit better but i'm feeling more like a
chess player now you know i will tell
you a small story how how does it go uh
i think everyone will relate to it
especially it's so hot so you are waking
up during the night and you want to
drink some water so just trying to find
it you know and i tried to go through my
mirror
literally it was like
going through the like
like alice you know it was one of my
favorite books so i was like
someone who has run full steam into a
glass door more times in his life than
he's comfortable admitting on camera i
know the pain of that it hurts when you
fully go through something that you
think is clear so it was going through
the looking glass yes all right well
uh looking in a mirror here we're
looking at the faces again these
gentlemen don't mind looking at a mirror
when they see that beautiful face
looking back at them for those who may
be just tuning in where were you on day
one but meet our participants once again
eight amazing players from around the
world two from america we see they faced
off yesterday with fabio karwana getting
a win yonda pomeshi of russia got the
victory with the black pieces over
dingley wren
hammer looking at the the faces here
what what uh what's one of the things
you can say about just how strong this
field is how incredible these eight
players are
i mean this is the the top tournament in
chess where we're trying to find a
challenger and i think one of the best
ways of illustrating
how crazy good this field is is by also
mentioning some of the players who
didn't qualify here to madrid who would
who who's on the top of your list of
players do you feel deserves to be here
maybe deserves a hard word but who are
some names you think you know are
watching this event hi hi at home right
i'm wishing they're here
well from the top of my head uh levon
aronian
maxima sherlock grave
i should also mention anushkiri
should they
fun fact she didn't mention the niche
gary in the rehearsal and i was going to
call you out for that niche so shout out
to you andy but i called him
all right let's talk about the eight
players uh and and and saw them now
let's look at where they stand in the
standings yonder pon michie and fabiano
caruana of course the only two victors
from day one four players sitting at
half a point as those two boards were
drawn respectively giving all four
players the point five dingley ren and
hikaru nakamura of course we know both
both suffered tough defeats we'll see
how they bounce back today uh hammer
your your thoughts on the biggest
takeaway from day one well i mean i i it
has to be young nepal
yeah uh the challenger who failed uh but
now he's back and in the first round
with the black pieces
he beats the highest rated player in
dingley rent what a start for him
amir your biggest well of course this is
a huge surprise first of all zingliwan
almost
never loses with white so it's a huge
achievement
but they have to
well i have to say that fabio won a very
fine strategical game against hikaru
nakamura it was a very complicated game
and it seemed that you know
at some point hikaru could even play for
for an advantage but at the end you know
uh it was a very fine technical win for
fabi well speaking of that fine
technical performance by fabinho caruana
our own
dina valencia caught up with bobby after
his victory
no you and hikaru have the most
hat-to-hand match-ups
amongst any of other two players here
is that true that
familiarity breeds contempt
i didn't expect that question um yeah i
was actually surprised i saw the the
statistics and we've played
what was it 33 draws and uh
13 decisive games
uh so i yeah it's it's quite quite a lot
of of chess but we haven't played too
often recently
partially because of the pandemic and
after 2020 over the board tournament
stopped a bit any car became a bit less
active
and we started playing a lot of rapid
and blitz chess especially online
but uh it almost doesn't feel familiar
to play
over the board chess against zika well
in the past
every tournament we would play
one game
getting back to the game where was the
point
that you realized that you were actually
playing for two results and were pretty
safe
well i was very pleased when he castled
short because i thought if he
tries to put his king on the queen side
either by king d7 or maybe by a waiting
move like h4 then it's a very
complicated position and it's not in
it's not entirely safe for white
although i i didn't think i was ever any
worse but after castle short i just have
a very pleasant small advantage
maybe even more than a small advantage
and it seemed like the advantage grew
and grew
and then at some point i was worried
that i was again
uh you know going to screw up in one
game because i i had this clean win
right before the time control move 40
with queen f4
and i didn't see it and then after the
time control i saw it but i tried to get
back to it
but uh of course he car avoided it by
playing bishop d7 and then it was super
tough again to uh to try to win this
and uh let's say when was the point that
you
knew that you were going to win anyway
um
well i was just kind of shocked by queen
h6 that was the moment when i i was sure
that white should be winning i thought
black played queen g4 and then i was
going to play queen e1 to keep the
queens on
and i thought it should be winning but
it's not
still not easy and after queen h6 i
thought it it just it looks terrible
like after rookie one he probably has to
exchange his bishop for the night but
that that looks dead lost
so then i felt i was totally winning
would you have preferred to be facing
your only countryman in later rounds or
let's say was hicaro a good opponent for
round one
well i can say this with hindsight
based on the result um
but i i didn't really have any
preference before the tournament i also
knew
um that i would play hikaru this is the
standard
um the standard system that the
players from the same country play in
the in the first
and the eighth game because of you know
of course no player in the tournament
would do this but just in case of
potential collusion that countrymen
don't you know
don't ever face in a super critical game
um so it wasn't even on my mind whether
you know hikaru was a preferable
opponent for the first game or for later
games because
it's it's interesting on here that the
point that dina asked bobby was the
point we've been talking a lot about so
uh
now that you've beaten your countrymen i
guess you're not so worried about the
pairings but remind everybody why people
from the same country play in the early
rounds again well they they play in the
first round or in the earlier rounds
because we are trying to avoid collusion
and of course we had some historical
precedence and just i think it's just
fair to other players it's important you
know so uh
well
in in the at the end of the tournament
so you wouldn't worry about well
different results yeah
the 50th anniversary of the fischer's
basket match we're speaking of bobby
fischer his accusations of uh collusion
against the russians how would fisher do
in this field
um i mean he would be one of the
favorites probably really it's a hot
take i think you think yeah well there's
a lot of people who consider fischer one
of the top three players of all time but
you don't think he would be able to
adjust to modern computers
i think he would be i guess with time
whether he would fit into this group of
eight elite is interesting so just i
thought i'd throw a curveball at you
speaking of this elite group of eight
let's remind everybody who may just be
tuning in how the eight players got here
as we watch this video that explains the
path each one of them took on their way
here to madrid
is the most important tournament in
chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
[Music]
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss
ali rezafaruja won the grand swiss
turned the heads of everyone in doing so
and has become the youngest player in
history to cross the 2800 evo rating
barrier he would become the youngest
world chess champion of all time should
he win the candidates and ultimately the
world chess championship match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamor
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
punched his ticket by ousting none other
than world champion magnus carlson in
the semi-finals of that event judah
would ultimately defeat karjakin in the
final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingley wren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 v-day rating
list
[Music]
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
and that is how our eight players got
here to compete in the candidates let's
remind everybody quickly what the
candidates format is it's a double round
robin for those eight players that means
you play each player twice one with each
color the winner of course challenges
the world champion as has been talked
about many times if carlson were to
decline
the championship opportunity the top two
finishers in this event would compete of
course we'll remind everybody of the
context behind that particular point as
the day goes on again it involves maybe
maybe one particular birthday boy we can
get into
uh we we have players coming into the
hall and so i think uh
i think we'll we'll tune in with them
here and make sure that we capture those
moments how early do you want to get to
the hall if you're if you're playing an
event like this hammer is it helpful to
get the nerves out the earlier you sit
down or do you are you a last-minute
arrival um well i i went the magnus
carlson school of jazz and he likes to
get there at the very last moment i
would maybe calculate a bit more time
but like five seven minutes before would
be optimal okay on the earth well
actually i think there is a very nice
historical example um given by david
bernstein you know he was always coming
to his game like 10 minutes in advance
and he said they're silently getting
ready for the game so i really like this
approach and i think that players have
their own rituals they stick to them it
check whatever it takes you know to to
get into the plane mode
yeah well it's interesting i think i was
an early arrival to get myself in the
meditative zone if you will but
regardless of when you prefer to arrive
to the game we have the games to preview
so let's let's talk about the particular
matchups that we see by the way shout
out to chat i saw tipsy town agreeing
with me that uh maybe fisher would get
smoked but i think most people agreed
with you hammer that fisher would be a
favorite in this so anyway we'll keep an
eye on you chat um and we appreciate you
playing along with that bobby fischer
question so let's play along with the
field rapport versus farouza happy
birthday to ali reza faruja almira you
want to did you say you wanted to sing
happy birthday was that what you said or
not
well i wanted first of all of course to
congratulate the birthday boy i know how
difficult it is to play on your birthday
and he's starting the tournament with
two blacks now so this is also a very
important test for him
and he's playing against uh richard
report who is also such a creative
player so like it would be a big bang
today on the board like i expected
nevertheless
versus on his birthday
what about the next matchup of the two
oldest players in the field nakamura
versus for job off hammer well nakamura
has something to
and uh you know these white games are
precious yeah uh so he's gonna want to
put pressure on his opponent but rajaba
is
infamously difficult to beat
uh and the stats kind of showcase that
that even though nakamura has the
advantage in heads up play there are a
lot of draws between them
well of course we have two other games
to to talk about as well but before the
action kicks off we want to quickly
remind everybody that they can head over
to chess.com to cast their vote
i'm going to do it in real time i'm
actually going to go
and predict a victory for the birthday
boy
with the black pieces in a wild slugfest
versus report i think he i think he
holds on i'm going to predict that
hikaru nakamura bounces back
gets a victory with white
two decisive predictions so far i'm
going to leave this one last
young christophe duda and dingley wren
are going to get a draw that's my vote
and then lastly we have carwana and yon
napomnishi i'm going to shock the world
here and also predict the draw just
kidding leaders leader i don't think
this will be as spicy of a game as we
want and i think that the players in the
early lead will be happy with a peaceful
result remember everybody you can go to
chess.com events or just use the command
vote you'll get a direct link in chat no
matter where you're watching from head
over cast your vote to take your piece
in some cash prizes some premium
membership giveaways we see a lot of
people doing it so far about 1300 votes
cast this is your chance you can vote
still up to about move five i think
allow so even if the moves are played
don't miss your chance and uh go ahead
and go ahead and do it
here we've got napandashi and karwana
how many chances do you think he will
take with the white pieces elmira well
actually i disagree with you okay okay i
like that on the results and uh if i may
and and i really think that jan will
try to seize the momentum and he will
try to win with wyatt especially that
while i've looked at their games
and
fabi uh has some issues in the opening
so he also
i'm really curious first of all to see
uh what is going to be his opening
choice today
um
janji pomneshi also
chooses sometimes like it could be the
petrol it could be the italian game so
it's a very interesting game ahead of us
okay
she does have a lot of preparation from
his world championship match against
magnus carlsen now seems the opportune
moment uh to use some of the those uh
weaponry he didn't get to use you know
that's a that's a great point hammer and
i think that uh
we forget sometimes how how much
preparation just never gets used in a
match right and that you can see players
winning games for
for you know years to come later for
preparation from a previous world
championship match as someone who was a
second for magnus carlson in 2013 in
chennai and 2014
how often did you see magnus use prep in
other tournaments that he didn't get to
play against bishop in both those well
my biggest memory of that was when
magnus beat vladimir kramnik in the
norway chess 2016 tournament
where magnus used a novelty in a very
strategic line
that we had prepared for one of the
world championship matches yeah and it
just ended in a very clean win for
magnus and he was so thrilled about it
that he went into the norway chess
special confessional booth where you can
talk about the game while it's going on
yeah and magnus said this is actually
hammer's idea and so
i was so proud
remember everybody you can vote those
are the cash prizes just last second
call out this is your chance if it
reaches move five you don't get to vote
in this round so hurry
go to chess.com go.just.com fwc vote we
have e4 played notice almira is pointing
at me i'm going to give her the mic here
because she wants to point out that
there was a troll that happened there
well of course first uh d4 was yeah
that's what i meant troll he said d4 to
the person but he played e4 so i and so
he you see the psychological war has
started yeah
and we like we have to mention probably
one our last game
uh we young sister of duda who is
playing with the white pieces against
dingley wren and i think that well
he he's playing his second game with
white it's very important for him to
score in this situation i think
especially that jingle iran lost
yesterday so
the first round is a clear indicator in
what kind of form you are so i'm not
sure the dingo is feeling well for the
moment so
he um he still has to um
well to find the feel of the pieces if i
might say so and also recently i think
that uh young sister of duda became a
real like polish sweetheart if i might
say like everyone is
following his games and
so everyone is supporting him
i think the whole country is behind no
he really it's not i don't know if it's
quite carlson norway comparisons yet but
it really is i can speak that we've
we've had many contacts with lots of
different major media
outlets in poland about about covering
young christoph duda and here's our
here's our bird's eye view just take a
take a quick snapshot these will be the
four games we cover in great detail
today something i instantly observe is
that we have two italians uh the a5
variation employed by dingley wren
versus young christophe duda we have an
a6 approach
by fabi against yonder palmishi camera
what else jumps out to you as we look at
all four games in progress well that was
going to be my comment danny very
interesting to see the same opening on
two boards and then ding he chooses to
go with the pawn two steps forward uh
whereas fabiano carana settles for just
one step
but the idea in both cases is to create
an escape route for the bishop
and in fact that's what fabiano just did
yeah if we go zoom in and
dive into that game agreed
let's keep going hammer not trying to
interrupt because i wanted if you could
to maybe elaborate on the the
differences between dingley ren's a5 yes
of course as you said it frees up a
retreat for the bishop but it also
controls a little bit of white's
eventual space expansion whereas a6
a more flexible move frees up the bishop
but but doesn't prevent white from doing
what he or she would like to do over
here so your thoughts on that
um this is a nuance in the italian
opening that is kind of all the rage at
the moment people haven't really settled
on whether they think pushing the pawn
once or twice is the better choice yeah
and that's why it's so interesting here
to see uh karana with the black pieces
going for a different variation than
dingley wren because these two are
two of the top players in the event they
are famed for their openings
and they have different opinions uh on
this um
on on this nuance yeah
your thoughts elmira on you we know how
well bobby is prepared in general we
talk a lot about it as white but as
black sitting down against someone who
he knows fabi's also played a world
championship match he knows jan is
bringing a lot of
home cooking to the table right is there
some thoughts on why he would choose a
more flexible approach with these a6 and
h6 to avoid that prep well let's say for
me it's a more classical approach it's
almost like a
philosophical way you know to choose
right i5 a5 i5
i5 is also something you can say it's a
chip processor
so it's uh it's a modern approach in the
joko pianos so i i really like uh
this setup because so what
is going on that's exactly what i wanted
to say because he's uh he it allows you
to play h65 yes well did everyone see
the shrug like he like he just went and
brushed his shoulder off jan's like all
right i ain't stressed about it although
i'm a little surprised that you
committed to the most aggressive option
on the board and fabiano he placed this
same g5 move that was hicarus downfall
yesterday so he's saying kind of also to
hikaru yeah this didn't work for you
but when i play it
then i'm gonna create an attack in a
better fashion than than you manage and
let's talk about there is
it it is sort of an evolving idea that
we have seen more and more modern
italians go this way for black and that
one of the one of the things about h6 we
think about it historically as guarding
the g5 square whether for the bishop or
the knight but the other idea we've seen
but it mostly occurs though i'm so
excited that i can't get the words out
of my mouth it usually occurs after h3
right because once the pawn is on h3 you
have what's called an anchor so when you
advance g5 and g4 you're going to be
forcing open lines for someone to play
g5 when there is no target yet that's
why yon was surprised by this and i i
don't know officially whether this is a
novelty yet it is not so it's not a
novelty but clearly at this level it has
taken yon by surprise because again you
normally see it only once the pawn has
touched the square your thoughts on the
risks of this emir
well this is so double-edged but i'm not
sure because i'm pretty sure that uh
some of the young seconds play this if
can we click on before because i think
i'm not sure if peter swidley or nikita
victor played this game uh
how is uh
do we have access to the databases
maybe we see we see you chat by the way
we love you that is it is funny so all
right we'll go ahead continue and then
just uh usually i have my computer so i
i i'm not because yesterday for example
what happened in the game uh against
dude in the report then later on you
know i cannot sleep so i was watching
the games and actually report played
this move bishop before so it's also
very important to know the history yeah
and if the player
plays this variation with both colors so
he knows the nuances very well
and i'm just i cannot remember
fabiano playing this
so is this a surprise uh real surprise
for jan
and
what aggression yeah
uh incredible play from fabiano trying
to go for the two out of two score
with the black pieces i mean we've seen
some amazing aggression this tournament
yesterday it was ali reza farouja
and richard rapport um and and today it
just continues these players are willing
to take a risk
uh i don't know if it's because they're
concerned they're gonna you know stroke
out from the heat
or or whatever
that's our concern
i gotta get a lead now before i before i
pass out and back out for the tournament
for for those wondering so this has been
played before the main move for white is
b4 uh which has been played the mass
majority of the time uh
i i think one of the main points is that
if black plays aggressively with g4 yeah
you can you can bring the knight to this
f5 square so i'd be curious to see if b4
is played whether fabi goes for the main
move that has been played here for kind
of allowing a rather obvious idea or
whether he has something special in
store for young everyone remembers how
he started off the back half of the
candidates
okay huge win in novelty versus maxine
bashed okay b4 is on the board so we're
going to find out very soon
what caruana has planned so probably
he's testing his preparation uh well i
will use the break later on to check
like my analysis as well but i also
think that also shows well how
performant fabie is with white and black
pieces you know he is
seizing
any opportunity any chance to
well
a completely new move is that right
danny
indeed was that on the list it is knight
g4 has never been played before and now
yon really leans back takes a sip of
water looks up and says i'm really glad
this water's cold
this is scary for yan nepamyachi he
could be facing an early defeat here the
line goes rook to e2 and fabiano is
going to sacrifice his knight for that
white pawn uh the rook will recapture
and then maybe pawn to g4 and i thought
this was the sensible way of playing for
fabiano because the difference between
playing that pawn forward earlier yeah
and doing it now is that the black queen
is controlling the square white's knight
wanted to use
however
the engine is very unhappy with my
suggestion so i will go back
i want to point out because one of the
main ideas is kind of instructive it's
this move d4 because once the rook is
unpinned now it's white who's
threatening things like bishop takes f7
and all kinds of just crazy firepower
coming out so okay either way what a
fascinating game we are about to have in
store everyone so if you had other plans
on this saturday saturday it's time to
change the schedule as they say and
stick with us amir what was the point
you wanted to make well i just wanted uh
i totally agree that this sacrifice is
in the air but i wanted to do it
always the f6 square because the rookie
2 or rook f1 i wanted first to play
queen of six using first of all this
opportunity because the knight can no
longer go to knight c3 knight d5 usually
you well you don't have this opportunity
very often and then to sacrifice on f2
and
play g4
you know this sacrifices well is always
there so and maybe you're not allowing
the immediate d4 i don't know like i
like it a lot um and again amir's point
is now when the capture happens in g4
it's not just that the knight can't go
to h4 as hammer said but no matter where
the knight goes there's material being
lost so i i just want to go for the most
forcing
okay so
rookie two
i don't want to go for the more forcing
one i want to do what elmer's doing i
want to do queen of six that's okay
danny i won't hold it against you
i don't know hammer i love the idea but
i think you know you're feeling a little
hot here we know madrid you might be
getting a little too hot on the board
here yeah can i try another line just
and then we can go tonight again because
i know that this is also a standard
procedure like queen f6 you can still go
d4 and then i use that in one of my
games and you go e5 if you take is this
possible this is a typical kind of
thematic way to break open the center
when your opponent's king has chosen not
to castle the main point is that on d
takes e for example there's okay there's
all kinds of weird stuff here but like
this is a move
oh even this is a move of course there
are a lot of tactical possibilities in
this position so
uh i'm pretty sure that phobia has it
all analyzed yeah and i'm not sure that
young nepam yeah she does yeah we see
him on the camera kind of agonizing
right now if he was very familiar with
this position he would have moved
already yeah and like he's not going to
take that risk to sacrifice one or even
two pawns in the middle of the board
when he knows fabiano is not his
opponent right now right uh jan's
opponent is the chess engine
and and that is that is terrifying
because chess engine's got some game
got some game i love it though it is
really important that ever that we
appreciate that yawn is going to really
be careful here because
as as uh hammer just said right you're
not just playing the person across but
you're playing their seconds maybe
multiple seconds you're playing
everyone's favorite second these days
which is an alpha zero leva plugged into
a super jet engine computer and whatever
it pumps out
this is this is uh
this is very scary this is a valid
hypothesis but as
he loves to say
could this also be a sort of
a psychological display right but
well actually he knows the variation
he's just trying to remember it
and not playing instantly might actually
induce fabi you know to well to think
that he is on the top
i don't know i just i speculate all the
time on things and i'm often wrong but
no it's okay i will say this to your
point right obviously regardless of the
hype and the excitement we see a novelty
on the board we know we're in for a
fight this is what we pay for
white is still fine like objectively the
computer says the device should be fine
here and again probably rookie 2 or rook
f1 are both playable this idea of d4 is
certainly a thematic way to change the
structure and block the bishop if yohan
figures it out it's not like he's losing
here but but it's still very scary but
should like or can we try to play d4
immediately by the way
well it certainly probably has more
value after queen f6 because the queen
is awkwardly placed there and then we
can use the momentum and play d4 but
maybe d4 even here and then we'll look
at it d4
ed
and i mean i i think it might be a very
interesting move
it's just that the psychology of the
game there's no way jan pomnychi can can
dare play such a move right unless he's
prepared to
to his teeth and right now there are no
teeth showing on yon napomnyachi if
anything he
seems component uh yeah whatever that
word is um and and not that uh spry
right maybe simply take here because you
see the diagonal is open bishop b2 maybe
we can sacrifice this one yeah i i kind
of like i mean i i don't even know
what's going to happen but i just want
to flip the script and go all in on a
gambit look at this i mean this is but
f2 is still hanging i'm really very f2
is but of course f7 and h8 would be
hanging for black and returned look at
the computer saying this is equal oh my
god you know what go bleep yourself
stockfish know what this is i i can't
even this is crazy
i i think you're right hammer i think
that regardless of whether he goes for
d4 or rookie 2 or rook f1
he probably is not sitting here across
from bobby thinking you know what i'm
gonna go for the sharpest thing i can
find because he clearly is surprised he
knows that fabi has prep here
he may not have a choice but to go for
something super spicy but i don't think
that's that is his first choice that's
exactly what i wanted to say is to say
unfortunately the uh like the character
of the position uh does not allow you
like to place something safe and that's
exactly why fabi is choosing this
variation
oh but on the other hand is there a more
scary thing
than yon napomnyachi on a winning streak
like we've been talking so much about
this guy being moody and and that he um
he when he first loses
it often follows another loss
um but also the reason he was the
challenger last time is because when he
wins
he wins not just once but twice and
three times so it's it's such an
interesting choice from fabiano putting
the maximum pressure
and yeah the the queen to f6 is on the
board and uh
i mean
napoleon she
this line hasn't been played
since the swedish open in
1895. apologies apologies they're
needing to lean in a little bit to uh to
read the chat um
but yeah i mean so
shout out to the featured chat there on
the person who did a little research
uh of course everything hammer just said
about nepo his style the things that uh
things that people know and love about
him are his streakiness and if he can
keep on it what would he be capable of
let's remind everybody of all the
wonderful things about yonda palmishi
and his path to madrid
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napomashi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
[Music]
2002 world under 10 champion ahead of
magnus carlson and that's where that
thing is from the record that's right
two-time russian champion the european
champion in 2010 a two-time silver
medalist janda pomeshi is uh he's got it
all in that look at the last line former
semi-pro dota player i want to make sure
that all of our fans watching whatever
whatever platform you may be tuning in
from
a lot of you might be dota fans and and
so is yonda pomeshi
right now he's uh not a fan of the fact
that he's been surprised by fabiano
carwana we see that almira's
right
nice albero's queen of six played on the
board and uh bobby taking another walk
hammer
yeah no i mean why would he sit there
and use his energy right now
he's in his prep and and walking away
from the table is also a way for chess
players to you know establish a bit of
dominance he's like i know you're going
to have to think about it a little bit
yeah
i don't need to be here i'll let you sit
thinking here for for quite some time
and i i think that's also what we have
to expect at this stage yana pomnyachi
uh falling into some very scary
preparation from fabiano caruana and
yeah he he's gonna
i mean if i'm yan naponnachi here i'm
already looking for like bailouts
possibilities to just clarify the
position to a draw because i won the
first round with the black pieces i'm
happy with my current standing
and i don't want to be blown away from
the board uh without
fabiano having to think about a single
move just repeating the uh engine's
suggestions
no i don't think anybody wants to be
blown away from the board
oh we've got
remember how danny said expect the game
to not be as spicy as everybody wants um
indeed remember how chat never remembers
the rare times i'm right it always
remembers when i'm wrong
help mira
let's change the subject i think that uh
before jan uh finds uh the most precise
continuation in this position we should
just give uh like an overview yeah
yeah let's let's head over to our bird's
eye view to make sure because this game
is clearly going to get a lot of
attention we knew it was coming in
because it is the matchup between the
two early leaders
but there there are four games in
progress of course you can go directly
to chess.com as you should and just
follow all the games and keep our
commentary in the background
again that italian with a5 between duda
and dingley ran a completely different
looking type of italian um where do you
want to jump to well let's jump let's do
a quick run through all three other
games because i know we're going to be
spending a lot of time here uh report
fellowship okay so it's a very important
route it's a birthday boy
okay here we go was it the bishop b5 i
know it's even queen d4 first okay
those are the openings of my childhood
well we're gonna have a look at the
d4 cd4 queen d4 let's do it we had a
queen d4 sicilian that's not an that's
not an early day opening we don't see
that every day at the top level
bishop to v5 and they change on c6 and
again the typical reason you you
normally take with the knight is these
are all the mainline sicilians you would
see putting minor pieces in the center
to control the game is usually what you
do why because the queen tends to get
kicked around when she's out there too
early playing with the kids that means
white has to part ways with the bishop
pair if you want to keep the queen there
otherwise you got problems
and you get this very interesting
imbalance in this in this particular
line of the sicilian because white has a
big center a moroxy bind structure to go
with it clamping down on important
central breaks but white has lost time
with the queen and lost the bishop pair
in order to get here hammer do you
remember who else had this maroxy pawn
structure those two white pawns
controlling in towards the center it was
the game of rickard rapport uh only he
had the black pieces i feel like this
situation is very similar to what
rapport played yesterday now we remember
what duda played yesterday and then
would rapport played as black
it's the same thing oh okay so i wasn't
mean to correct you i was just clear
playing okay i love you um so um
so i'm thinking
that well rapport he wasn't very happy
with how the opening went last time he
got in major trouble
against the polish player and now he's
kind of reversing it and saying well i
kind of like this way of playing i liked
how the pawns were positioned i'm gonna
play this way myself now that i have
some experience from from yesterday and
i just wanna as a sicilian player myself
i i
i wanted to highlight the big difference
here for black is that once you've
committed the e-pawn in a sicilian
rarely can you fee and kill that bishop
and not regret it later because of what
would be weak on d6 so it's an
interesting maneuver to not do what you
might often see here with the bishop
this knight is trying to get ahead of
the game to the king side
one because you have this pawn on e5
potentially allowing the f4 square to be
available but also because you no longer
want g6 anyway this bishop will be
naturally developed to e7 where it
defends your only real weak peska on the
open file and that allows black just be
safe get out of the center and maybe
even play for a move like f5 as you
generally want to attack in the
direction of your pawn structure so
something like this if we're just one
enjoying the coloring on the board and
two thinking about what exactly is
black's playing with
that you always have to highlight
whenever someone chooses to make two
moves with a piece rather than just one
natural looking development move what
exactly it is they're trying to achieve
there
well first of all i wanted to say that
i've played this position numerous times
with white so uh it's actually uh leads
to two positions which are not so easy
to understand like for especially for
the players who who use the open system
and so i suppose that richard didn't
want to go for the neither first of all
so it was a very uh smart move to avoid
also a very sharp line
and to bring it to the positions that he
feels maybe a bit better
so here
well the first thing that comes to mind
that i really want to
get to the same structure like yesterday
so i want to play c5 you know if given
an opportunity then if
queen f5 doesn't work then
this move is really possible you should
that's the first move you should
consider in this position in order to
break this structure so does it work
it's a it's a really good question you
want to see if it works right now yes i
really want to try it because uh young
ludwig pointed out that for example
queen a5 didn't
work yesterday because like
you could uh your pieces were getting so
active i'm not sure like maybe knights
maybe knight d2 in the knight c4 like i
don't like what is the possibility here
does this work yeah
g6 is a thread
bishop e3 is coming next and then might
be six maybe but uh
this should be
uh
but maybe i can just push like how one
of my i give my phone back favorite
scientists would say that this requires
a delicate piece of analysis but
i like to just say and the position is
unclear which is the lazy man's version
of saying i have no idea what's going on
here position remains unclear you should
always stay elegant you know in the way
you
express it's funny because that the
unclear symbol itself in chess for those
who read chess notation is this the
sideways infinity symbol right kind of
the game goes on and there were many
famous stories where people would end
their analysis with an unclear symbol
even though they knew they knew what it
was but they didn't want to reveal all
their analysis and the informant there
were some players who were who were
particularly known for doing this right
for ending the analysis early even
though they had the answer
yeah i'm sorry so i'm a bit afraid like
we were um highlighting all of the plans
in this position so if you don't seize
this
uh moment to play c5 then after if after
knight g6 i think um the position
will remain very unclear right
so no it's a great point that this is
this is maybe the critical decision that
rapport is uh thinking about right now
because if we let black do all those
things that i was coloring about and f5
has achieved black is in great shape
black has the bishop here the light
square bishop the white lax is is going
to lead to great things on the king side
so so probably white has to make
something happen to try to undermine
this structure sooner rather than
later okay
let's let's uh i i'm sitting here inside
i just want to get back to the nepam
nishi karwana game so that means let's
go back to our bird's eye view and check
in with the other four games again so we
can quickly
uh pay off some debt and look at look at
uh i want to check in with hikaru
nakamura and teamwork off as soon as we
can because uh i'm sure many of the fans
want to know that so we're just going to
jump right over there
ooh this is uh this is funny
nakamura rajab has this
we have this game reversed
because uh timora java wanted to play
the berlin defense yeah and he was like
yes he declined like fabiana yesterday
d3
was played it's exactly the same opening
bishop c5 on the hikaru he didn't go for
the structure with bishop c6 uh he went
for another line like knight bd2
and the very rare continuation knight d4
yeah this knight d4 line breaks so many
principles you move a piece twice in the
opening and then you're gonna have to
move your bishop a couple more times to
go with it
but what's what's the main idea what how
is black able to justify such a loss of
time for his development hammer um it's
because the the knight on c6
um before it moved forward in the center
um this night is is one of um black's
main issues in this rui lopez spanish
opening because white will very often
play the move c3
uh which effectively shuts down
uh the knights possibilities uh forward
um and that's why when you get the
chance
to make the trade you want to do that
and it's actually connected with some uh
tricky tricky moves
because when you play a knight to d5
like hijab did
after the trade
hikaru did have the option here of
playing the moon knight f3
and this knight move attacks the bishop
trying to win the bishop pair which is
considered an advantage
and if the bishop runs away the knight
can take the pawn in the middle instead
and then what was discovered about this
situation
uh okay apparently i'm wrong again
apparently queen e7 is a stunning move
uh but the point i wanted to make is
that the position after castles
i just wanted to show the main thing is
that if this happens black has things
like d5 and even lightning before this
question
before it was a piece
um
lol
so yeah apparently that's just brilliant
from black but you can also play there's
a similar line yeah uh where you as
black just sacrifice that pawn in the
center to just get really quick
development like for instance if uh
white hair castles yeah and then black
castles
a white can take the pawn in the middle
but then pawn to d5 yeah and and black
gets the initiative
by having some some early threats
despite giving away a pump and some
awkwardly placed pieces for white right
there's weird tactics when your pieces
are undefended on the fifth rank you can
tell the computer likes a position when
it's equal and you're down a pawn so
yeah really uh well said there he caro
as we as we pointed out though did not
play knight f3 he played c3 and has now
played a very aggressive pawn push
himself
with the move
d4 uh all right we got to dive into what
d4 is all about real quick though we
want to give a quick shout out to the
team from the other side of the block
the chess kid team is live here in
madrid with a very large staff and if
you're wondering what hiring a chess kid
coach would look like
you can wonder no longer we've hired our
own chess kid coach american feeding
master james canty to help level up your
game this summer there are free live
lessons at
chesskid.tv on a regular basis fridays
at 6 p.m eastern if you're looking to
tune in for some more candy content a
lot of people know the streamer
jameskanti on chess.com maybe you've got
kids nieces nephews grandkids who knows
tune in at 6 p.m on fridays for some
chess kid free lessons so all right
let's get back to this game here
what were you going to say hammer about
d4 yeah no the most interesting thing
about this position is the fact that
hikaru has spent no time
in rajabo already spending
close to half an hour so
rajabo just uh
looking
poorly prepared in this line i do
believe this has all been played many
times previously uh which means that a
player at jabba's level uh he should not
be out of book he should not be out of
his his openings here uh so i'm i'm very
surprised by that
uh and um that tells me he's in for uh
for a tough game okay so maybe one
prediction i made that car might win and
bounce back could be could prove true
any other
well first of all i i really like
hikaru's position and he's using one of
like most typical ideas to break through
in the center d4 he sacrificed the pawn
and then edie for e5 is this
for for me is absolutely crashing yeah
we'll just we'll show a little more of
queen e7 you castle
you can't take the pawn because you lose
the queen
and
all kinds of all kinds of very very
dangerous tactics the one thing that i
wanted also uh to share with you is that
uh of course when you can sleep like i
was wondering all over the internet and
i saw that hikar actually did like
quite an extensive analysis of his
yesterday's game which he shared it with
his community
and i just find it absolutely incredibly
so the player who is playing the
candidates uh takes his time
uh probably it also maybe helps him
grieve you know and so just start
it's a healthy process but
[Music]
as a professional chess player just
it's i'm really admirative excellent
i'll give an additional shout out to it
because you brought it up that hikara
was also the only player who lost who
actually he offered to come onto the
show and uh we had a we had a lot going
on on day one and we had bobby coming on
so we didn't invite hikar but it was
also
admirable and very mature and like hey
like i know i lost but you guys want me
on the show and he ultimately of course
not only provided the content for his
fans but like you said i think the
process is healthy to relive the the
game that way and so maybe it's why
hikaru is feeling fresh and ready for
another fight today so
uh so it's in your day it's a new day
like you said new tournament all right
well there's only one other game we
haven't checked on and that is dingley
wren and john christoph duda
just just quickly
quickly looking at our bird's eye view
reminder all four games in progress we
know that you will sometimes want to
follow a game more closely than we have
it we can't follow all four games at
once
so uh quickly quickly we're going to go
over here to
jkd
the polish with three names people say
the frenchman with three names with mbl
but no one
maybe maybe jkd sounds too much like
jean-claude van damme
now the french how's your jean-claude
damn um impersonation
you have to take me to the airport
i'm not sure i've watched any of these
okay have you ever seen bloodsport yeah
okay well we have some educating to do
um okay we have a very different looking
italian black with the bishop pair and
this is this is the position i feel like
we're used to seeing a lot of right
whatever happens on the queen side
black has this like long-term potential
maybe to do things over here uh i feel
like i see grisham play these positions
as black and as white and caruana as
well regularly but
what jumps out to you about this
particular battle here hammer eight
pawns for each player
uh the more pawns you have on the board
uh the more
complex the position in my opinion
and notice how
uh young christoph duda he has chosen to
give away one of his bishops
for one of the black knights and we
touched upon this yesterday that um when
uh there's a trade of knight versus
bishop the two pieces are considered to
be about the same volume but they have
two very different
uh functionalities on the board and uh
in general bishops are worse the more
pawns are on the board because then
pawns will often stand in the way of the
bishop's diagonals
and i think young christoph duda has
this very long-term strategy
where he feels that he's gonna have an
advantage uh just on account of the uh
black bishops uh being unable to put a
real mark on the game
i like that that sets the tone
for maybe even some later later
breakdowns of night versus bishop
imbalances but right now i want to i
want to draw attention to a different
type of
breakdown you guys notice anything about
this dynamic of jkd versus dingley red
not on the board
the chair
apparently the i don't know whether it's
just the you know superstition of having
lost in a chair or whether he was just
genuinely uncomfortable but apparently
uh dingley wren requested a smaller
chair from
fide and he was granted it your thoughts
almira well first of all during the
second leg of the last candidates it was
all about the chairs it seemed that the
players have chosen like everyone has
chosen a different chair yeah so like
when you were having an image like we
were
calling the tournament eight chairs at
the end so uh i think once again you you
have to feel as comfortable as you as
you can get like so uh
i agree that he needs to
if he needs a new chair and also that
beat
yeah i mean i uh
i i understand fully wanting to get a
different chair whether it was like no
matter what the reasons would be and
it's funny i you talk about the
candidates last time had all the all the
talk about the chairs i personally think
that
gaming and chair company not just gaming
chair companies but may you know
whatever office brand companies are
missing the opportunity i literally
don't understand why they don't go out
of their way to put more i mean there's
a lot of visibility you get a lot of
conversation going especially if the
chair has flare hey that rhymed i mean
if the chair had flare people are going
to talk about how it looks so and i
think uh
maybe in the future we'll see more
interesting expressions right of of
flair via the chairs that the players
choose so funny
there's caruana by the way
by the way i wanted to ask you how would
you feel playing in such a beautiful
hall because i know that like how
sensitive i am especially like to any
form of art so i literally would be
staring at the ceilings all the time so
you know
i
it would be amazing i actually think
that the uh the location has has more
than delivered i've never played i
played in a lot of hotel ballrooms like
every other chess player right you get
you get to know those very big kind of
the patterns of the carpet when you're
in ballrooms and whatever but playing in
a venue like this where the beautiful
things to look at are up and not just
some sort of you know office office
ceiling or or lighting a chandelier in a
hotel that gets old very quickly
um i would love it i don't know i mean i
i'm a bit of an 80d like squirrel
squirrel you know so i would love it in
fact it might be really bad for my chest
as if i needed more problems well i i
suspect that it would be for mine as
well so
[Music]
we've got a fun little comment here i
prefer to blame the mouse but i
understand
how that doesn't work for otb agreed i a
lot of us like to blame the mouse when
uh when we make bad moves but there's no
real no real such thing as a mouse slip
over the board
i don't think anyway
what would be a mel slip equivalent like
you put the piece on a wrong square and
then when you set it up you accidentally
put it on a different square no actually
it happened to me several times it's uh
when you make a second move of the
variation i would say that if we can
drive a parallel it's like you calculate
for such a long time and literally you
start with the second move and then
you're looking at the position and this
is like i have i have done that as well
especially in like a capture moment
where you're like calculating like
multiple like ways to like ways to
recapture and then you just literally
mess up the move order i've done that
before too yeah so apparently it can
happen okay interesting
all right well um there's a there's the
playing hall from a broader view half of
the players uh is missing
half of the players are missing uh and
on that note uh we're gonna we're gonna
take take a cue from our elite eight
players to uh to take a very very quick
break our first break chess.com's
coverage of the 2022 feed a candidates
round two live from madrid continues
when we return
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of
the retiro the retiro is
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a maybe best one in
madrid
foreign
punto
[Music]
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believes nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese american
grand master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix the unexpected victory earned
him a bid into the candidates for the
first time in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
the candidates is grueling the winner
requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
light queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
we are back
here in madrid getting a nice a nice
aerial shot aerial view of young
christophe duda and richard rapport as
they play their their respective matches
here in round two of the 2022 feed a
candidates this is chess.com coverage
it's happening live in madrid
richard rapport is focused with me here
in studio
is of course
almera and hammer
and i think
amira stop it's hammer time
what it's hammer time oh i you want me
up and and running stop
it's hammer time okay well we're gonna
we're gonna quickly get into the we
gotta go back to yonder palm mushy and
caruana
but
you wanted to show something from
ravport in perugia
so i'm pulling up that particular game
first
we've seen several moves going along you
want to break down this position or you
wanted to talk about
i wanted to talk about something a bit
more general okay i wanted to talk about
why the sicilian defense is the choice
of aggressive players okay and in order
to do that i'm gonna have to step over
to our uh special area let's go for it
go for it it's hammer time hammer time
stop it's hammered no one i mean you
know because he's he's dope on the flow
and he's magic on the mic he's hammer
time let's go okay so this is the the
rockport versus uh oliveressa game in
which alibraza showcasing his aggression
for the second time with the black
pieces playing the sicilian opening now
this opening has a reputation for being
very very aggressive and unbalanced and
i'm gonna try to explain why that is uh
and it is because uh as the moves come
on the board the night developing and
the pawn stepping forward uh once um
it's really all about
the discovery that was made that the
only way white can put real intense
pressure on black
is by playing the move uh d4
which rapport did
now after that d4 move what happens is a
trade between the pawns after which what
is very important to note is that white
has one pawn in the center
whereas oh yeah i'm
touchscreens are not my friends just yet
danny so white has one
white has one pawn in the center whereas
black has two
and this central uh superiority is
basically the whole idea of the sicilian
the uh that's the pro for black but the
con is that
um after some more moves we will notice
how in this position
um we have a situation where black still
has these two pawns in the middle versus
whites well versus whites one or rather
two white pawns against the three for
black however
um
this comes at a cost for black because
black hasn't got any pieces into play
and so the sicilian is very much an
opening that is all about the uh
kind of unbalance between having good
central control with your pawns and
getting your pieces out quickly and we
can see as the game progressed uh here
with the white pieces uh rapport uh he
plays the move c5 and so he's trying to
make a trade with his pawn in towards
the middle uh and after that trade was
made
the situation is like this that both
players
have uh one pawn each in the center so
um
alireza perugia tried to make it
imbalanced uh but uh with the white
pieces uh rickard rapport
he equalized that situation with the
pawns and he's now trying to exploit the
fact that black has two isolated pawns
on the queen side
good stuff and you know it's also
something that we should note is the
same structure
that we had yesterday that ravport was
playing with black as as almira's c5 was
played on the board
and
predicted well not met with queen a5 as
we've kind of now learned several times
in this position that while that pawn
looks tasty black doesn't seem to really
be able to afford it right too much too
much can be lost there and so we get the
same structure we had yesterday white's
advantage is
teeny i guess if you talk about just the
positional aspects of these pawns being
split as targets but black is doing just
fine on development you have the f4
square
elmira it looks like your prediction of
c5 was uh was a good one do we even see
it well there is only one slight
difference compared to the yesterday's
game it's just that uh
uh
alireza has a well a worse structure but
which is compensated here by two bishops
right that's i think it's the main
difference
yeah so black is worse positionally but
has the two bishops
is i guess
slightly ahead in development in a weird
way it's equal as both sides have a
minor on the for on the first and eighth
rank respectively and both sides kings
are yet to castle but feels like black's
a little bit ahead just because of how
quickly the bishop is sort of already in
the game okay well this will be an equal
one it's not necessarily uh
as sharper but one is what we're seeing
in the other the other feature game we
see a tired was he out late last night
partying on his birthday
okay maybe he was preparing you know
that's my my guess more likely preparing
than partying uh would would be ollie
rosa perugia for sure but okay when i
was his age i was preparing to waiting
since in the morning you know it's just
like stay up all night preparing for a
game in the morning yes yes like when i
was playing competitively like just i
couldn't sleep so yeah how did that go
for you i was gonna say that
uh i i think i valued sleep way too much
and just hearing the balance of how i
valued it i valued sleep way too much
more than the chest perhaps well i know
how important it is now that well then i
just well
all i was like
giant mind which was racing all the time
so yeah
yeah but this is a very important point
almira brings up because there was a
period of time where i started
i stopped preparing for my game the day
before because i thought if i prepared
something
i'm not going to be able to sleep as
well because i'm only going to be
thinking about
all the lines i have been investigating
and what i think is going to happen uh
the day after so uh there was a portion
of time where i just decided i don't
want to know my next opponent uh because
i don't want to disrupt my sleep and i
think chess players have really
uh come to understand
uh these
um
well healthy body healthy mind kind of
things yeah that um for instance magnus
carlsen he sleeps for very long during
the morning
because he doesn't want to get up
to um
way too early before the game
because he believes that kind of his
mind functions the best
uh a couple of hours after waking up
like 10 hours that's interesting well we
know he's uh he's young and uh creative
and i'm sure
i'm sure that yawn was because he was
preparing not partying even though it is
his birthday uh but because it's his
birthday i think it's
appropriate that we make a quick call
and uh and show people just just how
young is he we always say it
here you can see that uh
he is the third youngest player to ever
compete in the candidates magnus carlson
and bobby fischer the only two that uh
accomplished that feat at a younger age
18 years and 11 months the official sort
of benchmark of when the term started of
course as we know he turns 19 years of
age today
two days in but still
what a career
this this young man has ahead regardless
of what happens in madrid but but
certainly certainly an impressive feat
that he's even here so well we were
talking about bobby fischer and uh there
is
certainly reminds us of bobby fischer
even
well his attitude uh during the game his
determination
and
how would you like there is a word that
we use in french ampris it's like the
whole the game has on you
you know he is like when he plays the
game sometimes they look at him and he
enters the state of trance almost you
know this is uh
not many people like and players they
can get to this kind of concentration
yeah
no it's true it's an obsession you can
see it right it's it's a
focus and and passion now he's uh he's
creative and a lot of fun to watch i
really like your kasparov image uh yeah
i was gonna say i i think i actually saw
an early version of the image and i made
a shout out to the team to uh to say hey
maybe could we find a smiling gary but
maybe they couldn't find a smiling gary
so i also feel like his hand up on his
neck
it looks like an extension of his neck i
know it's uh it's definitely that's
that's angry gary right although to be
fair
gary's reputation you know and how
intimidating he was at the board
definitely was a was a big part of of
the storyline that followed him during
his career right so you know maybe it
maybe it's appropriate we should
probably make that face an emote on our
channel instead of instead of finding a
smiling gary but okay we're gonna back
out um and uh switch things over to
the the featured
game of the round if you will
sort of an unofficial dubbing that we
that we call the uh the most critical
game nippon machine versus caruana as
it's a battle between the two leaders
let's refresh and show everybody how we
got here because we left the game after
queen f6 had been played from caruana we
can already see by the way just before
we even dive in let's set the stage for
what's happening here
bobby has more time than he started with
by a lot
or no no no increment but he's only used
six minutes i'm sorry i was thinking of
the ninety percent no no he's but still
he has a ton of time
yana's yawn is almost
down to an hour right and this is the
opposite of how we normally see these
two players play so it shows you how
well prepared favi is for this game
jan played the move queenie one to
defend f2 a second time
the queen goes to g7 again if we just
look at the time stamps of this game
hammer and elmira favi has spent zero
time so this is still very clearly
preparation for him the knight comes to
f1 black castles taking a take in a note
from hikara nakamura's book that just
because you play h6 and g5 doesn't mean
you can't put your king on the king's
side knight to g3
knight to e7
making sure that f5 remains protected
just doubly rookie 2 queen one that's
it's yeah it's very strange well no it's
just that you do not see this very often
you know yeah
so
this position is really very interesting
now d4 comes
what a move from nepam nyanchi knowing
he's facing his opponent's preparation
yeah and he still goes ahead
and makes a sacrifice of a pawn in the
center of the board uh so yeah i mean
it's not too strange that he spent so
much time to get here yeah because he
had to build the courage uh to to really
uh put the pressure on black uh in a
position where he had to assume that he
was still in kirana's uh home
preparation it should be noted this was
the first move that really caused
caruana to do anything but physically
come back to the board it was 15 seconds
on a move 16 seconds 16 seconds 25
seconds these are basically the time for
bobby to walk back this move caused
bobby to pause for a minute and 57
seconds so still not a lot of time but
it was the first move in the game this
d4 shot that forced bobby to check
himself he did capture and now brings
the knight back to c6 which is that i
like to call that's like heavyweight
boxers and footwork right you bring the
knight to e7 once the structure changes
and you have a new target no problem
shuffling the pony right back to where
it was
to overwhelm the d4 pawn well it's
actually a very typical maneuver i
wanted to draw your attention to this
and once white played d4
then even if you're losing a tempe
you're you're going back to c6 and uh
now you have to solve the
problem
of how to protect the d4 pawn bishop b2
for me it's an is a natural move but the
problem is black has put three pieces
pointing in uh against this central pawn
whereas white only had one piece
defending it so even if white does use
the bishop to offer
additional defensive uh possibilities
fabiano can still win upon by just
capturing in the center of course but i
feel this is one of those positions once
again that when you sacrifice upon for a
long term initiative look at the squares
f5 and h5 yeah
so
i don't know um
just just i just want to get the in line
to just show like what elmer's talking
about you have f5 you have h5 you have
pawns that can't go back we always joke
about that that bug on chess.com because
the best move for black when you won a
pawn is probably g5 to g7 this is the
best move on the board right but you
can't play it and white will have
long-term compensation here for
for a very long time of course and here
when you exchange this dark square
bishops you no longer have this tension
on well
on f2
and it's very important so
the files are open for white stroke as
well so it's a very important factor as
well when you assess the position so
here i would
prefer white actually it's uh
i don't know what computers prefer here
uh i bet hamer prefers black but i do
prefer black danny and i i have a reason
for it okay
you know just don't mind if you do then
go ahead uh so in this variation uh
where white tries to defend the pawn on
d4 but fails okay
uh i'm gonna be up a pawn
but after that
i'm going to have this amazing square
for my queen on e5
this square
is fantastic because there are no white
pieces who are really in a position to
kick the black queen away from there
anytime soon
and then i will try following up with
the moves h5 h4
and i'm going to use this pawn to chase
away the white defensive knight so that
the knight has to step back and then you
can talk to me about all these squares
that knight is isn't looking for
because i was sassed today i succeeded
chasing it
that's a great point not very often we
talk about a queen on an outpost square
right and so that that's already by
itself kind of a cool feature
and before you even mention h5h4 i was i
was i was highlighting this
i didn't see it it's a great idea but i
was highlighting it just to show like
what you're saying that the knight now
can't access either of these squares
because of the sort of the x-ray vision
that the queen spies to the h2 pawn so
well you can still play h3 because you
have knight f1 just in case i mean
you should always
well
remember that you have a lot of
defensive resources no matter what and
uh
but
yeah that's so it's a valid point of
course uh
well and the main thing i would i guess
i would add is that while fabi did take
a moment on on e takes d4s we said a
moment was a minute and 57 seconds right
wow tons of time that was the first time
he had thought he still then played
instantly on the next move right um
sorry he took he took a moment on e
takes d4 and then played instantly with
knight c6 so
still in preparation or at least a
position he's familiar with right that's
that's likely a conclusion we can draw
there's certainly very nice features but
like how are you seeing all this
i mean
i need new glasses actually i could not
see anything you know i got lasik at
some point it really helped my eyes i'm
not kidding it burned for like a whole
day it was like someone puts shampoo in
your eyes and you can't get it out for
like a day and so it just hurts but i
got lacing and it proves
your vision is significantly useful i
didn't know i would need it to read time
stamps on a monitor 15 feet away that
are really small but it's helpful all
right there's
uh yonda pandashi doesn't need 20 20
vision to see what's in front of him
right there the chessboard is close and
he knows he has a lot of work to do
today if you're just tuning in where
have you been this is round two of the
2022 feed of candidates that's one of
the tournament leaders right there let's
back up to our bird's eye view remind
everybody that four games are in
progress
and uh
not not quite the fire on board
guys that we had in day one but still
every game interesting right it felt
like yesterday we were at one point on
pace for four decisive results like
seriously um
the two games that ended in a draw had a
huge advantage for for the po the polish
player duda and of course ali raza
farouja's exchange sacrifice was was
head turning
but these games are interesting a lot of
life here
you know i had
a thought which well has nothing to do
like uh
with the positional strategy but
more psychological finesse
maybe
i don't know who is uh coaching uh
firuja is this tournament nobody does
one and nobody does so you don't have
but maybe it was suggested to him that
uh richard
doesn't like to trade queens because it
was such a surprise for me that also
valeria traded queens you know at uh
such an early stage
so uh i find that
is it is it really true that players of
the 2750 plus level would have a
stylistic
not necessarily issue or preference of
like that really like i'm not sure but
we could establish a pattern i think
they they of course they're universal
players but maybe there was something
maybe like a slight uh you know hint
right i don't know because especially if
you're using you know
thank you
well let me ask you you were a second
for magnus for two world championship
matches you've been in the room where it
happens so to speak shout out to aaron
burr
does that is that a thing you talk about
that i mean there's preparation in the
opening we know there's preparation you
do just in general to be get your mind
right and your body right but are there
stylistic preparations against a player
like hey he doesn't like when the queens
are traded yes no
um
but this is also because magnus is
incredibly good at being opinionated and
like having these thoughts on what a
player is good at and what a player is
bad at and magnus also shouted out gary
kasparov once
because he thought kasparov had some
really good insights into basili
evanchuk
magnus had always assumed that ivan
chuk's erratic
opening style and that he was just able
to play uh anything uh kasparov when
working with magnus
had made a point uh of some detail i
don't know what that detail was but
there was something kasparov said which
made magnus think that there is a system
to evan chuck's madness so you can you
can have these opinions yourself but you
can also learn from your elders and like
kasparov played against evancho for two
decades so uh that's fascinating i mean
trading queens is uh
not something we're going to see soon in
this game here with napomneshi and
carwana in fact we we do have a move
though rook to a3 and fabi rushes back
to the board hammer it's hammer time not
not that hammer time but it's hammer
time what do you got well i guess he
thought that because fabiano was
threatening the pawn in the middle with
three pieces
and white only had one defender uh
napoleon must have felt that well i'm
going to lose this pawn regardless i'm
not interested in defending it which
will only lead to further
trades of pieces
so instead he's trying to uh
do one of these rook lifts where the
rook goes up the board on one side and
tries to go all the way over to the
other side
in due time and and thereby increasing
the pressure against an already
vulnerable
black king
i like that what do you say to the
psychology elmira of like hammer said he
knows he's going to lose the pawn anyway
so why put more effort into it let's
position our pieces for the long-term
compensation we know we're going to need
well
these lateral moves lateral rooks
moves they always escape my eye and well
i understand of course that he wants to
bring it in long-term to f3 and you know
to increase the pressure on f7
but uh you will always have well you
will keep one of the knights so it could
always go to e5 you know that's uh
that's my competition
gonna have his work cut out for him now
to uh show what his prep was all about
we expect him to be thinking for just a
minute here and so on that note we're
gonna take a minute and bring up yet
another one of our player profile
spotlights and remind you all the things
you did or didn't know about the highest
rated player from the united states
fabiano caruana stands as a pretty
popular choice for winning it all here
in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
uh
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played
played very well
soon to be 30 caruana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 2844 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
[Music]
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vichy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
i'd say
that's a really interesting stat there
from danya that he would be the first
player since vishyanan to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years he's
a four-time italian champion 2016 u.s
champion the singfield cup is again the
tournament that will always be mentioned
because it was the performance of a
legend there in st louis
uh of course he's the grand swiss
runner-up which is how he got here
and as is often pointed out he's uh
the only person to have never lost a
classical world championship game to
magnus carlson um and uh he's the only
participant to play in three previous
candidates so
his career
is a fantastic one it uh it's one that
why so many people have him as the
favorite and here we have
a this is a now this is a great comment
i was there when fabi made it in person
this is from greenman rd bobby mentioned
during the world championship coverage
so glad you were tuning in that he looks
for positions that give his opponent a
slight edge but are very tricky to
navigate he feels feels like we're
seeing this thought process prominently
here today meaning green man rde feels
like we're seeing it i think so i don't
know if you i find if you saw that
comment from fabi but we asked we got as
much as we could out of him me and has
about how he prepared and he said one of
the things that's very underrated is you
know that you know that chess is super
hard you know that you can't always
prepare a win with the engine right so
one of the trickiest things to do is to
go for a position that you hope that
their team stopped analyzing a little
early because they're like oh it's just
an edge right but you went a little
deeper knowing that it was an edge but
there are a lot of problems potentially
a lot of pitfalls right and that that is
maybe the most often place where you can
catch somebody off guard um in a line
where they have an advantage so
interesting
yeah i mean that is not new information
but it's really uh
i i mean fabia's breaking code here
you're not supposed to to talk about the
grand master club you're not supposed to
reveal all our secrets first rule about
the the chess club you always talk about
chess club no yeah
but yeah i mean this is a fantastic
point from fabiano and it is the way to
catch your opponent unaware right these
days you play something that the
computer is not recommending uh because
then there's a
smaller chance that your opponent has
spent time on just that uh variation
no i'm i'm taking notes and answers
your thoughts on the fact that while
everything we just talked about in
regards to bobby's comment again great
comment from from the the chatter there
on twitch thank you for that
now he's thinking so is this thinking to
try to remember your preparation use the
clock as a weapon you have earned that
time advantage or do you think he
genuinely was surprised by rook a3
well i still think that he's
well within his preparation right uh but
maybe well here it's like you
go right you'll lose a knight you go
left you know that's a typical russian
you know glory story you know so uh it's
like
he has a choice probably and
maybe this choice is critical right here
right
and i think it's very important of
course to take a deep thought
and to consider
his options
is that a russian proverb you go right
you lose a knight what is that it's uh
it's uh
it's
it comes from russian uh folklore you
know where it was like actually it's a
russian warrior at some point he comes
to a crossroad right so and then it's
written on the scarf and a stone so okay
you go right you you lose your knight
you know you go left you know you lose
well depending on the story is something
more available so it's like what what
are you willing to sacrifice so
i love that
most
i guess the joke is they would they
would rather lose the more valuable
thing than the night is that the joke it
depends it depends
well um we'll see what fabi comes up
with like you said it's a critical
decision and uh
this stuff this game definitely had all
the makings of exactly that comment from
fabiano caruana
and again huge shout out to the twitch
chatter who put it out
we want to give a shout out to the
youth speed chess championship
the third annual chess kid usb chess
championship will feature eight of the
top youth players from around the world
and a series of blitz matches you can
catch all the action starting june 20th
at twitch.tv slash chess kid fun master
mike who's here in the building at the
palacio de santonia happy crocodile
women's grand master kenny
cetsalvasvili sorry about that and wfn
maria rodrigo um going to be a lot of
fun shout out to the kids at home
and uh let's give a shout out to all
four games in progress maybe make a
different decision about where to go
next we've been really focused on nepam
nishi karwana
well i think we should go to hikaru
because the thing about hikaru's game is
that it's very similar with his
countrymen karana in one respect
and that is the time usage uh we saw
fabiano karana now taking his uh time
for the first uh moment in this game uh
but that is also true
uh of um
rajabos opponent nakamura because even
though
um
this seems like a
you know not as tricky of a position as
fabiano's
it has quite a bit of venom
and that is underlined by the fact that
tamari rajaba feels that he might go
down to less
more than an hour behind hikaru
on this move
he's on pace to get there let's let's
show everybody where it where we left it
for those who may be tuned in a little
late hikaru was offered a berlin he took
took a page out of fabiano's book to
decline the berlin with d3 similar to
their game from yesterday but after
bishop c5 where fabiano played the move
bishop takes c6 against nakamura
hikaru plays a different line which
leads to this sort of rare looking
multiple minor piece move approach from
black d4 is played and this was the
first sign that we were smelling
something fishy because rajab in a
relatively well known position took a
lot of time before playing c6 which is
the most common move by the way c6 is
the most common move but but the fact
that he took so much time was the odd
thing
d takes e5 cb5 he takes f6 queen f6
these moves were played instantly
literally instantly by hikaru
after castles castles and then queen h5
you know you just immediately spot the
structure right
bad pawn which leads to an undeveloped
bishop doubled pawns which means this
bishop isn't getting out here
i love white's position here i'm
surprised the computer doesn't give
white more of an edge it feels like such
a tough position for black to play but
then going back to fabiano's comment
during the world championship that's
what a hikaru has managed
here that he chose online that the
computers didn't initially think were
very good for white
but as it transpires yeah uh rajab is
coming under increasing pressure
and now a big move from him he's moving
his pawn forward in the middle just
giving that pawn up
and rajaba is going to be down upon here
well actually i expected this move from
timur because
this is so much
in his style sacrificing nepal he has
two bishops and he
does not want to commit himself to a
passive defense right
d6
could be considered but
so
it's not in his like uh
style once again so d5
by the way i think it might just
immediately yes so knight g5 of course
uh simply wins so but you're right it's
to play d5
okay
and uh
say more about why you expected it so
it's an active move obviously
you want you get your only real
advantage in the position as black as
the bishop in the game but a pawn is a
pawn right i mean what if icono just
takes it well he takes it so we trade
queens then probably takes only one i
think and then he develops his bishop to
f5 let's say is it a possible
continuation
and then rook d8 and try to win the pawn
back or
in the worst case scenario
maybe exchange the the wrong bishop so
we get to the opposite color bishop and
games sort of
uh
how would uh young would we call it the
bailout yes
yes
taking notes
there's a bailout but a moment ago we
saw hikaru number 12 the rare duck lips
where he kind of lowers his lip and kind
of like is
not really
not really thinking that his opponent's
plan is very good
oh really is that broken down in the
video to come soon yeah
i do but i mean you previewed this video
so much now danny i feel like it's time
to release
crack it will it will it will come don't
worry
um
we've got a lot of spoilers a lot of
spoilers a lot of spoilers but no
seriously hikara very focused he's uh
primed here to use maybe the advantage
he he has on the clock as you pointed
out
almost an hour so he'll make he'll make
sure he makes the right decision i think
this will be very quickly a two result
position for recaro will will it
ultimately prove a victory that would be
a huge bounce-back
game
for the five-time u.s champion but um
but either way it'll be a position where
he's he's the only one who probably can
win i feel like it's also yeah unlike uh
it might very soon be a one position uh
one result
uh position meaning only higaro wins
no danny uh meaning that it's gonna be a
draw oh okay uh because i i do feel like
uh this end game down a pawn for rajab
it really resembles what is called the
martial end game
which is actually the spanish opening as
well
but a very different way there
and it's very typical for that opening
that black gives up a pawn to have an
unopposed light squared bishop which is
the same case here
and so i'm curious to see
whether hikaru will be able to to pile
on the pressure or whether it will just
peter out pretty quickly because
here in this line you have um oh it's
not on the screen but the the line danny
is uh is analyzing now if we can put
that on the screen
the white pawn on d5 the pawn in the
middle
is very exposed
and
it's very difficult for white to offer
that pawn sufficient protection and i
could easily see that pawn being lost uh
in the near future after which a rajab a
woman could make a draw with an equal
number of pawns so um right now like you
said danny a two result game but hikaru
needs to be extremely accurate to make
sure that his initiative doesn't fade in
the next five moves
i actually had the same feeling but i
wanted to mention
another possible continuation uh after
queen d5 here is it possible for black
to play uh queen g6 just to keep the
queens on board and
g6 yes screen g6
well i see the bar like so it means the
computer doesn't like uh i wanted to
play uh bishop b6 or bishop h3 but
probably this is not sufficient
compensation well i i want to suggest
the move uh queen takes beef i was going
to say it might just be that you're
giving
the second point
a mistake that only danny could make
but we could start with bishop h3 first
ah queen g5 that's what you wanted okay
yes i think that's a very yeah if you go
here then queen g5 and white is actually
up two pawns now
okay
of course so the yeah well then you
cannot keep the queens on the board so
unfortunately okay it was it was a good
line and instructive point about queen
takes d5 i hear you right it's it's
definitely a hard hard ending game to
prove how white can win when both bishop
e4 and rook dd8 are coming
as a chance to maybe win back the pawn
so
interesting quote here from hikara
nakamura
he says winning is fun losing is fun
playing interesting games with both
colors is what makes it worthwhile of
course just speaking about what it is to
play chess at a high level i think that
i think of all the top players hikaru i
think that that's i i saw a hammer kind
of smiling maybe like calling the bluff
that losing is fun i understand but i
think hikaru genuinely feels like he's
played so much chess he streams chess
all the time i would say that he's
developed a thick skin
for losing in front of a lot of people
it happens all the time right and so i
think he genuinely feels that i'm not
saying he wants to lose but i think that
that's an interesting comment and
probably how he feels really
well i do find it's it's first of all
it's
it's a very
sincere comment and i think that we had
this conversation uh a few days ago and
that's the point that i wanted to
explain that uh a chess player is always
identifying himself with his victories
or the games he's playing so it's not
it's all very concrete and it's the
world of ideas what i wanted to explain
that
very often at the lead levels we forget
what plane
is essentially you know the
i think the most important aspect of
playing is fun
so that's what i wanted to say also
about magnus i think that uh playing so
many world championship matches and
having so much at stake that it's
well he lost this feeling when well
you're simply on your plane and it's fun
no matter what so i think he's trying
actually
it's it's
pure wisdom i think from hikaru
interesting
i'm not sure he's he's genuine i think
all players to become the level they are
they have to hate losing so much that
they put in enormous amount of time
uh to to kind of avoid that by
practicing
but i will agree that
one of the most important skills once
you have reached that very high level is
the ability to deal with the losses yeah
and i think this speaks to ikaru who
frankly doesn't lose very often yeah
because he's he's just he's made winning
uh a regular occurrence on chess.com but
also elsewhere um
but
um being able to cope with those few
losses you do
encounter is is incredibly uh valuable
and and sometimes you don't even have to
believe what you're saying you just need
to have that psychology of yeah it's
okay i lost
it's okay there's another game yeah uh
coming in and actually this matchup is
going to be a very good illustration of
just that hikaru coming off
a tough loss um in the first round he's
now trying to bounce back and and having
that mentality may increase his chances
of getting back into it immediately they
say all the all the best players and
athletes have sort of short-term memory
loss in that sense right they're they're
so confident in what they're able to do
it's what got them there that they kind
of developed that ability to just focus
on the presence quickly forget the
mistakes they made they don't hold it
against themselves and the type of
attitude that allows them to bounce back
although you made an interesting comment
about
players they they want to win they hate
to lose kaidanov when i was working with
him for short periods said he could
define like the psychology and then a
full bullet point list of what that type
of players strengths and weaknesses were
based on one high-level comment which
was there are those who love to win and
those who hate to lose and that it's
actually a very different type of
mentality and attitude toward
prophylactic thinking versus you know
taking chances and recently we don't
have to get into that but it's an
interesting interesting psychology to
consider the style that a player
develops based on the joy that the
thrill they have of the kill versus the
absolute just how much they despise
losing and and i think we have a lot of
uh those uh who love to win in this
tournament
based on how much aggression you've seen
in the first two rounds but do you
remember like yesterday fabiano shared
us
all his insights and the first thing
that he said i do not allow myself to
get too excited
this says a lot you know about the
the mindset and like it's pure joy
winning you know but finally it comes
down to like to being relieved you know
so i think that uh just like in all
other sports you're allowed you know we
have a completely different ethics you
know so it's allowed to uh
well
to express it
that's that's a really great point i
mean like they win an nba game a single
game let alone like the finals and every
teammate you know
they scream and enjoy like they have
like a release right they they high-five
they hug it out right they sometimes
literally scream to the crowd right and
there's chess players aren't allowed to
do that right so there's a lack of like
emotional letdown that you experience
from from a victory that i feel like we
should do something about that go ahead
yeah because i i was i i know that
there's been uh some research in
handball which is very popular in norway
i don't think the u.s even knows what it
is i have no idea what you're talking
about
but in that it was discovered that teams
that massively celebrated goals and
there's like 30 goals for each team per
game
teams that really celebrated their goals
was doing better interesting just
because of like you know you're kind of
also saying to the opponent yes we're
the best we're gonna take you down i'm
not sure the endorphins
i mean there's a lot i'm sure there's
all kinds of studies that could be done
about that well and also i think that in
chess you well it's well fabby said and
it's a very elegant way of saying this
you're also um preserving your opponent
because you know you're still you have
14 games
so uh it's uh
i don't know maybe they are celebrating
in their rooms you know maybe they go
home
and you know i i don't know i can't
really see
like uh fabian and chuchulov like you
know hugging it out maybe they have a
whole secret handshake like boom boom
wouldn't that be hilarious that's the
next skit i'm gonna make bobby do him
and choo choo you have the power to do
that oh i could yeah probably
they'd probably do anything all right
let's back this thing up and take a look
but we are dancing the flamenco yes then
it's like they're doing the handshake
i'm going to tell fabi if he wins the
candidates we're doing a flamenco dance
that's it
there's uh
there's four four boards in front of you
oh they brought us they brought us back
yeah we'll do it so we'll do the
flamenco dance if if
with bobby that's the deal if you win so
let's let's head back and take a take a
peek at where all four games stand very
very little to no action in the rapport
for rougey game the queens have come off
the board and
those two young players who i think we
would all classify as players who love
to win
they're uh they're giving it a long
think
of course we've spent a lot of time on
napalm rishikarwana which has had some
things change
um and then this this this duda dingley
ring game i feel bad we're kind of
neglecting it the most but it's a very
very long positional struggle ahead in
that italian um with a very close
position there in the lower right corner
do you want to head back and take a look
at that hammer do we want to go over to
the uh the panda she harmonic game uh i
would say uh nepalniachi and karana
uh if only because i'm planning to look
at this ding versus uh do that game uh
on the monitor on the next hammer time
preview foreshadowing don't go anywhere
we're going to have some more breakdowns
of the positional battle of knights
versus bishops ahead all right what
happened here a couple of moves
carwana took
let's see about nine and a half minutes
on mu 17 knight takes d4 so the first
real think of the game occurred
uh right here someone standing in front
of our camera we love that first real
shout out to a nice looking suit of the
day knight takes d4 and after bishop
takes
h3 okay
95 and bishop a2
so the bishop was attacked moved away
uh jan de pomneichi just playing calmly
on down a pawn playing instantly too by
the way now yeah well he kind of has to
because he's way down on the clock and
we just got an interesting situation uh
in front of us
fabiano has chosen to play with
extreme risk
and he has a 30 minute time advantage
and a pawn advantage as well
but in the resulting position
does he like this outcome
and and will this suit him
better than jan pomnyachi who is kind of
the king of uh
messi
uh so um i'm very intrigued uh by the
the new developments
and i think this is going to be a tough
game for for both players both of them
trying to reach that two out of two
score to just dominate uh initially here
i'm trying to find out the point behind
rookie 3 very often you know when
computer
offers
you like an h4 move recently like almost
in every position and you don't
understand it initially and then
somewhere on the move 22 like you see
the point and i cannot make it work for
the moment
well i i think um had uh white's rook
still been in the corner
um the bishop could have taken it so i
feel like it's it's something as simple
as just
getting that rook away from uh
potentially being captured and then
secondarily uh hoping for to bring it up
over uh to an attack uh against the uh
the black king and i i think there's a
real certainty from sarcasm it knows
like it's a big bug theory you know
they're always bringing you know this
sarcasm card for for
children you know so like i spotted this
you know i have some of sheldon's
qualities you know
do you think do you think he's being
sarcastic of course
maybe there's a here's my version of the
attack i think the king moves
to unpin the pawn from f2
and on that note your son you're
actually maybe immediately threatening
f4 because after the captures you would
have knight h5 with a tempo on the queen
then you can recapture f4 with either
the bishop or the knight depending on
what black does and suddenly the g3
square is available so let me let me
just play some fantasy chess real quick
we'll make some random move and again
forget the eval bar here i'm just trying
to show that if nothing changes
suddenly a move like f4 in fact the
engine likes it right that's the idea is
that i'm very quickly
justifying what what did look like a
very awkward placement of my pieces into
a quick attack right because the g3
square is going to be a real problem so
the engine backing me up there feels
better than almost anything that has
happened to me while here in madrid i
actually really think that there's an
idea here especially because that shot
is is not something that black can do
anything about the g5 pawn can't run
away from this fate right and
you know the point mean is that the rook
can't move forward yes more useful than
on c1 or d1 that's like i because i was
feeling that it has to be on c1 and i in
the c7 pawn and open files but
here he wants to keep his dark square
bishop exactly maybe to sacrifice it's
at some point maybe that's something
like if knight f5 knight h6 is possible
then bishop g5 and rogue g3 this is
fantasy it's like all all in on
something like that
well i mean fabi's thinking again he's
earned the advantage on the clock he's
up a pawn and the computer's like black
and i i made those moves randomly of
course and he'll have to come up with
something but
the point is there is there is a future
where white's pieces look like they
planned it all along if black isn't
careful and i'm sure fabi
is aware of these these potential ideas
and if he makes a standard move uh like
uh for the italian we should be six
right okay this looks good let's try
yeah here we are for the trade
of course this transition i'm just gonna
make it i would assume it's good for
black because opening the file and then
over protecting the light squares can
only be good
so nepal would not do that
so how do you continue here
it's a good move it should be six
well what about your uh
king h1 danny
it's a simply king h1
i guess
i guess already at least now if you take
a2 i don't have well then i have knight
f5 then
ah okay yeah that's that's huge no no no
no no no
even even immediately maybe right inner
inner meso yeah of course you have to
guard the f5 square so how do you
continue here
at some point you have to start using
the majority i don't know what pawn
should come first i think you can maybe
make an argument for all three pawn
moves in fact
um
but like white's attack is coming on the
next move
like white's next move is pawn to f4 you
like it you like that idea yeah no i i i
ever do you want me to say it i'll just
say it out loud
say my name i like your idea
what is going on here
all right f4 f4 is coming and uh
and hammer likes it yeah no it's it's
really difficult to deal with for
fabiano if if he has to play a move like
knight g6 right now um knight h5 yes if
you wanted
i'm i'm not sure i was gonna think about
it then you get your favorite angles
just out here the queen is really uh
very vulnerable i like that move
actually because the queen is in a rare
case is the queen better on the outpost
square than a knight
in this position i guess so but maybe
you can start with knight f5
can you
okay i don't want to what's
okay i mean now the the white
rook and queen is making a lot of sense
this knight cannot be stationed here uh
without causing massive headaches for
black it has to be captured
immediately
but once that capture is made white
recaptures opening up for the rook down
the open file
opening up for the bishop
towards the black king and just really
releasing the energy in in white's
pieces and now i i still like this danny
i i think this is a great idea and
i think fabiano will be um
nervous
about satisfying lines in his uh
calculations yeah i think if you play
knight d5 there then uh your idea simply
smashes uh black f4 1995 f4
and i don't see even how
let's see that line again elmira on the
top so knight g6 magic six oh wait don't
be six first yes b should be six because
we want to release king age one the
pressure from the seventh and ninety six
knight to five yes and i don't know how
to react here bishop f5 is probably
forced of course
then you take and then knight
if knight e5 i wanted to show that your
idea like with f4 super strong yes it's
very strong and and now everything makes
sense that's how everything makes sense
like technically i think that john is
very sneaky in those because he has such
a good feel
for potential of an attack right i mean
everyone has known that about him for a
very long time he's a he's a very
intuitive player has a very good feel
for the danger in positions
bobby plays c5 and he uses the majority
he uses the majority which i think at
some point had to be black's plan and he
gets up to uh take a walk
and as jan returns we take a look at the
larger playing hall cam so that we can
take a walk it's going to be only our
our second break of the day don't worry
we will leave you with a view where you
have an eye on all four games of course
uh there is so much ahead here in round
two of the 2022 feed a candidates don't
go anywhere our live coverage from
brigid continues in just a few minutes
[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
for chess continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
we are back we are back looking at the
beautiful
beautiful park el retiro park
what a gorgeous scene there in madrid
albert hero is one of the parks where
citizens of spain citizens of madrid
will play chess regularly i i want to go
to there that looks very pleasant i
would like to go to el ratiero park
someday maybe we will
but right now we have other things to do
and that don't look at me like that
hammer it's fun to go to parks these i
bet the players would love to go to the
park too i'm i'm sure you could go to
the park
uh if you just went there on a rest day
because you are currently in madrid you
you make it sound like it's such a
freaky thing that you could go to the
park let's do it let's do it on monday
you want to go to the park dealer i'm
not sure i want to be outside in this
spanish okay that's true we want to keep
you inside
we like we like young love the camera
right where he is here in madrid we like
elmira scripchenko right where she is
and we hope that you like our coverage
so far of the 2022 fide candidates it
has been it's been awesome it's been so
much fun the players are delivering on
the board the fans are delivering in
chat the team here is delivering we are
we are having a great time we hope we
hope you are too what do we want to do
with this uh
next part of the beautiful program the
beautiful games we see in front of us
lots of options i wanted to troll you
first you're good to go
finally i've got some confidence now
that it's about the park on the typical
americans you know they want to go to
the park i want to go to del prado you
know
so okay let's have a look at this
position it's absolutely crazy and i
think that we should stick with the game
uh between yande pomnesi and fabiano
caruana
it's
an absolutely wild affair
c5 was played
right as we left we highlighted the use
of the pawn majority well it's not how
many pawns you have it's how you use
them and it's time to push them push
them baby as jazz yazar would say
b take c5 and now fabi is
i didn't realize this was a debate but i
guess actually
what did you think was the obvious move
i i i don't think there is one now that
i i see it i i thought d takes c5 i
guess i just assumed to capture back
with the pawn
yeah but then we have the uh wrench
painted patented yeah
uh if you're gonna make fun of a tool as
one tool to another yeah make sure you
do it right yeah i'll try um but then i
think that the danny plane
of king h1 is super strong
the thing is
first of all when you're playing uh c5 i
thought he already knew what the
follow-up this is what i find surprising
well you take a deep thought yeah c5b
takes c5 that's uh that's why i agree
with you it's like probably the next
move is absolutely natural and fabry
thinks he takes once again yes and he
takes for the bishop
so he's taking with the bishop to put uh
pressure on white's rook
and he's making the argument that now
that you have to spend a move uh
protecting your rook then i will have
time getting my pieces into defense uh
afterwards but i'm going to be honest
with you danny i'm not even sure nepogi
will move his rook
oh man now that but you don't have that
would be something you don't have a
square that's the thing bishop like you
have bishop before next so rook c3 is
not possible probably you know
so it's actually funny so the more we
look at the square yeah the only safe
square is b3 which
is awkward
right
and you want to play rook c3 but then
bishop b4 is coming so
so white's rook is lacking squares
and that means the rook is probably
going to be sacrificed so janna
pomnyachi has already given up upon in
the opening now he's going to give away
a rook for a bishop as well
this is this is fascinating the
uh
all the psychology went into that i
agree with y'all mirror that it wasn't
that fabulous taking time it's that he
usually when you make a move like that
you already know your plan but he
thought for another
eight minutes almost before taking
backwards with the bishop
he must have really been afraid of not
gaining a tempo because of the f4 idea
but how would you sack the exchange so
let's say you do you still play the king
h1nf4 idea or do you you don't need to
move your king because this bishop is
going to be gone
so maybe you do something else
yeah
um i'm not really sure danny i it's such
a tricky position
um
you know i i would probably still go
king age one
but the problem is that
uh after fabiano then captures uh the
white rook
uh you're down a lot of material
uh and you no longer have that rook
coming over to the other side uh
creating an attack on the black king i i
think the reason fabiano hesitated is
because he assumed that pawn takes pawn
was not a possible move
for nepal
because he saw that that would create
such big trouble for the rook and then
she says well i don't care
um i'll just give away my rook
and uh like for this to be the second
round of two players who who won their
first round game the amount of risk they
are willing to to take first fabiano
playing an incredibly aggressive opening
with black and now napogniachi giving up
a work for bishop uh it's just
outstanding i mean
yes more of this
thank god none of us said this was going
to be a lame game
thank god nobody here said that or
predicted a draw
i didn't do that
um okay but let's let's talk about this
because if now we know this exchange is
going to happen and we know that d6 will
be
the most natural weakness i start
thinking of other moves like queen d2
like just to say like 22 or queen to d1
something like this
happens
i think that's now much better than king
h1 and the computer likes it too because
i'm gonna win back
some of my material here
you're allowed to sneeze it's okay we
all sneeze we're all human hammer
um amir are your thoughts
well i had thoughts uh
which are completely crazy because what
like the second round
i was thinking about actually the second
game of the world championship match
where yanni pomneshi was black was
having black pieces and magnus carlsen
was having white and actually
i was a bit surprised that almost no one
talked about this game and how it
psychologically affected young but i
think that was the game actually which
broke him and he went didn't convert
yeah
no the but the position was so
complicated it's almost like it it has
nothing to do with this position but the
spirit it's like it
put him on tilt
i think so starting from this game he
like it affected his it's so much so
that's exactly the feeling when i look
at the position in
i get
it's very complicated position uh maybe
black feels that
well fabi feels that he is supposed to
win but actually white has so many
dynamic resources and so many resources
to increase the initiative then maybe
the position is balanced who knows it's
it's
fascinating i remember that game and i i
think that i mean young had a very big
advantage at one point according to the
computers but from the human perspective
and once again i really had the feeling
that it was very difficult and
especially the feeling that magnus would
gamble
in this situation i think that what's uh
really psychological had a
huge psychological effect on yam
we actually got to move on the board
yeah he didn't go for it by the way the
the computer kind of did like the
imbalance of this exchange attack at
least from the perspective that it's
unclear but now he puts the rook on b3
but it's still tricky because the move
we thought
just looks good for uh for black the
rook has to go to b2 no the rook can
capture on the pawn on b7
because it turns out the white bishop on
a2
is in fact protected by the one thing i
literally didn't even see that
and if we were to get a traitor like
this not only would nepamyachi get back
that pawn he lost in the opening he also
has that amazing square on f5 uh for his
knight uh where there are no black pawns
that can chase it away and the white
bishop now sorry the right squared
bishop black hat
uh with the exchange of of those um
black just has no way of preventing uh
the white knight from moving in
afterwards
so i guess he just didn't need to lose
his rook so he he didn't give it away
yeah we just
we overreacted i guess to bishop e6 i
personally again fully just
wear the egg on my face i wasn't even
looking at this but it's obvious now and
but okay black black doesn't have to
give back the b7 pawn by developing the
bishop no and one of the disadvantages
of this rook move is that the rook is
now blocking white's bishop we wanted to
have that bishop pointing in towards the
the black king
um but
you know for
material reasons uh we haven't been able
to to keep up that pressure
so what
what is black's move now
the
i wanna i wanna defend the b pawn so i
can develop the bishop especially the e6
can i play a move as slow as b6
well then we're back to the danny plan
right
if pawn to b6
king f1 king h1 and here comes and the
pawn is coming in putting pressure on
those
a few black pawns that are still
protecting
the black king
and this could be a big big problem uh
moving forward and can we make a very
strange looking move
well anticipating king h1 king h8 where
it's not at all in the spirit of the
position
you want to play f5
well
i want to use it as a threat the
possible spread not for the moment but
then maybe you will play knight f5 what
do you
think knight five
definitely comes to mind the moment you
put the king on aj bishop b2 comes to
mind exactly but i don't think i can do
it right away because actually maybe i
can meet bishop e6 with knight f5
so i mean i'm not even sure
nepalnyochi is that afraid of a black
bishop attacking the white brook right
right we've seen so many lines in in
which just giving up the rook uh would
be
actually quite advantageous
so just threatening the work in itself
is not going to be um
be a big success for fabiano
i want to give a shout that we've seen
some interesting progress in the
nakamura rajab game hikaru did not take
on d5 with the queen so we'll get over
to that in just a second i know everyone
is
kind of asking for maybe a little more
naka coverage from some of the some of
the comments i saw
okay bobby fabi has got to figure this
out it black
he didn't actually play that that was my
analysis
got to figure out how to keep his edge
he's up a pawn but there is work to do
and as as has now been dubbed i i say
humbly the danny planned there's there's
potential life here that you have to
watch out for so let's back let's back
up um either either to the bird's eye
view or we can jump directly over to the
nakamura game but we'll we'll get a
quick look a good reset to show
everybody where things stand hicaro of
course still has a huge time advantage
on the clock look at that an hour and 23
minutes while it is his turn to 38
minutes from her job off
and we head over there to see that uh
hikaru
in that critical position that we left
it on
took on d5
with the pawn and not the queen
yeah so he didn't want to trade queens
because that would put
black into this drawing martial end game
territory where it was unclear how to
keep protection
of the white's most advanced pawn um
in in the long run so he took with the
pawn let's we're gonna analyze this here
to see we had e takes d5 rookie 191
queen c4
and then h3 a very uh anti-martial move
freezer back rank a little bit of
protection but it's a slow move and then
bishop d7
yeah i mean i i would be uncomfortable
here
as hikaru because the rook on a1 and the
bishop on c1 and frankly the knight on
e1 as well all of these pieces hikaru
has
is just not contributing in the fight
right now and yes he is up a pawn but
black has some rather commanding bishops
about to put their rook from the corner
into the center of the board pointing
down
towards white's position
um
i feel like uh this could be unpleasant
for icaru even though he's up upon
well i completely agree with you because
first of all i have well i feel that
those bishops are more powerful with
queens on board
white has
well
very specific problems while
finding out how to coordinate the pieces
so even if you bring
finally managed to play for example
knight c2 bishop b3 bring the rook then
the a2 pound will be hanging
and the d5 is of course is very
vulnerable so
those are the factors that
we should of course uh have in mind when
we assess this position so i don't know
how uh to coordinate the pieces should
you start with queen f3 bishop f4 or
queen of three knight c2
uh and then bishop beats two good move
queen of three you because i i wanted to
point out the move i keep wanting to
play is bishop e3 right if white could
magically take the dark square bishops
off the board white would be incredibly
happy right but the problem is the only
way to offer that trade is this which we
can quickly see
not that not that this isn't an option
it it definitely weakens white's king
side structure it puts a target on the
open file so bishop e3 is the move i
want to play and i wasn't thinking about
this move but this is a very strong move
because because now this is a threat and
if you do play rook e8 i can develop to
a square that is protected by the queen
as well right so queen of three i think
is probably the best move in the
position not just because it threatens
bishop e3 but because it guards f4 which
finally allows white to complete
development
and actually do so
maybe sort of just in time well actually
i i wanted to play knight c2 first
because i'm not sure like uh if a bishop
before is
maybe it's a bit premature now so my
plan was to play knight c2
oh rookie two
i've missed something i fork
i guess
oh then i've missed some because yes
because i was thinking that uh
that was not possible
why is it just winning it must be yes
and i think this is uh like uh
it's just simply a very big position
bishops move backwards danny they don't
move like that okay very good
um no i didn't think that that was
possible because like in my calculation
like after rookie two yeah just to my
defense i was one wanted to play a b3
but i probably missed something as well
so
what is that uh
oh you have rook f2 intermediate of
course so now now that they see the
position yeah of course
so um
because i want to play b3 and then
bishop b3 if we'll exchange queens of
course but then there is absolutely
like it's a very nice tactical
refutation of
with rookie two so it has to be either
bishop e3
orbish before
icarus you see how dangerous this
position is like in one move
it came from a little bit slightly
better for white to absolutely lost
so um
you have to be very careful but then
maybe you have to play bishop b3 now or
in the next move yeah
well ikaro calculates lines like this
for a living he's the uh
the most popular chess streamer in the
world many maybe were surprised
by the fact that he made it to the
candidates but he brings something to
the candidates that of course none of
the other top players do because of his
community and his following and his
reputation being that of the online
blitz and bullet legends so let's remind
everybody of who hikaru nakamura is as
he sits here and thinks in this critical
moment
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believes nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this japanese-american
grandmaster leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix
the unexpected victory earned him a bid
into the candidates for the first time
in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
yukaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
[Music]
hey kara nakamura will he catch
lightning in a bottle it's got to start
with a victory a bounce back of course
from the first round loss he had to
fabio on carbuana but
his reputation his career is full of
accomplishments that say he can do so
he is
well he's a five-time us champion
so many things he's uh he's won the last
four chess.com speeches championships
which is not an easy feat and he was the
first chess streamer on twitch to reach
a million subscribers
shout out to agad mator who someone
called us out and said that we said he
was the first to reach a million on
youtube that's not what we said we said
twitch so take that take that twitch
chat uh hikar was trying to think of
what he can what he can do to make sure
he doesn't get himself in tactical
trouble
in this
sneakily sharp position here
rook coming to e8
yeah and i i think he's uh he's a bit
uncomfortable now i i think uh rojaba
has the pressure
uh and um the the thing hikaru has
working in his advantage
is the time situation yeah he's way up
on the clock
and he will try to um
keep the tension he will try to avoid
that it's just traded down to something
that's very easy for black to deal with
and i think that's also why uh hikaru
chose not to trade the queens because he
wants to keep more attention on the
board to exploit uh rajabov's um
somewhat um lacking time management yeah
that's that's a really fair point i mean
we were talking about him not trading
on d5 with the queen for those maybe
just tuning in on that point here
to because he didn't want the end game
but another very good practical
observation there by hammer in addition
to avoiding the end game and maybe a
draw the more pieces on the board the
harder it is normally for your opponent
to play under time pressure so
what do you think about that oh mira
well once again i think even though that
i i completely agree that this end game
had uh a lot of drawing tendencies i
still think that uh this choice is very
risky
yeah especially that i think that the
mura jabba once again you you should
always think about the position uh where
the type of positions where your
opponent excels and those are two
bishops
like with the queen on boards and very
dynamic positions for temura jabba
well he's he's got his work cut out for
him he knows it he's uh he's thinking
hard
i still
still think white has an edge if you
find all the right moves but i guess
we've seen so many times that you're
tactically right on the edge
uh
if you if you don't find all the best
moves so hey carl this is this is a
longer thing than we've seen him take in
the entire game today
we'll see how long he's on the clock
there are four other games going as well
let's remind everybody of where each of
those stand i feel like we probably have
to give some attention to yon christoph
duda and dingley wren or the
or the chess gods
might come after us
um
i know that uh
well we sort of have like a divine
situation right now
like magnus carlsen being on mount
olympus you know
choosing
like it's a really like sort of greek
mythology situation i've been such a fan
since i was like a kid so we here we
have a situation where like
an absolute god you know
might choose or not to play
and who is this hero
who is going to be chosen
it would be it would be interesting if
the uh the norwegian final boss
norwegian chess god chose not to play
but speaking of other gods thor brings
down his hammer on a regular basis on
marvel villains across the world and we
bring down the hammer whenever we want
to get a little bit more a little more
deep analysis a little more insight so
we're about to we're about to throw to
hammer and give him an opportunity
to look to look at the young christopher
duda dingley run game
and on that note let's uh
let's hook him up
yeah danny so i thought there was a very
interesting moment in this game which
kind of goes against common wisdom uh in
this position from that uh duda versus
thing game
ding actually played the move
c5
voluntarily blocking in his bishop here
on b6 that bishop is now much less uh
influencing the game because of putting
all these pawns on the dark squares
and what is the reasoning then for
the top rated player in the event to
make such a decision well
yes the black bishop is bad but so is
the white bishop ding is arguing that
both bishops are being blocked by the
black pawns so both bishops are equally
bad
and this move does allow black to have
uh increased influence
in the center of the board and we're
going to actually jump further
into the game as well
um apparently my my soft touch is not
soft enough sometimes
but here in this moment that ding had
actually
started putting even more pawns on dark
squares and now he goes ahead and plays
the very aggressive g5 a move we will
recognize from nakamura's game yesterday
and fabiano's game today ding is really
going for that aggression and he doesn't
care that all his pawns are on the dark
squares because yes the bishop on b6 is
terrible
but so is this white bishop on d2 it's
just pointing into a wall of black pawns
blocking its path i think this is going
to be a very interesting game and and i
kind of like ding's position i i think
he may be able uh to get something out
of this with his aggressive pawn play
a lot of maneuvering ahead in that one
for sure right it's a very gonna be
that's that's a closed position if i've
ever seen one and i love the i love the
highlighting of voluntarily blocking in
your own bishop like that you just you
don't see that every day
dingley wren in a shorter chair than he
was in yesterday for those who missed
that storyline
all the other players playing in the
chair with the big back but uh
ding doesn't want that
every time like i look at the music i'm
thinking like about the song by peter
gabriel is like i want to be your
sledgehammer sledge hammer i i mean
amber there's so many ways to just you
know have a good time with you
especially when you're over there
playing playing weatherman you know
yeah king fluff man you're stealing
viewers comments
yeah there's a little bit of a storm
moving in on the eighth rank right maybe
uh maybe a pawn storm lol how about that
for an awkward chess pun i'll be here
all week everybody don't forget to tip
your waitress i kind of liked it danny
that's precisely what ding is doing he's
using his pawns aggressively to storm
against the uh the white king barry
chess wanted to know what's the forecast
i hopped in the chat one of the best
things about you heading over to the
telestrator as we're calling it the
maurice monitor as it's been dubbed
throughout most chess commentary lands
is that it gives me a chance to hop on
chat about cloudy with a chance of bad
bishops let's keep come on this is
awesome natasha archer do we got more i
love this so we got we see a pawn storm
moving in from the north we've got
cloudy with a chance of bad bishops by
the way cloudy with a chance of
meatballs as a dad
one of the most underrated animated
films a film not a movie
cloudy with a chance of meatballs is a
film hurricane ding to make the landfall
i love it uh it's good stuff
this is absolutely brilliant
you look good over there you maybe could
be a weatherman it's not as easy as it
looks because you're constantly looking
at yourself on the monitor which is like
reversed
right it's it's not it's not easy so
don't worry it's breaking the codes of
uh traditional weathermen no don't you
think so
traditional weathermen are
very good at what they do i would say
it's a very hard job
that's what i had in mind
anyway i'm so glad that he brought this
c5 move because it was like one of my um
undisclosed desires if i might say like
to to come to this position and to
understand it
camera will you give us a forecast
uh on this one here well i i think we
said it right uh hurricane dane
on the way with a pawn storm
and uh if if i was uh if i was staying
in this position
i would be massively tempted uh to play
the move f5
all in on the pawn storm yeah
i guess the concern is
that when you start pushing your pawns
forward there's less pawns uh protecting
that um
black king and also in in this concrete
situation
um if ding pushes his pawn forward here
uh then the move e takes f5
uh knight takes back
and then knight e4
and
white's knight gets a very nice position
uh in the middle of the board and i
would imagine it's uh this kind of play
ding is uh considering at the moment
and i wanted to just to point out that
these moves like c5 first of all
deprived white of
any positional uh
like idea playing d4 first g5 deprived
of any counter play so
with f4 and then i wanted simply to come
back a little bit later after knight e7
that
and that explains the move b4 that white
played because right here yeah a little
like after 97 yes uh
duda did everything just to uh well to
play before because he needed
a plan and something very active so
they're they're really
they really weren't any other plan
that's what you're saying right f4 has
been shut down for business d4 has been
shut down for business
it's fascinating you know how
weird this sort of closed as we said
cloudy with a chance a bad bishop's
position is is when you get a chance to
open up your bishop you choose not to
you don't even take it you take with the
pawn because you care so much about
keeping this structure closed even at
the cost
of this uh bad bishop
oh man all right well a lot of people
care a lot about opportunities to play
an online chess that matters big events
we're bringing them to you the first
ever chess.com global championship
qualifiers are well underway and we'd
like to see what our amazing community
has achieved what can you achieve you
can submit your best game and we might
show it live next week so if you've
played in the chess.com global
championship use the command submit in
chat for more info
we'd love to see what the community has
been up to and if you think you played
one of the best games so far in the
chess.com global championship qualifiers
are running every weekend submit it and
we will review it and maybe maybe we'll
announce it on the candidates show who
knows so all right
back to dingley runs game a takes b3 was
played and after the bishop found safety
wait no he hasn't played at five sorry
that was my analysis there so we're
still on the clock here with dingley run
considering
open it up or keep it closed
yeah and i mean if ding is happy with
the draw here he can just sit and wait
there's nothing really white can do in
this position
white has an extra pawn
on the side of the board the pawn on a2
and this is a past pawn because it
cannot be interrupted by any black pawns
on its way down the problem is that uh
ding he can just put both his rogues on
that uh a file yeah and he'll just put
tremendous pressure down on the pawn and
there's no way that pawn is gonna make
it all the way uh to becoming a new
queen uh so um yeah it's interesting to
see uh what a level of ambition
ding is gonna show now is he gonna take
risks to go for the win
uh or is he just going to settle for a
draw in a position where neither player
really can make
any progress
it's a good question i predicted a draw
i'm sure he cares about that i'm sure he
wants to prove me right so he probably
won't play for a win because of that
well i do like rook a7 i have okay they
did but then i feel that after queen b1
there won't be much progress
so the recony e2 also protects and then
i can even triple
uh on the b file i can play rook e b2 so
on the other hand i think maybe he can
seize uh the momentum now play knight g6
and bring his knight to f4
but it's starting to see like he has a
full board
playing i mean you can double rooks on
the a file you could you could play for
this so he's got a full
a full view of his options and we've got
an amazing view of the palacio de
centonia
i love it i think that i will always be
able to exchange those rooks so like
queen b1 b7 that was my idea
also so uh
uh yeah but still i mean ding is in
control right i mean like you can
exchange the rooks but like i think you
can
kind of try to play on both sides of the
board here for a long time right if the
knight ever comes to f4 and the exchange
happens maybe then the g file becomes
open right there's
i'm not you know claiming like some big
advantage but it feels like a very comfy
position for for black queen e8 so
ding is trying to play the move h5
uh his queen now protecting that square
enabling the pawn to move forward
and this is going to be like a
heavyweight
duel
where both players are trying to make
some progress but it seems difficult for
both of them and and with that i thought
maybe we should head over uh to
nepamyachi
and uh karana because napolichi has just
played the danny plan he
did can you each one all right
yeah we're gonna do that let's let's
head on over to the yonda pam nishi
faviano karwana game because mr carwana
looks a little
i don't know it looked a little tense
there he gave the the fabi neck rub
there's kind of a patented bobby move
where he kind of leans over and rubs his
neck a little bit of a stress reliever
there
they've got king h2 on the board after
so we left it on b5 okay b5 was clearly
a better way to play
uh than i was thinking with b6 i think
the main tactic just to show everybody
is that if you take twice the bishop
doesn't hang we already solved that
but bishop a6
is likely a problem here but on the
other hand if the bishop comes out there
to attack the white rogues we've kind of
discussed the possibility of
not being so afraid of losing our rook
if it means that we can maybe get our
knight into the attack against the the
black queen so like no none of the moves
here are are obvious and sacrifices
uh are possible at every junction well
it's funny because john didn't take
there
he played
knight to f5
and after queen to f6
he played king h2
the danny plan the danny played he's
playing for f4 i mean if f4 happens and
the king side opens up we are
we are in an all-out slugfest it'd be
very very dangerous for caruana we said
he played like ricardo did yesterday and
and in that game
everyone was skeptical of the of the
risk that hikaru took by castling short
we haven't been that skeptical of
bobby's approach here it's been a
different type of position but
if this position blows open we might
start uh
start talking a little bit
about fabi's choice here to play so
aggressively with the black pieces yes
and rook g3 is also a massive threat now
oh rookie three first and then both f4
and h4 or knight h6 you know i always
look at some concrete sacrifices of
course f4 but rg3 knight h6 and bishop
g5
i like that
rook g3 threatens knight h6 bishop to g5
everything blows open well even in this
position right almira earlier you
suggested the move knight takes h6
as just at this moment
exactly that's so that's maybe the like
although
is there wait there's there is always a
defensive resource with knight g4 maybe
not the king let's show it before we get
you in our heads and everyone we lose
everybody just to show a random move the
point is that if if captures captures
bishop takes
there was some idea that queen takes
could be met by rook g3 but as elmira
pointed out there's always a knight g4
in the end
maybe other things but knight g4 check
interposes the pin and white keeps uh
sorry black keeps the queen so this
would be fantastic but but this is a
great idea right we have to watch out
for this shot honestly it's getting so
dangerous here if i'm bobby why am i not
just taking this
uh because then you have no light
squared control in the position and you
let the white bishop on a2
be be unopposed with its pressure
uh down towards the black king
but you get rid of such a dangerous
night on the other hand i think that uh
that's probably the right concentration
here
you get rid of
not only of the night but like of half
of the threats potential threats maybe
um
i i really don't like you don't like
this as well for fabiano no i can see
that the the engine is suggesting b
takes a4 here uh yeah
uh and then moving the rook over to
attack the black king
uh and then like these um here fabiano
is up two pawns
but those two pawns are the pawns on a6
and a4 and i really struggle to see any
chance of those pawns getting past the
white bishop
the white bishop is on the light squares
and you just exchanged off the only
piece that could challenge this white
bishop which means that your extra pawns
on the queen side are probably not that
significant
so um
i mean it's a tremendously interesting
position but i i think both players feel
like uh they have chances to win here
fabiano with uh potentially two pawns up
and napoleon with some very dangerous
bishops pointing in towards the black
queen
a king yeah i don't disagree i think but
i think as elmira said you're you're
kind of picking poisons right i mean you
want to trade off the light square
bishop and leave
yon with the knight
or would you rather
take your take your chances
in a position where yes white dominates
the light squares but as we analyzed
sorry not that and bishop takes f5
at least you have a bunch of pawns maybe
you use the b file to get active and and
and try to
playing some active defense but for sure
i'm with you hammer i mean this you
probably have to already put the king on
h8 or h7 i don't know which one that's
actually what i wanted to do without
taking on on a4 maybe like you're
winning a tempe but still
maybe it's useful for black to start
immediately with the move like king h7
right
i think that even now it's possible okay
you brought like
another piece into attack so
yeah
it's very unclear
wow but i think maybe like bishop f5 is
the lesser of the evils like if we oh
but it looks like he just
moved did he did he played b takes a
four
okay maybe it's just a transposition so
maybe pick up the relationship so he
took first and maybe with the intention
of capturing
on f5 next depending on whether or not
but what if there's something subtle
about if the rook commits to g3 right
away if he has a different plan
we're going to find out because jan
doesn't take a lot of time vintage yawn
coming out here it took a lot of time to
start but as we look at the gap
between the two players on the clock
becoming less and less at one point
caruana earlier in this game had
about an hour advantage so
this is uh what do you what do you feel
when you when you can when you're
sitting across from your opponent and
you can see in their body language you
can see in the rhythm of their moves
that they're feeling right stella got
their groove back if the if you will
how do you feel when stella gets her
group back hammer
danny i just want to say that all your i
mean chad is calling me out for not
getting your references but people need
to understand that not only is danny way
older than me
uh he is also american and i am
norwegian we have a very different
uh
cultural backgrounds and as such the
references are prone to to being
misunderstood or unknown at times
okay well good okay this is such an
eloquent speech he knows like that's
awful that's so friendly
i know myself that there are a lot of
things that when i was traveling to the
three united states that i was missing
at times and like my first thanksgiving
was only at 2019 which i spent like
watching american football you know and
we had a turkey and i thought that it
was such a special moment but those were
the things that i only saw in movies
yeah that was like so the turkey
american culture i guess eating too much
food and watching
grown men beat each other up anyway
let's watch let's take a look at bobby's
guys enjoy the merry christmas speaking
of grown men beating grove men beating
each other up we're gonna have a lot of
grown men beating each other up here in
madrid for the next few weeks and fabi
has some uh
some interesting matchups ahead of him
right the head-to-head scores that he
has against most are are good other than
that that big one you circled there in
the middle against dingley wren
i don't know what speaks to you guys
here
hammer your thoughts on
what speaks to you about about favi's
path as it as it stands well actually um
i'm i i've been uh ripping into this
ding versus uh karana uh match up uh
where i i saw that fabiano has a
quite significant negative score uh but
i was made aware by robert hess
uh that uh in fact two of those wins for
ding like two of fabiano's losses are in
fact from when they were like 12 13
years old oh interesting okay uh so uh
actually it's not that bad ding has the
better score against another one of the
pre-tournament favorites but uh he's
going to go into that
not as confident as these numbers
may suggest speaking of context to be
added to the score as well we hear the
context about his record with dingley
wren because a couple games from their
youth further context just everyone
pointing it out we know that it is now
eight wins versus hikaru nakamura this
was the head to head by round coming in
so his record now against takara was
eight wins and five losses so we we see
you chat we know we're all over it here
all right we'll go back to the game here
what do we think we've got uh
another move being played it was king h7
elmira as we were talking about it you
suggested perhaps the power of playing
this move before taking the knight right
flexibility i think kind of favors fobby
as he's defending this position a little
bit
well first of all king safety
i don't know he already well played
quite a risky move g5 so i think this is
very consistent also very consistent of
fabi maybe playing for more
so i
i think that
he still feels that
even though the disposition is very
complicated that three results are still
possible yeah
so
[Music]
i'm really amazed of how
how
they evaluate how strong players
evaluate the position so how
uh
like finally no that's like
because the smallest nuance like could
influence their assessment and they they
have this feeling it's almost intuitive
now so
because i always over estimate i have
this tendency
yes and uh
and i think that
this is a very powerful demonstration of
how
they lead place
yep i'm also guilty of that i think it
is a another common trait we talked
about short-term memory loss being a
common trait among the elite right they
just let go of their mistakes very
quickly i think another common trait is
like we said lack of emotion there they
don't
they're just very skeptical of their own
chances in a healthy way all the time
that kind of helps keep them in check as
they
play very complicated positions and
young at the same time though
he has to spell a little bit of blood
here right and he also probably has to
have the sense that it's
almost now or never right he's going to
really think about this position before
letting fabi off the hook because
if he doesn't convert
now bishop takes f5 as a threat
you know there's bishop b1 at some point
maybe then you won't take twice because
at the end there's bishop to be one
in some positions
maybe not right away
there's also f4 though so probably he's
just sitting here thinking all right
well bobby's allowing f4
let's go big fella let's look at it
let's analyze f4 i mean actually i don't
understand
why he can't just play f4 and pry open
the g file i i guess he's considering
sacrificing the knight first
but i mean either f4 like opening up
towards the black g f4 g takes up four
bishop takes f4
now you have to take an f5 because you
there's no way you can protect on h6
yep takes a five
e takes a five
and now maybe rook g8
to exchange one rook
it's very important like to exchange
attacking pieces
yeah and if black can start taking any
pieces off the board at this point as
ugly as these pawns might look
they are extra so with every piece that
comes off the board every ounce of
pressure that black can relieve from
white's attack is just going to be maybe
a winning endgame
so you have to be uh
you have to be really precise if you're
going to go for these concrete lines
with f4 and that's kind of what yon must
be calculating i want i want to look at
this though is there anything
i know pots or c check pots her play
check
but i was looking at the g file and
wondering if there was anything here
oh i completely forgot about this check
but i think it's probably just horrible
because after the king moves it's like
now what do you do yeah computer's like
yeah good job dan cause the point is now
you're taking and the rook's falling so
i knew it was bad but i just had to
point it out
that it was a check
so that means that means that this line
is forced so maybe bishop f5
and then rook g8 i actually really like
you i mean this this looks like a very
reasonable guess of where this game
might head and
not because we're trying to play guess
the move necessarily which of course you
can do on chess.com it is a feature um
but
but on the other hand like uh
this light square bishop that white
still has it's like it's a monster let's
say bishop d5 okay it protects on g2
yeah and controls the a2 attacks the f7
so it's like uh it's such a powerful
piece right now yeah that's a monster in
the middle of the board
that is not a bishop that is a monster
yeah
it's just a weird position right because
like you can't help think about the
pawns and the evil bar but this is why
hammer didn't like it he's like look
this is
this is a really tough position for
black because of white's dominance of
the particular light square color
complex
and i'm not even sure that if uh
black would win a third pawn on f5 that
you know this position would be winning
we have action
and like i said not playing guess the
move just to do that but to try to maybe
anticipate if we can what the storyline
of this game might be what the players
are looking at and you can just tell
that bobby has to be feeling
happy that there's no concrete
sacrifices maybe but he has to be
feeling the the the pressure here
as yawn is now untying the pieces these
are pieces that were given big tasks
earlier in the game now the queen
is coming to a4 maybe coming to d1
we already talked about the bishop it
feels like with every move that yawn
kind of re-coordinates the pieces with
the looming threat to blow things open
you know what it reminds me also of the
yesterday's game he didn't play g5 the
move that we were analyzing for quite a
while and he chose a very specific
moment to do so so i think that we are
completely obsessed during like our
games with concrete variations
but maintaining the pressure and
maintaining the cows on the board is is
very important and so
not going for the concrete line because
he's absolutely sure that fabiano has
calculated it and calculated it
precisely
but he increases the pressure so this is
the
this queen d1 move is uh absolutely
brilliant from this point of view
for those who don't remember the
critical moment elmira is talking about
is that we knew young was better with
black against dingley wren there was all
this pressure mounting but we we
established just how brilliant it was
that he didn't go for the knockout blow
until ding was also under time pressure
so just those practical sort of elements
and and uh
you know things that the players are
doing in these games as a strategy as an
overall strategy is fascinating so maybe
jan knows that at some point he's going
to be all in on an idea like this
keeping it flexible you also still keep
the h4 option open which we've talked
about sneakily is still something to
keep our eye on there's also your
sacrifice idea right and now the queen
is adding other elements for black to
think about so i agree this is this is
this is going to be a very very
interesting position for fabi to figure
out knowing the potential dangers
um and that yawn is playing faster
playing more confident with every step
so
all right i think we have to look at
some of the other
lots of stuff happening
in the uh
rapport for russia game but
that's one we haven't checked on in a
very long time as we look at the bird's
eye view
only one move has been played in the
nakamura
or java game and it was the moves we
predicted the queen came back to f3 and
the rook came over to e8 so now as long
as icaru doesn't blunder knight c2 we
expect bishop e3 or bishop f4 to be on
the board can we have just a quick look
on
uh
richard report versus celebrization yeah
i think we should again just happy
birthday
happy birthday
to ollie rosa fruit i almost just i
almost just bursted in the song you are
so welcome chad cause you guys know you
don't know what i'm gonna do i almost
just started saying happy birthday
because i said happy birthday twice by
accident
it's rude to not sing someone happy
birthday anyway we're not going to be
there do you have a dress
a dress yes like maryland so like oh now
that would be something if i if how
about if farouza wins the candidates
we'll do a marilyn monroe happy birthday
mr president i'm not going to do that
wild vincent flamenco
this is something that i want i already
oh hey
i already owe an andrea botez like
cat made dress or something i don't know
i still i'm gonna do it it was a charity
event so i got to do some cat meeting
all right but where are we at here this
is an end game it has been for a very
long time between these two
young gentlemen playing in their first
candidates each respectively we'll back
up a little bit to where the queens were
traded
and
just wanted to note a few changes in the
positions so like now the uh black spawn
is like on the b files yep yes there's a
yeah we just if we fast forward and
tarantino the position we've had a
captures to the b file which doesn't
actually solve the c6 weakness problem
which was the biggest weakness in the
previous structure but it does give
black some new chances and some new
pressure as compensation for it so how
did that happen on the other hand he
doesn't have his pair of bishops in your
moors ah that's the other thing so let's
see how we got there we saw the brook
come to c1 rook a6
typical stuff okay now we can already
anticipate where we're going here the
knights remaneuvered along with the
bishops developing and the one early
observation i have to make elmira is
what did rapport do with his king in
this structure in the end game he
brought it to the queen side
and ultimately that paid huge dividends
for him defensively and to maneuver
ferocious king on this side of the board
is never going to be a helping factor to
the weak c6 pawn so
we have to keep an eye on that storyline
should ravport find a way to get
get something
um in this end game it it may be because
of a lack of sufficient defense to this
weak c6 pawn so
the bishop was exchanged on b4 as you
said
bishop here no longer it improved black
structure pawn structure but on the
other hand of course it created like
well
it's balanced do you have the weakness
on a2 now and the weakness on b4 so
yeah
even though c6 is still weak if a2 is to
fall
even b2 could come under fire unless the
rooks are traded
so
so quite the
quite the interesting end game again i
know this is a queen's off the board
position so it doesn't
doesn't scream fire on board like some
of the other games but
the more i look at it the more i feel
like we could we could still have a
decisive result in this game
i actually really like the idea of
moving this bishop
to d6
hit the rook and then use the
use the c file if i
to can to bring pressure to the c6 pawn
maybe i have to play b3 at some point
and then play rook c2 because if i can
block the bishop's defense of a2 then i
can use the second rank to guard a2 and
double rooks well that's i have a
feeling that white is slightly better
and mostly uh because look at those
nights the knight on g6 you know doesn't
have many perspectives so you should
bring it to play probably via f8 maybe
knight f8 knight g7
uh or you know 97 then at some point
they can take it and win on c6 so and i
don't d2 goes to c4 knight d6 as well so
are you going to
exchange it
yeah
shout out to robert hess who if he was
here he would highlight the pawns
ability to corral and tame a knight a
wild a wild beast stallion becomes a bit
of a donkey against a pawn
either on on b3 or g3 and upon in front
of its structure right that's a that's
against the soviet chess school
i know it i i know what you were going
to say um
by the way we have richard's report on
our screen and we were talking a lot
about music so does he look like a rock
star
he does look like a rock star plus the
shirt there and what a great comment
here from chat from casey i think casey
able rookie is forced to protect the
pawn
kind of groveling as a move i i i guess
so you're right i mean ferugia knows
he's uh he's on the defense
but what i was about to get to and and
with hammer here back with us in studio
i want to ask
what's the plan for white so we've
highlighted the dysfunction for black
the knight is corralled black has to
defend two weaknesses now a bit of a
groveling move right according to twitch
chat but how does white make progress
well i guess that's why uh rapport is is
thinking right now
he needs to he has maximized his
position so far
and he needs to figure out what's next
um and to be honest i'm i don't think
it's it's obvious because the the
black bishop on e6
is doing a really good job
of discouraging the the white knight
from getting into the game yeah um so i
would like to get my knight involved
um
but i'm not sure how i'm gonna
accomplish that
what what kind of credit you give to my
plan of b3 i kind of like it uh danny d
let's say we play it
and the idea is again
by eliminating the threat the only way
that black can increase the threat is to
double which would be an exchange of b
for a
but in theory i guess it should also
drop the c6 plan i i see the tactics
with b3 falling as well at the end but
okay we'll
we'll calculate that the the idea of
blackboard to do nothing is to play rook
c2
to double and only then try to release
the bishop with some sort of
threat because one idea on the mirror is
at some point you might actually trade a
for c if white can do that with some
firepower right if the pieces can get
active on the c file you might make a
trade like that
well i agree with this of course but for
for me that like uh the most natural
trade here would be in the long term
like i would win maybe the eight upon
you will win the b4
so and then you will try to win the c6
error
yeah i was going to say i'm actually
quite intrigued also by a suggestion the
computer made in the initial position a
move i don't think i would have come up
with myself
out of the blue
it's the move a3
where the idea is
that after black makes the trade
white will recapture with a rook
and then we're gonna see a trade of
rooks as well
uh and if that uh rook trade happens
uh then white can recapture with the
pawn
i wasn't sure what you're gonna say i
think both are possible
i i really like this pawn takes because
then you can
try and get that pawn up the the side of
the board and and black's pieces aren't
really in a in a situation
uh to prevent that so
easily and in fact it is this a3 move
that rapport just uh made on the board
wow
look at you calling the shot what are
you babe ruth over there
uh
we don't have
there's no other country than the us
that plays baseball okay well you
mentioned
baseball i will i will come back to your
disparaging comment against the great
american past time in a minute but first
i have to say that we have not a
baseball event coming up but we do have
an nfl event just around the horizon
blitz champs is coming this july it's
going to be amazing you can see watch
your favorite nfl stars compete for
their share of a hundred thousand
dollars for charity
the legendary wide receiver larry
fitzgerald as you can see
kind of kind of headlines the event cave
on thibodaux has an active fan club on
chess.com amari cooper may or may not be
streaming chess lessons soon wink wink
hint micah parsons so many things you
can catch cleveland brown's receiver
like we said amari cooper dallas cowboys
linebacker micah parsons and uh the top
drive top five draft pick there so it's
gonna be awesome tune in it's july 9th
and 10th in the afternoons it's not pog
champs but it's the first kind of
non-chess endemic celebrity event we've
done in a while and we're pretty excited
about it and uh we hope to see you there
right after the candidates it's our next
big event july 9th and 10th so
a takes
a3 was played rook has taken on a3
hammer's idea lives
and you knew who babe was when i said
you were calling your shot though of
course i did of course and it was a
great segue you think i did that on
purpose
well i i don't know the reference i just
know he's the basis oh he came to the
plate and like held his bat out
and
the legend is he was calling his shot
because he then hit a home run to
exactly where he was pointing it could
also be that he was just stretching
i don't know that it was ever confirmed
actually on record well i mean if i was
just stretching and then hit a home run
in that area i wouldn't confirm or deny
either
yeah
okay i do know an incredible story about
a chess game calling their shot if you
want to hear that yeah so
first ever tournament i tournament i
ever organized back when i was a
tournament organizer in arizona copper
state international and daniel fridman
german grand master was there along with
anna zatonski but in the last round he
played the black pieces against buddy of
mine david pruis and i had every title
player because i brought in title
players from all over the world first
time they'd ever done that big deal for
me i had everyone signed the board right
and david went over to the f7 square and
signed f7 and said i'm gonna sacrifice
on f7 and win this game and he
sacrificed on f7 and won a brilliant
checkmate attack against grandmaster
daniel friedman who was for the point
everybody was it was probably easily 150
feet eight points stronger so it was
that was literally a big deal calling
your shot
everyone allows a good cruise story yeah
everyone loves a good damn proven story
shout out to david pruis chest dojo live
if you're looking for a great twitch
channel with educational content give
them give them a follow give them a sub
so all right
we're back to the games here do we want
to go to a bird's eye view and and uh
take things a different direction just
that that was the position on the board
while you were
well telling a ridiculous story no that
was a very nice stories like i always
love a nice story i was trying to
to find a way to avoid those exchanges
for example to play rook b8 in this
position but maybe then white can play
rook ac3 and that's how you double on
the c file also
yeah the rook comes from a3 to c3 in a
different way and then the bishop could
come back to a3 we're talking about the
game if you look in the in the upper
left corner there for those sorry sorry
that it's in your head but uh
we're gonna head over to the nakamura
game
his battle versus teamwork
is uh
stuck kind of right where we left it uh
the position is
very tense for nakamura and you can tell
because he doesn't use his time lightly
right hicaro doesn't uh spend time on
the clock unless he really has to but
really giving this position a deep think
before making a commitment
he spent 32 minutes on queen f3 for the
record and i mean he spent so much time
on on this move as well at some point
hikaru was up an hour on the clock
right now that time advantage has shrunk
to one minute
he is very uncomfortable with his
position right now
let's i mean
uh
are we gonna try to predict what lines
he's in i mean he's thinking so deeply
you have to wonder
what he struggle evaluate what he's
struggling to evaluate
maybe
first of all that's the variation maybe
he was planning to play knight c2 so
bishop b3 he knows he needs to exchange
this bishop so
well it didn't work out like in a in an
ideal world you want to take with the
knight on a3 so he probably realizes
that he has to play bishop iii and take
with the pound
yeah and again for anyone just tuning in
almir could very well be right maybe
when he first started this whole line
because akara wouldn't make the blender
right in front of him and but i think he
might be onto something because he
didn't go for the end game and maybe
when he first started this line he
thought that he could get knight c2 in
right now he's recognized that knight c2
would be in a media blunder again as we
said
we showed this line earlier
so he has finally moved and indeed he
has committed to bishop e3
where he will now have to take back with
the pawn because he didn't have time for
knight to c2
the structural change still gives white
a tiny edge but this this already feels
way worse although it does feel a little
better hammered that that dark square
bishop is off the board man that guy was
dangerous yeah for sure but now if i
play b4 just because i don't want you to
uh to let you fix my pawns so because
you can play a3 and then i still fix my
bombs b4 a very aggressive move
i like that well in some ways it's also
a very defensive move because when
you're
defending when you're trying to
equalize
an inferior position
you will often want to make pawn traits
and if all the pawns disappear off the
board you can even make a draw
if you lose your bishop yeah so
exchanging pawns is one of the key ways
of trying to defend a problematic
situation and i i agree with omira this
b4 looks like a really good move
both because it gets rid of black's
doubled pawns but also because now
uh the black queen
is is able to make many more threats on
the white position that than she was
earlier also i wanted to open some files
and
um
yeah i also just want to highlight
because you said it so quickly i think
it was really instructive that the
threat is a3
for white yeah this is a positional well
it's in my mind you know it's so it's uh
but no i think it's a really strong
point i think especially because when
most
most levels of chess chesapeake we think
of threats as attacking moves right it's
ready to win a piece but this is a very
real threat because if this structure is
fixed not only will the pawns remain
doubled the bishop will remain less
active and that allows a knight who
thrives on maneuvering to kind of
slowly work different angles so i really
like the idea of b4
should should rajabov choose to take he
hasn't moved yet is there yeah i think
he played bishop b3
uh rajabov has not played bishop e3 no
no no i think hicario played notice
no i was saying for java hasn't moved
yet i was just about to ask is there any
other option besides taking no
right that that's what i was getting to
is where java hasn't moved yet but i'm
not sure what else he could be thinking
about so
the
all right well java is thinking here
and as we've said several times he's the
oldest player in the field and
that doesn't that doesn't mean he has
any less chances to win that means he's
one of the most experienced players in
the field we're going to jump into our
highlight and player profile on tame
over java and his career and how he got
here to madrid
the oldest player in madrid at age 35
timura
is competing for the third time at the
candidates and for the first time in
nine years
once ranked in the top five in the world
raja qualified for the candidates two
years ago but was unable to compete due
to covet concerns for this year's
tournament fide offered raja a wild card
which raja accepted
[Music]
born in the same azerbaijani city as
former world champion gary kasparov raja
beat gary kasparov at age 15. in fact he
has never lost to the former world
champion
one of the peak achievements of
rajabov's career was his victory at the
fide world cup
in that tournament he defeated the top
seed ding lyren in the final to qualify
for the 2020 candidates tournament
in madrid raja hopes that he can lean on
his experience at the candidates to post
some impressive performances even though
expectations for him here are not as
high as they once were
[Music]
gary kasparov lost to tamar rijaba in
the linnard's tournament maybe that was
when raja really first arrived i guess
but this guy
he's had a quite the interesting career
hammer he's a three-time european
champion he played in the 2011 and 2013
candidates he won the world cup remember
he would have played in the last
candidates
if not for covent concerns right so i
think that's a really interesting stat
that he could also be another player
playing in his fourth candidates
technically because he willingly
withdrew right and turned out he was
right otherwise he would have a stat
there just like fabiano which is his
fourth candidates is underway so talk a
little bit about teamwork or java maybe
not as well known as some of the other
players
camera but i think there's a there's a
lot a lot to this guy yeah i know and he
has really excelled in knockout
tournaments uh he he is a very very
difficult player to beat and he has
shown a lot of great nerve uh in
managing to to win the the feeder world
cup um which which then is the direct
reason uh he's uh he's here today so um
he's um he's a player that it's very
difficult to beat but he's struggling
with winning games
and in fact rajabov has not won a game
of classical chess
uh for several years yes he hasn't been
very active because of the pandemic
right but but he's looking down a very
unfortunate
statistic that he will want to turn
around
here in madrid what do you think about
that elmira as a guy who's been playing
for a really long time certainly he's
had many great victories in his career
or he wouldn't be here but is that is
that playing with your mind a little bit
you start to maybe make decisions at
some point that you wouldn't otherwise
make because of the self-imposed
pressure to get to get a w
uh
this might certainly be true but maybe
not true for this tournament because
like as we all know
like the first place is at stake so
probably you can
you can play in an absolutely different
manner here
and i think that uh that's what he was
doing already
starting from the first round uh
he might have in a very unfortunate
tournament like in norway for example
but
let's say it was a training session so
you were trying new openings or you
trying to get the feel of your opponents
in the game
but
here
well
you can sacrifice it all like just
and try to win the tournament
yeah i guess an interesting point he's
he does he doesn't have to break his uh
his draw streak so aggressively that's
kind of the point right in an event like
this unless you really start to see
someone run away with it someone is just
on fire for the most part you're still
in it as long as you're not losing right
and if he will be able to
uh to play the way he played before i
remember so many of the of his king's
indian sacrifices absolutely brilliant
sacrifices so that's just so to bring
the kid
yeah you know so it's
to play for the beauty of the game of
course and the stakes are very high here
well he was very well known for the
kingzini of course also from azerbaijan
at one point they were talking about him
as the second boy from baku for those
who don't know the nickname for gary
kasparov the boy from baku uh rajava
also from the same hometown in fact
funny story the first time i met for
java he was 15 playing in a tournament
in moscow
lost a blitz tournament lost to gary
kasparov in that tournament but i
remember all the media there one it was
my second trip to russia and i was just
a total fanboy i'm a year older than
raja but i was just a total fanboy there
like watching this rajab of kasparov
blitz match and all the media was there
because at the time roger was a real
prodigy right he was being talked about
as maybe you know one of one of the
successors to gary kasparov even at that
young age of 15. so anyway funny story
he and i were talking about it at the
opening ceremony because i think it was
the first time i had seen him in person
since that moscow blitz event so another
story i didn't know it was going to be
story time with dan today but apparently
i've got a lot of stories to share hope
you guys are having a great time guys
and gals we're going to take a very very
short break when we return of course we
have more action all four games are
still underway which means we still have
so much ahead in the palacio de centonia
it's a beautiful beautiful building some
beautiful chess being played we will be
right back with more action from madrid
in a few
wanna play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
i want to play chess on
the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss ali reza farouja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the us
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
prix cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid fide awarded one of
the eight spots to the wild card invite
grand master tamor rijaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event judah
would ultimately defeat karjakin in the
final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingley ren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many
many more at chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
what legacy
will these players set for themselves
will we have someone re-challenging for
a world chess championship title a brand
new challenger who knows
so many things ahead
we are now looking at the beautiful
views outside of the palacio de centonia
of course it doesn't properly reflect
just how hot it is but you can tell by
the clothes people are wearing that it's
it's summer out there i can tell you
that
and
as we move inside the playing hall where
it's a little bit cooler
a little bit nicer more refreshing a
great view there uh well it was ollie
rosarusha before someone took a took a
slow clock in front of the camera
richard rapford
um
we have uh so many games going still as
we said we have a bird's eye view uh
right now coming your way
of all four games still in progress
we see that uh rookie five has been
played by rajabov
we'll get we'll get rid of that uh bad
question mark there apologize for that
we will remove the game glyphs from the
board um but uh we're going to dive back
into that game
because we do want to see
we do want to see what we're java did
because it wasn't the b4 move that
almira was talking about so
we'll definitely jump back to the game
as soon as we can everybody don't you
stress
and uh
here we have it
rookie five on the board
fiber job off and then d6 responded by
caro
wrong camera there we're still looking
at ali reza ferrugia
but uh we'll we'll get over there in a
second let's talk about the position we
see here elmira d6 and the response to
rookie five threatens b7
allows bishop c6 i wanted to explain
first of all uh rookie h5 of course it's
a very concrete move but it's also it's
not very comfortable to to play like
upon down so yeah if you if you have a
chance you try to get it back of course
so like rookie five maybe that was uh
supported also by concrete uh variations
but d6 uh bishop c6 now probably
or can i
still win the pawn back maybe i can play
rogue d5 queen d5 so many options and i
don't want to change the queens okay
then maybe rook g5 i like rook d5 a lot
um
one yes queen d5 there was rook d1 of
course so then queen and rook d5 i think
is more precise
but the thing i wanted to point out is
that the moment that rook leaves there's
a pawn hanging i'm not sure
i'm not sure you want to take it so
so flippantly but uh it is a pawn no
maybe both are still possible because
like quincy five rook d1 of course i can
take on the three take on e3 take only
two so so many uh possibilities yeah
yeah okay so that's probably not going
to happen
rajab i'm going to think about how he
wants to maybe corral this d6 pawn
before anything anything crazier gets
underway but again back to the
aggressive bishop c6 i feel like that's
the other way to play the position
because black has so many active pieces
right
so much potential
for threats if if white is careless a
move like queen e2 would come in not
just with pressure on g2 but pressure on
b2 pressure on e3
obviously the d6 pawn is dangerous but
i'm i'm just looking at the the the
potential tactics here and
no but you're absolutely right because
like of course you can uh
well win the pound back and then
equalize right you could be looking for
more
and for some for a dynamic solution you
know like to increase your
pieces activity like rook g5 of course
is coming to mind after bishop g6 bishop
c6 but then
maybe bishop c6 then yes yeah i like it
bishop c6 but you know rook d5 was also
made a lot of sense
i like how aggressive he played it it
shows that raja maybe thinks there's
there's some double edgedness right i
mean we've been talking mostly about the
fact that he carves up a pawn feels like
white has the advantage obviously the
eval bar kind of
kind of guides that bias a little bit
for us to feel like white is better but
but i think hammer said it well b4 is it
was a good move but it was also kind of
a defensive move right it was thinking
about the weaknesses rookie 5 is not a
defensive move it's an aggressive move
right he wants to win back the pawn with
interest but then uh
i don't like g6 because it's also it's
very direct that i would prefer to to
give up the a2 pawn and play rogue d1
yeah so you think you're saying hikaru
should have maybe played this interview
just to keep
the passer it's very important it's like
but what you did yes but what to do now
another now i'm looking the v2 phone is
maybe we should sacrifice it oh yes it
might just be the e4 like like the point
is the pawn is extra so if you play a
move like this i don't think you can
take because of knight d3
so i'm not sure if that's the move the
computer wants but it looks very good
you you protect e5 now you can play
knight d3
push the rook back you've got to pass
pawn
so i agree it feels like rook d1
might have been
a slightly more just kind of like
solid approach to keep your edge if you
were hit car d6 is a very
very aggressive move and it just
immediately opens up these kind of
things that has me feeling like who says
black isn't isn't playing for an
advantage it's a very committal move
once again yes like i it's
i had this feeling it's like you know
it's coming from like when you're
studying all the positions you don't
know why but you want just to play rook
d1 to keep the d5 pound maybe to
centralize your pieces because i know
how difficult it would be later to
coordinate your pieces yeah so just out
of these
concerns i think that
because d6 like
everything is possible now
yeah you see i can win the pawn back and
i can activate my pieces i can
i can do whatever i want in this
position and this is
uh a bit scary i think
yeah i wonder if it was hicara feeling
like he needed to be more aggressive
than
than he needed to be right sometimes
that happens like you lost right you
know you had an advantage maybe you're
getting a little bit
a little bit too invested and converting
now and and not to say that rook debug
wasn't maybe just objectively better but
uh
rajabov is going to be someone who can
take advantage of that right he's an
experienced player he knows what it is
when your opponent maybe over presses
right
and uh
one mark i think of strong grand masters
isn't just that they win games clearly
start to finish one-sidedly but that
they understand that it's a process and
you let your opponent sort of over push
a little bit and then pounce when you
have the opportunity to do so so i
really feel like this game could be
about to turn if roger plays bishop c6
i'm just liking black's position i mean
just just optically it just looks so
open and dangerous right
for white the only weakness black has is
this you know back ranked blender but
only only eye blunder into background
checkmates that's not something no no i
do you do okay that makes me feel better
um
i i just had the thought you know
yesterday of course i couldn't sleep for
a while then like we're here covering
the candidates yeah and you know i've
been looking at the history of the
candidate this is always the kid of
course and like there have been times
where they played 28 games you know like
sorry i really want you to have a story
something happened that maybe i'd throw
up we're gonna we're gonna head over to
due to dingley remember just very
quickly repeated we apologize everyone
we're normally normally right on top of
something when it's coming to an end but
they repeated
rather unexpectedly in my in my opinion
on here bishop c8 bishop e3
and then it was uh it was just a shuffle
putt but so he finally uh well he
doubled his rook rooks on the b file as
we predicted but that's what i wanted to
tell you that ding's idea of playing
queen eight was actually to play bishop
ca to guard the b7 square we didn't have
we didn't have time to mention it but
only then i think he was intending to
play f5 is was it correct or not well
i'm going back to the position elmira
said because again we didn't we didn't
look at this game a ton we see the two
players gone but almira's point that we
didn't have a chance to look at was
queenie gate was preparing bishop c8
precisely to make sure that the rooks
would stay out of
of this uh seventh rank
that was a key idea
that dingley wren went for but it shows
that now he's sort of stuck i guess
right i'm just sort of trying to paint
the picture how do we get a job black
feels stuck to get too aggressive
because of the counter play that white
would get
right but white lacks opportunities
really
to do anything right i mean both sides
are lacking real opportunities here
we see that empty very short chair there
for dingley rendezvous not a short guy
by the way tall guy but wanted a short
chair um
and uh in the end
i think i think neither side just felt
like it was worth okay but they do go
for f5
so he prepared the five yeah
and finally pushed it
and you are forced to take because
otherwise of course the knight goes to
d4 it's very important to exchange this
knight yes so
yep
probably yes knight g3 i cannot see the
moves i'm getting closer and closer to
the monitor like here like on the
spaceship but you're creeping in for the
whatever this was
but um
yeah i mean i guess it's not not a super
surprise once the f5 exchange happened
as you said white had to take the knight
to prevent this but i'm still i don't
know i mean i feel a little robbed
because while i i agree that there's
you know
it's hard to make progress
still a lot of pieces on the board here
for for a game to end so quickly was
there really no plan either side could
go for
uh let's
maybe let's get back to knight g3 uh
king g7 like while the king is still on
g7 yeah
that i think that we should have a look
at this position
if you want to
define the plan here then
[Music]
the more i look at it the more i
understand i mean i
what are you gonna do
well maybe it's it's sort of balanced
if it's if it wasn't for the fact that
the queen and knight are holding h5 one
plan for black would be like h5 h4 g4
okay but not possible
if it wasn't for the fact that the
bishops are holding down the b file a
plan for white would surely be to
execute here and try to simplify and
maybe even have the a pawn and you have
to be very careful because like you are
you don't have the light squared bishop
was from white and then your pawns could
fall
like you know the roman empire
so uh yeah all right well i'm sure
everyone wants us to get back to more
exciting day but this is just a surprise
right it doesn't happen very often that
a game will end in that type of fashion
so again for those who want to see every
handshake happen in those dramatic
moments just not not so dramatic here
just a very very quick draw so let's
head back to our bird's eye view if we
can um and show everybody where we sit
because we now have one game in the
books
uh it is the draw in the lower right
corner
which we will reflect for you
next time around and right now just
happened so quickly now we have to look
at all three of the other games again we
see
fabiano still with an edge but still
with a similar sort of dynamic we left
them with
um
meaning he has a couple pawns but white
has a lot of light score control in the
palm mishi versus caruana
maybe we can have a look at this game
because i also had
i thought that you could also
positionally uh sacrifice an exchange
now okay you know just to release some
tension because you mean black sacrifice
maybe not exactly in this position
because i haven't looked at the position
but you know that's what i had in mind
because those two bishops are so
powerful so maybe now or i first i was
thinking about rook b3 like in some
previous positions so that's how this
positional sacrifice came
well into my intention and then i
thought but then why not sacrificing it
for another bishop so that's how i was
um
trying to find out like what could
possibly be like the how closer we can
get to the truth yeah in this position
so i like that idea a lot honestly i
think that i want to just show elmira's
rook b3 because i think it's fascinating
just forget forget that the rook is on
it it doesn't work precisely because
white can take and then the rook can
take but i think that type of shot is
really instructive because undoubling
your a pawns and then quickly having two
pass pawns right
that's some explosive stuff there and if
you don't take it then the rook is is a
real thorn to the pressure you had so it
doesn't work but i love it although
let's look at rook takes b2 because
just after we showed your your first
instructor point i actually think this
is a real move and look at that even
here like because i was just thinking i
don't know if there's a follow-up but
maybe there is a follow-up here i don't
know but even if there isn't no but now
the thing is now i i have to well i
wanted to push my well a3 because like
it doesn't matter i have those spawns i
want you to push and you don't have the
bishop on bits anymore and the very
important point is this that now my
pieces the knight on e5 and the bishop
on c5 like just those are real monsters
you have absolutely no chance of
exchanging those i i love this idea i
wonder
i wonder how much
how much credit fabiano's giving this
idea because
your last point about how getting rid of
the dark sport bishop just cements right
the stranglehold you have
in the center is is a really key one
especially because that knight is so
critical to almost black's entire
position right it kind of kind of starts
and ends with the fact that the night
guards f7 right it holds these other
squares in place i think that really
important too
but that's very strange like we managed
to like i managed to explain in a very
rational way something that came to me
intuitively you know it's like uh but
now the more i look at this position the
more i think that maybe this is possible
now
i don't know like how computer evaluates
it like in the long term maybe it's not
correct at all but
i really love this these pieces the
knight on e5 the
and the bishop on c5 and especially like
all these threats on the on the g1 a7
diagonal
would possibly be
deadly
well one thing we have to point out is
that bobby mayer may not be thinking
about this but he's thinking about
something because he now is
lower on the clock than yon at least for
the for the first time where we've been
covering it
we obviously left it to take a look at
the other games but
if you're just tuning in at one point in
this game fabiano carwana was up more
than an hour
on the clock
and
and clearly playing from some sort of
deep preparation
and maybe why he he got what maybe could
be an advantage here right but it's but
it's a very dangerous position if you
don't sacrifice the exchange
let's just point out that white might be
threatening to take the knight elvira
and just take f7
right i mean
so there is even a good i was going to
say now we went from an intuitive idea
that we explained rationally to now
we're being concretely forced to
consider brook takes v2 because if we
don't
f7 might fall that is kind of funny
right it's an intuitive idea we
rationalize it for positional sort of
strategic reasons
and the more i look at it i don't know
that he has a better move to guard f7
ah you know yes of course there is also
like a small tactical shot even though
it loses like knight g4 and then take on
b2 but
we have to protect their seven pound
anyway no you mean like right away like
right away yeah you would love to try it
yes of course but then
because f7 is falling and then i mean
you take then queen f7 or maybe even
rocket screen like probably you take and
then take on the seventh so
um
we have a comment from chat that says
that these two i assume you're
referring
to
napomnishi and caron or maybe referring
skripchenko and wrench i don't know but
these two love complicated positions
you're right and this one is nutty so uh
great comment there from mungus we agree
that it's a it's a nutty position
and we love it me and elmira and maybe
maybe they do too maybe uh napandashi
and karwana um
yeah
it comes
my poker years come back to mind so like
i was having this tight aggressive style
so you weren't a bluffer no not a bluff
well i was a bluffer in some spots
because you should carefully choose them
yeah and then
also it's also a
risk-reward situation you have to
evaluate carefully right and then
what also comes to mind like when you're
playing the candidates this is where you
have to give it all right so you can
lose everything everywhere yeah
and the question what i wanted to ask
you i'm so sorry well fabi is still
thinking it's like so
what does it
why
in chess we want the candidates be truly
uh
deserving of this match you know that
they have to go through the
qualification path and play
30 50 games in order you know to to play
the world
champions so we want it to be a gauntlet
yes exactly i think i i've made the
final boss norwegian joke a few times
and magnus tweeted as such uh in
response to elon musk elon musk tweeted
a few days ago something about chess
and uh about how you know if a young
player's learning it like it's like a
video game map that's boring and all the
rules are defined and and then the
norwegian final boss is
you know it's kind of a jerk waiting at
the end to beat everybody um
on the board you know he's hard to beat
and i think uh
we just it's something something i guess
romantic and royal about the game right
we want there to be this epic story line
they fought their way through the all
the different levels to get to king
koopa at the end of the mario brothers
um
so anyway i don't know it's fun i i
wonder how i wonder how the outside
world feels about it because you know
there are many
different cultures i mean like tennis
doesn't have a world championship match
but it has a series of grand slams right
you have playoffs in other sports so i
don't know how people feel about it
outside looking in well we don't have
well i had that feeling first of all as
a professional chess player but then
also like now a commentator because i
feel that my prism is
gradually changing but we don't have a
universal uh system yet i mean where
like everyone can play the tournaments
qualify so um i think that we are
probably
going in that direction
and even magnus has expressed his views
i think that uh he wouldn't be against
it yeah no and magnus gets a lot of
credit for that because he's the guy
sitting on the throne saying
i don't know that i want there to be a
throne right maybe i want there to be a
different system you know but i i don't
i mean i think initially i really
respected and agreed with that i love
the excitement i love knockout
tournaments almost every tournament i've
ever designed on chess.com is a knockout
you know the speed chess championship
anything we do i think i think that's
very fun but
but i think a lot of people really like
the appeal of a match like a heavyweight
match too and i think some people
evidence would show that more people
tune in for that than like every other
thing in chess by far besides pog champs
okay that's another story um but okay
and rook e8 was played rookie eight wow
okay hold on so this was not
the move we were expecting
we wanted to give all the pieces because
they are not our pieces we wanted it but
the computer agreed by the way
after after letting it sit the computer
agreed that this was this was the best
move for black
including your a3 follow-up this this is
what the computer said was black's best
chance i like to look at it after the
movie's playing i don't like to predict
unless unless unless there's good reason
to predict with the engine i like the
eval bar but i keep the engine move till
after it's played most of the time to
keep my chest brain analyzing but after
after it was played i looked back at the
engine and the engine liked your move
rook takes b2 so this was best but okay
rook ge8 was the second best move and
now we're back to this position from
caruana
what happens on takes e5 i think we just
have to
analyze it jan
looks like he's about to move by the way
with his body language indeed he is but
he doesn't play it he plays bishop to c1
back to the f4 plan
you know you know what it's also a draw
yeah is it like yeah well that's exactly
what it was it's the silent rover
because he when he made the move he
looked he glanced that you know at
fabiano you know it's like
yeah and then uh well and then only he
well he knows it like i love the body
language we recognize in the players
because we've like been there like he
did that thing where like exactly like
amir elmer said it's a silent draw for
he moved and as he moved he looked up ah
and look at that fabiano went right back
will he play rookie eight
and will we have a draw
unfortunately one of us predicted that
this game would not be as spicy as we
wanted they have already proven me wrong
so i'm not going back and saying i was
right
um but i did predict a draw because i
thought that neither player would would
need to risk it almira because they're
leading the tournament for the record i
desperately hope i'm wrong here and that
favi plays rook takes b2
i have a feeling regarding so is this
the
ev no evie plus situation means that
you have to sacrifice
you got you gotta do it come on
bobby bobby everyone chant bobby i mean
come on chat
send him the uh the psychic powers
the strength to go for rook takes b2 but
it's so easy to take those decisions
when you're not feeling the pressure you
know like like i
it would be so difficult for me to
to do it over the board i think
you need to be completely sure yeah
and it's easy for us to say and it may
be what the engine also thinks is best
but the point is the reason that man is
very focused and nervous is because this
also risks losing to go for a line like
this right i mean like you're down the
exchange
your opponent still has this very nasty
light square bishop so
i will we will not hold it against
fabiano if he accepts the draw given the
situation he was also black
look at the time i think that's the most
important factor now like so
um
when you are like sacrificing an
exchange first of all even though it
feels very natural uh then you
you have to understand how to play the
next 10 moves almost but yeah and the
position has still a very concrete
character so yeah
even if root b2 a3 might feel very
natural that's like how many moves do
you still have left i don't see
dany what move we are no he is on move
32 so eight more moves eight more moves
okay then maybe
maybe this is possible
it's i don't know i i know that bobby
face
yeah i think he's kind of like uh he
just glanced back at his clock as well i
think he
we got some chant we got yeah i knew it
unfortunately chat
called it maybe i don't speak as fluid
faviano as i do hikaru but uh
i could i could see that our our efforts
will be wasted here i believe that yon
will probably play bishop to c1 and
accept the silent draw offer in return
from caruana
and we'll have our second peaceful
result could be wrong but how often do
you look at your opponent when you're
playing a chess game because i well i
have the feeling that i am so absorbed
by like by what's going on on the board
that i almost never look at my opponent
i'm the opposite i look at my opponent a
ton a ton
and i think i think there's a lot of
players that do i mean i i
i i don't know what it is and maybe it's
because i'm just
you know thinking that it's making more
of a difference than it actually is but
i feel like seeing
my opponents just reaction their focus
their emotional sort of like feelings
and reading the body language is i don't
know something i can't turn away from i
put more effort on the board
but i i do look at my opponent but
that's something which actually poker
taught me you know like yes well to well
to look at the body language you know to
look at well
to um
well
psychological the dimension became very
important to me then yeah so and maybe
it made me a better chess player as well
so but uh i still feel that
i should do it more often like
without disturbing the opponent of
course because it's it's not easy
because it's a very
thin line you know it's like
i've been thoughts that especially if
your opponent is known to be rather
emotive and maybe distract you or
whatever it can be like all right i
don't want to look at this look at this
person who's driving me crazy maybe
better just focus on the board but just
a glance of course sometimes is um
jan and nicara are probably the two most
expressive players in this event icaru
very well known for being a very you
know
expressive player uh with his emotions
facial expressions body language and
yawn too half of his facial expressions
are a meme on the internet i saw gotham
chess tweeting just now
a shrugging face from beyond some some
sort of meme about game review so anyway
yeah it's uh there we go and we're gonna
we're gonna stick we're gonna stick
right here because i think we are
seconds away from seeing
in fact we're about to see even a claim
so this is
might as well even just offer the draw
i believe no he's just he's going to
claim it so this rule for everyone
is very important for those who don't
speak over the board
especially a lead level chess if you
believe you are about to repeat the
position for the third time the proper
process is you make a claim before the
move is on the board i have made that
mistake because it's it's three-fold
it's position okay he just offers the
draw straight up and here we have a
result okay but i i will explain that
rule for those who don't know because
well well it's a little silly and kind
of weird because internet chess has
changed that because the internet just
tracks it for you so if you repeat the
position three times
you know chess.com server will just
automatically claim the draw so people
don't even have to think about this
anymore but if you ever play in an
over-the-board chess tournament
especially when with these stakes they
will be very strict on the rules which
is
because it's three-fold position not
three-fold move you have to claim it
because once you make the move
technically you're resetting it because
it's about whether the position has
occurred exactly that many times with
the same player on move and so you have
to make the claim before you make the
move otherwise you reset it so sorry for
the rant but it is an interesting little
nuance in chess but also it's uh
something that we've discussed uh
yesterday so like that's why you need
score first of all
that's one of the reasons and second i
was not even sure like i was thinking
about two other reasons maybe uh it's um
intellectual property like it's
completely different topic and maybe
it's also uh
like a legal proof that you won the game
because it should be signed you know by
both opponents so there there are
several elements of course that uh
which that's actually a super important
point because we don't think about
anything disingenuous happening in
events like this they're on camera the
players know each other but there are
very large scale tournaments right in
the u.s you have the world open where
there's literally hundreds of people
just in the open section and if you
don't get a signature from your opponent
that says you won
and they falsify another score sheet
it's quite possible you could have a
real controversy so great point from
elmira actually on that that one of the
most important purposes of a scoresheet
even with all the advancements in
technology
is proof
of a record of the game um
and okay we've already moved on over to
uh report for ruja good call oh
we've uh brought up that board whoa what
happened here another week ending
so for there is a feud yesterday he had
to defend
a very unpleasant one this is this is
more unpleasant than yesterday's battle
with for java
for sure
two rooks on the board is already
offering way more dynamic chances than
one
the fact that this rook has taken the
seventh rank
could spell danger
it puts you in a spot just to add
context at that even if you were able to
trade like b for c
it doesn't have the same value anymore
if white is also entering the seventh
rank with with a very devastating effect
on the king side
of course black has a d pawn and who
knows what that actually looks like but
just pointing out that if you were just
able to do this the game is basically
over so actually you might be able to do
this if you played before
now that we've now that we've given
context that if we used our imaginations
and the pawns were gone sometimes that
sometimes that gives you a plan first
you imagine and then you go for it then
you weaken your own king and then you
weaken your own king and that then you
lose the game yep
and then i'll play d3 or k2 and yeah
that's funny because if you play v4 it's
not a good way to move okay my apology
we were just so focused on the abstract
i think if you play yes let's let's move
something like h6 b4 after d3 are you
are you losing
uh maybe let's say yeah it looks like
the pawn is too fast so really good
point that as as nice as this idea is
farouza is in control should this become
a pure race black is faster
okay
um so
black is to move here of course so then
we need to make a move
something like h6 right well you see
this
it's a useful move
g6 because it's you know it doesn't do
much but we need um
yeah i do something i like h6
although h6 you know i always have this
feeling
somewhere because you have this
imaginary positions play f5 then the
king will go and h5 g6 and something
like this will happen
and something terrible will happen is
well the other thing of h6 i always
imagine either one of these pawns on
this square now you have the back rank
meaning that right with the king sitting
on h7 so you have to be careful before
the record it's funny because we're
playing imagineer wait a second he gave
up a bomb
wait you played rook a1 yes so
oh my
okay out of the imaginary into the fire
here we have we have
a huge moment right now in this game why
has aldi reza just given up the c6 pawn
for the record that is this is a moment
where i will look at the engine the
engine is just saying rook takes c6 and
then rook c7
what the bleep
oh my god but i i really think that
sometimes elijah runs out of patience he
doesn't want to defend passively this is
a very unpleasant position really this
is a very unpleasant ending and
um
he's trying to create some counter play
but i believe that uh
he's simply not on time like he wants to
take the age two pounds he takes the
pawn without hesitation for the record
and just
i mean
oh my gosh don't go anywhere ladies and
gentlemen this this could end up being
maybe the only decisive result we have
in the round and not one we saw coming
report just takes on c6 mm-hmm
immediately played rook h1 okay then i
play rook she's seven i know it's just
rick
it's literally the imaginary line i was
giving i was like hey imagine a world
everybody where somehow this rook gets
on c7 the game is over
and somehow ali reza
just clearly miscalculated something
very
i don't know what because
because he's such a strong player and
this is
quite
quite clear
okay let's see
when you take on h2 you still protect
the h7 pawn so okay okay we should
consider this but the problem is that we
need also
to play d3 maybe something like rook h3
rook g7 and then king h8 okay so let's
not just resigning
but drug g7 protects on g3
we need an an extra temp so we need to
play d3 and there is no way how we can
do this yeah if by the way elmira's
point if if the pawn was on d3 in any of
these lines it's completely different
right because now the king has to go
backward and the pawn advances and you
get a queen and this really brilliant
point that the pawn is guarded on h7 by
elmira that's really important the
problem is that while that's useful to
put the king there
white is just up pawns and
you can make almost any move with the
rook and you have the b-pawn you have
the e-pawn black has no moves
and the reason black has no moves is
because the king is in a mating net
right if you put the rook somewhere
just to put it on a square if the rook
ever moves off the eighth rank you have
checkmate
if you advance the h pawn the rook goes
back to the seventh ring you know it's
like we were talking about this like you
make the second move of the variation
but here's it seems like uh the
he wants to make d3 rook h2 at the same
time and then
and somehow you go for okay one
oh man this is
a surprise
and poor alireza ferrugia on his on his
birthday
is
is facing
a lot of pressure and of course one of
the things we should highlight amira is
you know to give credit
to part of the reason maybe he he made
this miscalculation is we haven't even
talked about the clock he has only four
minutes and i think that
frankly when we first came to the board
we were so focused on
the fantasy we thought it was a fantasy
that this would happen i wasn't even
looking at the clock but now we see
maybe why aldi reza misplayed that
position so clearly because he was very
nervous and remember there's no
increment so he looks at that clock he
hasn't played a lot of chess this year
you get those practical nerves
right and maybe you just you mismanaged
your time there well on the other hand
you know this uh
this position this ending is very
unpleasant so it's the physical feeling
that they you get the more you look
you don't want to defend it you know and
that's the nature of a mistake actually
because maybe a more passive defense uh
would be more sound but uh it's very
difficult like
from the human perspective once again to
uh to defend it right
and again you're making a great point
i'm not just trying to highlight that it
was maybe a mismanaged clock because he
you know hasn't played a lot of chess
that is a practical muscle that you know
that you're in shape with when you're
playing but you're making the point like
no one likes looking at a bad position
or a tough position right and the longer
you look the worse you feel
and that that sometimes puts you on lack
of a better term on tilt right in terms
of the way you're calculating
and now we see the wheels are coming off
super quickly here
h5 that's such a good move actually like
here
yeah here here comes the e pawn
so he'll take play rook h3
takes
he'll take back
no page three alireza probably has to
play rook h3 i i don't see anything else
so uh
but then probably you uh
you'll push e6
so if
let's say rook h3 so okay we'll look at
it so if rook h3 if you play e6
so what happens
[Music]
but if you go backward maybe you're
actually suddenly
in trouble right you have to run i
cannot go uh maybe i cannot go kangai
four
so i'm almost for king four okay three
then
i'm going to stay right here because
they they move fast here
we
we have 16 minutes for rapport two
minutes for ali reza perugia we are on
move 37 right now so that means we are
three moves away from time control
but those are three of the toughest
moves ali reza ferrugia has ever had to
play in his life
with with what's at stake here this is
this is very difficult
well he went for an active defense you
know like i
i have to praise it
so um
kinky full first but oh
no no but then it can take on g3 and
that's the same so now rookie threes
can be a threat yeah that was your idea
in fact rookie three is
okay it's dangerous or maybe then it
allows of course rook g7 rook h7 but
maybe white doesn't have more than a
draw i'm not sure it's like this is uh
uh a very concrete position so
let's say rook g3 okay
let's let's bring up the two board view
with analysis so we can look at this
line i don't want to lose the live
position for the fans but i just want to
show there we go we got rook takes g3
because this is an important line amir
is pointing out you have to give rook g7
first i think
and after the king goes to h8 you can
take again okay let's say yes so
remember white has a draw if you wanted
but how do we play for a win with this
aggressive king
okay
we cannot play e6 for sure
okay if e6 let's just show rookie three
and yes i was looking for okay three and
rookie six so then
uh and you still have a draw of course
so how to ollie reza ali reza has moved
rook takes g3
rapport
again pointing out e6 is not a threat
because of rookie 3 winning the pawn so
we think we're going to see rook g7 here
it comes
either king h8 or king f8 just to show
the fans likely the next move is king
back to g8 because now you have to guard
checkmate so
you still have to go right back to g8
even if you go to f8
uh
so
so you might as well go to h8 we're
going to have this position on the board
and then what we'll report fine
we've got uh
uh richard's birthday present to ollie
reza faruja may not be a welcome one
shout out to chat yeah this is a huge
moment for the now 19 year old ali reza
faruja did he just make move 40 yes they
did okay so
first that's the biggest problem
actually yeah i just took a deep breath
no but then like when you're having an
advantage basically when you're
defending a position and you have a plan
it's uh
well you don't want to reach the move
40. you want your opponent
like
well
to make a mistake of course because uh
now richard has
one hour to think
it's huge now that he's reached the time
control you don't want the person with
an advantage with a bunch of time on the
clock rapport will make sure he finds
the right approach
let's back up our approach quickly take
a peek at the bird's eye view because i
don't think that nakamura and rajava
have reached time control yet so just to
stay with the drama of the first stage
of these games again reminder to all the
fans you have to reach move 40 you get
more time on the clock
and then you can take a breath even if
you're the commentator and struggle with
anxiety
you can relax once you get more time
okay we've got oh whoa okay only move 34
12 minutes for hikaru three minutes look
at what's happened here this is
this is significantly better for recaro
than where we left it this is this is
truly a two result position i think for
white
what do you think well i think it's
probably equal probably equal but just a
centralized knight
of course no no i mean hikari is playing
uh for two results here but uh
knight is six uh well
it's probably just a draw so he of
course he will never exchange this
powerful knight against the bishop and
then
rajab created this tension on the um
king side so it's important of course to
have this in mind as well that the h
pawn also at some point
could
be very fast
i like rook c7 but then how to continue
here
with black
what if you just wait if you play bishop
g4 i don't know where the bishop was
before was it on j4
the bishop okay let's back up just a few
moves before back up a few moves before
so we had on d7 okay yeah it was on it
was on d7 but i'm curious how we got
here because when we left the position
the queen's oh so he played queen b5
that was it okay
so queen d5 rather than the moves we
were potentially suggesting of bishop c6
or rook d5 roger was feeling some danger
so decided to exchange into the end game
hikaru happy about that i i would think
um
he goes for an end game where white has
an edge mainly because a centralized
knight on a dark square one let's
highlight why we feel like white is in
control it's not just that the knight is
centralized is that the knight can't be
removed it's it's outposted here this
rook has the aggressive opportunities to
both poke at the a-pawn and even this
is this on the agenda right because if
the rooks come off we highlighted that a
rook ending is likely an easy draw
but the knight end game versus the
bishop
that's a position that's gonna be very
hard to hold especially with now less
than two minutes forever java who by the
way
still has five or six more moves to make
first of all i wanted to come back to
this queen d5 move this is the move you
were you were trying to explain like how
do you take these decisions so this is a
move of a person who doesn't want to
lose
you know this like we were considering
uh rook d5 and bishop c6 because you
know we were thinking also about the win
but i think that transposing to this end
game show clear intentions that while
you draw is okay you want to equalize
with black so this is maybe something
here he was okay with beforehand
before this game so and then
if you were mentioning uh the rook
exchange uh later on you still have to
be careful because i can bring my king
to the king side your pawns are weak
yeah
you can lose
the h4 pound this threat of rook c6 the
rook exchange with these okay yeah you
can't be you can't be crazy aggressive
because the king can come in but notice
that for java avoids it with a minute
and nine seconds on the clock for five
more moves and again this is if you've
watched a lot of overboard
over-the-board chess in your life fans
this is
not a time control with increment that
one minute is very different than
traditional chess that you've watched
where they're getting time added on
every move so we can't go anywhere
although by the way
rapport may be beating farouza here soon
we have drama here in round two and he
leaves the bishop on priests
the bishop is on pre but it can't be
taken because of rookie five jack just a
show it's a it's a quick fork and black
regains the knight that would be the
rook ending that rajava desperately
wants right 96 is what he's praying for
i think hikaru may just play brook c6
anyway
even after rook d5
it attacks the bishop it attacks the
pawn
i think hikaru is going to win this game
i really do i think that with this
why didn't he play bishop g4
instead of bishop do you think
rook c6 was like a positional threat
let's just uh
well
go back to the position be after rook c7
after rook c7 uh
here
now the last position where he played
the in the live yeah
so here like just back from g6
bishop g4 bishop g4 so was it rook c6
like a positional threat i wanted to
know
it might be right because if takes takes
the knight in game
is potentially very unpleasant of course
rook c6 played where java instantly
plays rookie five check in only two
seconds by the way which he needs to do
so
now he has a minute and seven seconds
for four moves
hey carl puts the king on f2
for a job off
oh man
okay place bishop d7 but this is
it's it's a pawn now the car the car is
going to take the pawn on a6 and
yes but maybe he's looking for gtx h4
takes rookie four
can you protect us yes you can protect
knight f3
um
[Music]
he's also he's trying to create some
counter play
rook takes a six wins a pawn you're
suggesting g takes h4 g takes h4 and
rookie
with a target that's interesting okay so
ricardo's gonna have to calculate
you could also you know play a weird
tempi move right ask ask an awkward
question to the bishop i think it likely
just tucks itself on c8 if you let it so
that means you probably want to take the
pawn down while you have the chance
right because
just remind everybody the whole reason
the bishop
had to go to d7 is you couldn't go to ca
the rook is here right so if you don't
take the pawn now and you move the rook
somewhere else rojava likely just
defends the pawn
yeah
you should be consistent you play with
c6 you have to take rook a6
yeah i'm just wondering if there's some
trick i'm like i'm like i'm playing full
hikaru here i just i've watched too much
of this guy to be like we assume this is
the obvious move he makes some weird
move because there's a nice c6 fork or
something i don't know i'm just like so
you you've lost your innocence i've lost
my innocence it took my innocence long
ago which is a whole nother story we
will get into on a different show um but
yeah
well i i still have this uh the romance
excited and it looks like always hopes
for the best you know it's like you take
the pawn okay he did okay you took the
ball all right rajabov takes h4 good
call elmira
that's exactly the move we expected
so
probably rookie four i
[Music]
using his time he has 30 seconds and
counting
that's true it happened to me once like
live on the french television you know
actually
uh
fabiana gave his whole rook against
sergey karakin and then i was like
they're wrong
i was like exactly like mine
when you're just screaming
and i fall out of my chair all the time
it's well documented so um rookie four
played that was a very well spotted
quick quick heads up elmira white is
still better
but it does show the game is not over
right because if black wins this pawn so
just uh to um
to show that i wanted to meet king g3 of
course by rook g4 so that's just
to show everybody small tactical ideas
we cannot defend the spawns you can't
put the king on h3 because there's a
lined bishop with check which means so
if you do this real quick fun exercise
for everyone to get better king g3 rook
g4 check if you move the king you lose
the pawn anyway so why play king g3
and if rook g4 check and you play king
h3 you've walked into the line of a
discovered check so the rook will
capture the knight
and unleash a check on the king and win
a piece for free fall for it
so
i don't think he'll play king g3 but he
has seven minutes to decide the
trickiest possible move
for rajabov's 40th i think i
well
how can you continue here so you have
probably two okay i love you
is on the clock
and if he moves his bishop you want to
play a4 okay he's got five seconds
what's going on you have to move move
grandmaster move okay
there we go bishop to c8
oh man i'm too old for this elmira that
was two seconds
of my life that are way too long i will
never get it back oh man
okay rajaba moves
and i feel better
sorry i just yelled move grandmaster
that felt i feel ashamed about yelling
at him about that but now this actually
explains that i really loved this movie
d6 because my idea of course was to play
a4 you know to create the path sound i'm
not sure like if it's like the best idea
but like
to remove the bishop from this diagonal
first and then but hikaru goes rook d8
agaro has a very creative or sorry
a very confident way he creatively moved
the rook there i talked about the the
screwing in of the square gary kasparov
style if you notice hikaru moving the
rook kind of drilling it into the square
d8 just
right like i know i'm winning and i'm
reminding you right there which again it
almost becomes like a subtle habit and
and players who've converted a lot of
advantages in their life you just you
kind of build the type of like poise you
have right when you know that you're on
the prowl a little bit you know and and
i think he nicaragua knows that this is
his game to get i i think he's going to
take the victory i really do and what a
bounce-back game that would be for the
five-time u.s champ
so man surgeon tone to ground control
should we go on a break major tom
degrasse i i don't want to because i
don't want to miss i want to go back to
the perugia game now so now that this
has reached time control let's please
back up and head back over to the frucia
game because
we may we may get a look at rapport and
know very quickly that he's going to be
thinking for a while
but that game is moments away from from
winning so
let's go back here we're flipping over
to rapport
versus for ruja
and
by the way when are we going to have a
basketball players you know in uh in the
chess show like i'm really looking
forward to michael jordan you know
i appreciate that we have the nfl blitz
champs so
we are also working on an mba event
really yeah and i guess actually i just
signed the contract today so i'm gonna
spill the news um my my vp of
partnerships
alex brewer might be a little irritated
but i think i can there wasn't a plan
for announcing any other way that
gordon hayward is someone who recently
kind of struck up a partnership with us
he's an nba all-star he's going to be
streaming some chess he has an active
fan club and we are
we were actually closer to doing an nba
style podcamp than we were at nfl event
but um we didn't pull it off before the
playoffs started so we had to kind of
pull the breaks up but there there's a
lot of nba players who play regularly on
chess.com a lot of people know klay
thompson a big chess player uh daryl
mori who's a buddy of mine who was
actually texting me in the middle of
this game he's the the gm for the
philadelphia 76ers place everyday on
chess.com so i just wanted to share a
secret you know like
well sometimes you think like what are
your wildest dreams yes like as a kid
like once again like my wildest dreams
were like um writing dragons okay this
one you know
not even close not even close
then uh singing opera you know like so
not even close and then playing chess
against uh michael jordan so maybe to
get that closer
closer what happened so who knows so i
don't know that uh mj is a chess player
i don't know if mj's a chess player i
don't know that he's not someone who i
know is on chess.com
but uh
but there are many others so
anyway yeah so look tune ahead everybody
we uh we have a lot more a lot more
fun celebrity chess events coming up uh
this year and around the corner and in
many ways uh just working with different
celebs who we know love chess like cave
on thibodeau having a fan club gordon
hayward is a big part of some other
stuff that we're planning to do so
anyway um
we've we've got two matches remaining if
you just got here this is round two of
the 2022 fidei candidates the two
matches that are in the books were both
ended in draws fabiano caruana and jana
pomnishi the co-leaders through their
game
and then we had a very quick and
surprising repetition from jan christoph
duda and dingley wren but of the two
matches still going the drama right now
is really focused on richard rapford
because he knows
he knows his advantage is winning
but he knows it might be now or never so
all right our break comes now or never
because the policio de centonia is
beautiful as it is
um also
has restrooms can i say that on air that
may not be the most professional thing
i've ever done that sound like it said
we're gonna we're gonna take a break and
we will be back with more from madrid in
just a minute
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of
the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a maybe best one in
madrid
punto
[Music]
the oldest player in madrid at age 35
timur rajab is competing for the third
time at the candidates and for the first
time in nine years
once ranked in the top five in the world
raja qualified for the candidates two
years ago but was unable to compete due
to covet concerns for this year's
tournament fide offered raja a wild card
which raja accepted
born in the same azerbaijani city as
former world champion gary kasparov raja
beat gary kasparov at age 15. in fact he
has never lost to the former world
champion
one of the peak achievements of
rajabov's career was his victory at the
fide world cup
in that tournament he defeated the top
seed ding lyren in the final to qualify
for the 2020 candidates tournament
in madrid raja hopes that he can lean on
his experience at the candidates to post
some impressive performances even though
expectations for him here are not as
high as they once were
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid like queen isabella before them
the candidates is all about leaving a
legacy
we're back we are back in madrid
rapport
focused on his game i love this view i
love just looking at it makes me feel
like i'm right there in the playing hall
with him
richard rapport of course is uh
is still in the position we left we kind
of had the sense we knew we could take
that break so we took it it's round two
of chess.com coverage of the 2022 feed a
candidates in case you missed it with me
here almira kripchenko international
master danny wrench our man hammer is
taking a little bit of a break right now
but we're going to continue to have the
action for you we have two more games
still going
if you missed it high level reset two
games are already in the books uh the
two tournament co-leaders drew their
game napomnishi and caruana respectively
and then dingley wren held with black
versus john christoph duda so
will ali reza barusha be able to hold
this bla with black here that would be a
birthday miracle elmira
well
uh
and you know
richard is still thinking yeah that's
it means that maybe
the win is not so clear he certainly has
to find uh
the winning variation but
look at his face he he's looking puzzled
so maybe something that um i rivers are
calculated that uh
has a finesse
what do you think
let's let's try
do something like
let's give let's give it a check
we're not going to calculate one because
i'm too lazy for that
no kidding two i think it's easier for
the fans to showboard so let's try to
analyze what we think he's calculating
again we've highlighted several times
that e6
is not on the agenda
because with this pawn controlling the
f5 square white would simply lose the
pawn
so that's key
but what else can you do so what if you
just move the king first uh well i was
thinking about check first
one thing that i wanted to say that
analyze and calculate is like
if you can make a move and you're pretty
sure like you make it and it's already
half a move you know so you are
advancing in your calculations so just
it's just
an advice like for
for the players so i was actually
looking at uh g7
rook bg7 first not let the king on e4
part of my idea of this because we'll
come back to it was that if i make the
rook choose
maybe there's an idea that i'm running
in
right for the mating net and i'm not
actually winning this game with a pawn
push just to show like some fantasy
lines if we get something like this and
you come in
you're actually threatening both the
rook and you're threatening to mate with
checking me i didn't see rook h5
ah that's the move okay that holds
everything together that's the only move
by the way i think because
otherwise i'm attacking the rook and
threatening rook g7
and then rook h8 is checkmate so what an
idea okay so that doesn't work so now
we're on to elmira's idea which is
rook b to g7
king of eight
well so now i guess well i cannot play
sex still because you will take the puns
so now we have to find like what is the
follow-up
uh can we i know we cannot exchange
wanted to play uh
rook g7 but this is not easy at all
because
what what happen we'll just show it so
they'll be established then it's just a
draw of course if it takes takes yes
then uh
but how is it
no because you will always exchange the
bounce because you cannot go like easy
my idea was to go k5 king e6 but it's
way too slow because my idea too like
if you go here here and here is it not
but i guess black is holding this is
this just feels so scary for black but
apparently it's holding okay um
no no that's not enough of course like
you have two dangerous rooks of course
so you have to keep them yeah but uh
like my first idea was to play rook d7
but of course it doesn't work because by
the way he's played the move king of
four so can give four probably won't be
my idea he'll have something better than
that but i do like this idea in theory
you force the rook here before you've
advanced
and kind of give your king
a touchdown run ahead from checkmate
right it doesn't mean it works but you
are now within striking distance of
ending the game with a forceful
variation so we have to play rook e3
okay the rook is hanging first of all
and we have to keep
the rook on the e file to attack the e
pawn so that's very important
so i will always take with the check on
e5 and then i will have this defensive
resource rook
h5
so that's very important like i think we
have to we are almost forced to play
rookie three so you have to play this
well now i that i know your idea of
course it reminds me by the way of the
game nigel short played against timmon
you know in a
completely different uh like context
where the king came from g1
h2 g3 and came to h6 mating like with
the whole
board of
the boat is the most forward yes full of
most famous king walk of all time if you
if you've never seen this game chat just
do yourselves a favor and just google
nigel short john timmon just in the
king's march what king's march last
king's march if you just google
short timing like it's like the first
result even before king's march because
it's such a such a beautiful elegant
display of what a king can do to help a
checkmate attack succeed
rookie 3 has been played
so rapport not going to go for king g5
and you see the more the engine thinks
the more it thinks as we said that it's
closer and closer to potentially holding
so
it is ali reza faruga's birthday again
we've been talking about it happy
birthday to the young man
he would love a birthday present of
holding this game
we need to find
like the idea
how to proceed because
we have all these checks you know like
there is nothing uh
concrete once again and it's very
strange because when you have these
powerful rooks you think that you are in
the word you think in the game like in
two moves yeah and the
pasty bond and that like
from
now you know
this was a brilliant defense i mean
seriously it's
it's
it was such a risky defense right and
obviously were
both us and the eval bar we weren't
alone in saying what are you doing right
you're giving white this massive
advantage
but i wonder how deeply
ali reza was was looking ahead right
where did he where did his evaluation
because part of calculating his two
parts right there's the i go there he
goes there i go there he goes you go as
far as you can and then at some point
you're evaluating in an abstract way a
position that is not in front of you and
you have to make your decision about
whether you can hold it whether it's an
increase of your advantage so i wonder
like did he just go to this point
and just realize that look
this isn't as easy as it looks i know he
has a draw but there's no mate and if he
doesn't have a mate
i got a one right i wonder what the what
the abstract sort of uh goal was that he
had in mind if there was a chance to
talk to him about it
we might ask him we might ask him that
if we get a chance after the game so
what is the position that we have in
mind because like that's why i wanted to
exchange rooks you know to win the
d-bound and to keep both pumps that's
like something that i was aiming for
is there's is this something that we can
we can obtain
yep
so rookie three
um
can we play um
rook d7 is a draw even after checks of
course we've established this so um how
can we try
yeah it's one of those positions where
again the the eval isn't telling the
whole story everyone because
and i'm not saying there isn't a winning
path here for white but obviously
rapport doesn't see it or he would have
moved right and we don't see it and even
the engine if you're running it on
chess.com events like many of you might
be
it says white's winning but there's no
concrete suggestion right i mean the
computer right now is basically
suggesting to check and then go back but
you know why because there is a concrete
threat to rook f8
you know you have to do something about
it yeah when you go here you're
threatening checkmate but my question is
the computer's suggesting this but why
is the rook on c7 any better than
like
what's the next move right and you by
the way the computer just proved my
point it's bouncing around again between
rook c to g7 and rook h to g7 so the
point is
sometimes you have positions where
the computer is not wrong mathematically
and and is here to
to guide us but converting this is a
completely different story and and and
coming up with a plan that has risk like
activating your king to lose a pawn
uh you know
lucky for raphort is this he always has
a draw
of course but always has a drop
how how disappointed is he going to be
and how
uh inspiring it would be also for eileer
as uh you know like
he started the tournament with two draws
it's uh it's very difficult especially
on this level so and he
played two very interesting games and
even if today you know it was more of
um
a positional you know advantage for
richard
he
probably escaped tactically
yeah so that's uh
but once again you know i want to play
rook fade and take the pound but then
you're mating me
yeah so maybe rook fade is a threat and
then i will go back yes i don't know or
maybe rook fades and then rookie four
and i'm checking you and that's a draw
like this as well so it's not black to
move yet but just let's say b4 okay i
wanted so let's say y not b4 then rook
f8 and then i'm probably checking you so
you know so it's uh well you can come in
but now i'm just checking you forever
and actually funnily enough
rook so that's what i wanted to do i
would love to play a move like this
but you just can't and so it's just a
draw um
wow
well
ironically the only game with a decisive
result might be a game that
we haven't given as much attention as we
normally do with the superstars such as
hikara nakamura but i think it's time
for us to back up a little bit and go
back over to that game hikaru's
advantage
seems to have
increased
against rajab off after the time
scramble craziness that was
we now have a position where
rajab has been unable
to get the pawn on h4
but uh but ikaro is threatening to win
yet another pawn and then
push him so ah so that was the reason
like behind the maneuver like d6
you know bishop c8 and rook d5 so he
didn't want to create a passport he
wants to well to win the b5 bomb
and uh
and then i mean the the knight
centralized defended by c3 is really key
i think it makes white's
chances of of dealing with things here
so well right the night is just such an
irritating piece in terms of preventing
progress and having tricks so i'm sure
ricardo is calculating forced lines now
like what does the race look like if i
take b5 it breaks and you take h4 and a4
and you know you give a check or
something and you try to push and i'm
pushing too right i think that this is
one of those positions where when you're
looking at it
sometimes they're evaluating abstract
positional improvements right because
you can't realistically calculate the
game to the end in a middle game you
have to improve on your on your
advantages this is a position where you
could go 20 30 moves down the road if
possible if you needed to you know you
don't want to totally do that yet but
you're not outside the realm of
calculating a very concrete forced
variation of your hikaru here
and also yes this is like a very
important point but also i wanted to say
like if you would create a passpond by
playing a four b takes b takes it makes
it easier also for black at some point
to sacrifice the bishop maybe to get two
pounds and that would be a draw even
like so that's also like
i think he wants to keep the three pawns
here
it's a good point he plays a little bit
of tickle there let's let's bring up the
analysis board so we can maybe show
almira's variation there i think that
it's important to show that
you don't just
you don't just want to play a move like
like before like g6 before i mean when
the rook was in d6 i think so okay so a
few moves before
so here i suggested day four because i
wanted to to create the past sponsor
but even if it's a race so you see well
i'm not sure like how accurate it is
yeah just in case so even if i play
a5 a6 it makes it easier for black to
sacrifice the bishop and then to take
the c3 pawn you know something like this
that was my idea so makes it easier i
mean if you just uh not not to say what
happened but just to say like if black
sacrifices
and gets something like this
you're drawing and you see the table
base just kicked in there and says it's
a draw
rook
rook and knight versus king and rook
even if white is to corral these two
pawns and win them for free is not a win
so table base says draw um
but that type of variation is exactly
what a car wants to avoid on mirror's
point is he's trying to corral this pawn
in a different way although he
he hasn't quite been able to do it and
he hasn't had the
let's let's also look at why he didn't
just take right
because he played
c5 bishop d7
so you take it
i don't know maybe he feels that uh
black has enough counterplay
i guess so
because uh
yeah he's not sure so maybe this is
not going to be as easy to win as we
thought something like check and the
king moves and
okay now check no maybe even check first
where do you go yes i want first to yeah
uh
yeah black's not really playing
oh yeah to create a few threats and i
mean you're you
check and torture
i know check i can even take but if you
if you go king before also i was a bit
afraid that after king
e4 rook h3 can give four
uh white could run
into a mating net if it's possible with
uh with the king green on if like you
have to be careful
you know here here you could almost
maybe i can take take
i mean
or run h4 also it's possible you see
it's it's it's not trivial at all yeah
no
this is a really instructive point to
show that it's funny because it's not
even so much about the race it's not
that you're not taking this pawn because
you believe that white can't win the
race
it's partly because if black gets this
pawn it opens up all these chances to
draw because of the checks right so
hikaru's
hikaru's sort of stubbornness to not
just grab the pawn
is he he really wants to find a way
to win this pawn on favorable
circumstances he can't let this rook get
in the spot
where suddenly he's got a whole bunch of
draws
and what would you check there was one
moment i'm so sorry
like when the rook was on c5 and uh the
bishop on d7 here
uh another possibility was to take
knight b5 here but it's probably is
coming to the same position yes like 95.
[Music]
yes exactly so and then uh
your your pieces are even farther yeah
so that's why he carried it into the
circuit yeah there's no i mean whether
you push a4 or bring the knight back and
directly transpose then you go yeah so
okay so then it doesn't work
so now we understand now we understand
no it's not knight f3 is a very good
move
knight f3 protects the pawn even more
importantly prevents potential
counter play for a draw of some kind and
unfortunately if you're icaru it also
removes the knight from the central
position that was threatening to win the
pawn so he's sort of
back to square one but i i'm going to
stay with my prediction that i i think
it car is going to find a way here
because this is a two result game for
white he's going to grind it if he finds
a way to get his him and his opponent
back in mutual time pressure who do you
take in a mutual time scramble hikaru
nakamura or the field right of course
it's not even a question right so i just
i feel like this is a okay rajab
incredible player and if he and if he's
proving as we look at it that there's
some sort of optimal defense here i mean
look at this it's kind of it's kind of
funny right there's some geometry here
the brook defends the bishop the bishop
is holding the rook is keeping
everything at bay it keeps the king out
right of the e file it keeps the knight
back of guarding the pawn
so this is knight f3 is like it's a
perfect prophylactic move
like this is even though like it was
very beautiful on d4
like i have this feeling of how
important is to deprive your opponent of
any kind of counter play once again
yeah even in the end game so it's like
uh
i like this move very much so he could
keep on increasing the pressure and
maybe even playing until the very end
yeah in the time travel
so and win the game in the time trouble
because he i think that's what he wants
to do right
if he can find a way to keep this exact
position and just put both players under
two minutes he'd be happy that's what
akara would like so uh
okay
well uh we'll see whether he can do it
if you're just tuning in of course we
know that richard rapport is also trying
to see if he can do it and deliver the
birthday boy some
a very unwanted present with a loss
there but we've got a lot ahead we had
two games finished and on that note uh
we also had an interview with one of
those players earlier today dingley wren
and young christoph judah they played
their game to a draw uh and it came out
of nowhere moments after the match our
own dean of bellinghay caught up with
young christophe duda about the game
jan schustev thanks for joining we just
had your opponent dean loren here in the
studio you have heard everything that he
said about the game is there something
that you would like to object
yeah
[Music]
yeah i'm not very satisfied with this
game to be honest i
prepared the idea in the opening which
of course didn't give me any objective
advantage but i hope actually to get a
playback position and outplay him
somehow the process but
the thing was that
i wasn't feeling very uncomfortable
in this position and i mean i
yeah i basically didn't know what to do
so
and i think it was worse um
i mean i i really didn't like my
position and didn't know what what to do
and
um yeah but i think that
he was better he probably could have
played something better i
i think 8xb3 maybe wasn't the best move
in the position
um yeah but i i mean i missed a lot of
stuff also in this game like he played
some moves i wouldn't have found in
million years you know so
um yeah i'm
quite content with the draw even in the
final position i guess it's sort of
balanced but i mean he's he has two
bishops he he's better and i have to
just you know do nothing and not towards
my position
so you're taking the road very smoothly
step by step game by game
yeah i mean today's raw is nothing i
mean yesterday of course i exported a
winning position and was very upset
about this game
especially that i did see a winning
continuation but at the very last moment
i changed my mind and i actually spoiled
it totally so
yeah yesterday was kind of painful today
i mean it's
just you know very boring game actually
recovering from yesterday yes
right you are actually the first player
who
knew he was going to play the candidates
so you had almost one year to prepare
how does it feel to finally be playing
the tournament
of the year
yeah it's very nice
actually i didn't know how much time i
had because the candidates weren't
announced at the time i qualified to
them
yeah i was actually very shocked you
know that i qualified and because it
involved beating magnus
the world's
so
well interesting it's a funny storyline
we haven't thought too much about he was
one of the first players to know he was
playing in the candidates but he makes a
good point he didn't know when he was
going to be playing in the candidates or
the field of players before him uh once
again the results versus rapport and
dingley run have not been updated so
this was the head-to-head
pairings and schedule set up for young
chris of duda coming into the candidates
the biggest thing that jumps out to me
elmira is that he's playing caruana
tomorrow your thoughts on how he might
be feeling he said to dina right he said
okay first game was kind of tough right
and now it's going to take some rest
here it's a quick draw right he didn't
see what to do so he you know he didn't
want to go crazy
maybe maybe he also did it because he
wants extra time to prepare for that guy
fabiano carwana what do you think yeah
that's what i wanted to say so
maybe fabi took this decision of course
he was a long time and the position was
very complicated but he also knew that
he's having white tomorrow and well
let's have a look at the score right so
he is leading by three victories right
so it's uh
i i'm not even sure that players they
take the strategic decisions so they
look so okay
should i like
push harder here like is this more
important around but this is certainly
something that uh he's taking into
consideration
but while we were looking at this
absolutely brilliant young man you know
young sister of duda i wanted to ask you
uh do you think that this was the first
polish player to
to play the candidates i know you're
you're quizzing me because you know the
answer
actually i didn't know the answer myself
i don't i'd have to think back of great
polish players i don't know off the top
of my head but it is a great trivia
question maybe for the chat maybe a chat
answer yes i actually want to god answer
was this the first polish player to play
in the candidates because i don't know
the answer no they think it's like it's
it's not so trivial because like uh
first what do you consider the
candidates for example if you're
thinking about the
uh london tournament in 1883 the candid
like historically the first candidates
kind of the candidates yes but you know
that johannes secretary is actually a
police player you know so he won this
tournament actually by like by three
points margin and then went on to lose
uh like against tennis a lot of people
thought zukertor was maybe the strongest
player in the world there for well so
exactly so that's uh something very
interesting at the time he was born like
he was a polish chess player of course
but that was a russian empire once again
but i think that's a polish legacy
polish chess legacy yep
no great stuff and obviously young
christoph duda wants to continue to
build on a polish chess legacy and maybe
help inspire
the growth of the rebirthing or you know
continued growth for chess culture that
while while has a lot of history hasn't
had a lot of stars in the in the top of
the world i mean that's why i didn't
know it was a great question because
i myself
i mean i can't think of a lot of great i
mean like i'm saying like world
championship level polish players right
there of course there are many great
grand masters from poland but young
christophe dudas said in in a quote that
he had uh we you know we quoted but
we'll bring it up again at some point
but he said he always thought he would
be world champion like this guy believes
that that he's going to be the world
chess champion and he certainly
would like to to get that shot um by uh
by winning the candidates so but he
himself was inspired also by the games
of akiba rubinstein you know that's like
i feel that he has a great future ahead
of him so um
let's see first how he does against fabi
tomorrow for sure because as almir said
the first point in question we asked
remember he has three losses
he has three losses two faviano car one
as we switch over here to the aldi reza
faruga game uh we've had
we've had a move made rook f7 check and
then king to g8
um
no it was a rogue g7 or king f8 probably
or g7
but still no
no concrete action and the problem with
committing your rooks in that way elmira
is that okay i guess it prevents working
fate so maybe that was his idea right i
was going to say
it limits your chances for other
opportunities because now the king is
attacking both rooks right so there's
never going to be an opportunity where
you you know you would move the rook to
some other square to attack something or
whatever so
uh so can you try before here that was
my plan beforehand so is does this work
the reason b4 might be good is because
you're taking advantage of the fact that
the d-pawn can't push at this exact time
right so just want to push like b4 b5 so
like uh how do you defend here
so what if black
plays rookie one check
so that he can't check that was in my
head oh apparently that's losing i did
something like to what
i don't know like i i i first of all ah
you can now check and take yes okay
that's the difference and you're
questioning you're threatening
among many other things your king is now
in the fate of the king is on face so
there's no rook f8 okay so that's
actually
can i try before here okay that's a
really interesting point i want to
highlight again about rook f7 maybe
black can't play rook f8 and we'll
analyze that next maybe instead of
rookie one
but before but this is this is a this is
a threat that you have
if black makes a mistake you're now
threatening to check and take here
which you were not you were not
threatening when the rook was still
on
g3 right
so like i'm trying to find uh
what you see by the way we have another
check
played
mm-hmm
so if rook h8 then at least to the same
position than uh with rogue d7 so it's
the same okay shaking g7 even if your
king is a little bit farther so it's
like okay shade here when i want like i
mean oh no yes no no i mean so it leads
probably to the same jewish position
even if even if your king is a little
bit farther from the e pawn yes i think
that
maybe you can simply
attack the b-pawn and take it so this
doesn't work for sure
well it's interesting because we were
talking about
maybe one of the only chances that
rapport would have to win this would be
some sort of some sort of crazy king
walk and
even though hammer's not here i actually
want to show that crazy king walk on the
telestrator real quick you okay with
that of course i'll leave you alone for
just just a moment you mean the game
let's look at this leave you alone for
just a moment and show that game it's an
absolute jewel yes of course one of the
most epic
games you could ever see in chess oh hi
there everybody uh
final position oh no
this is we're showing the final position
but no we can we can show a lot about
this game so
this game's dominance is really
a positional lesson about the power of
having control over only one open file
on the board because white's brooks
dominating the d file prevent black from
doing anything to change the position
here the queen and bishop as cute as
they look over there are actually
threatening nothing on the king's side
as long as the knights on f3 and so
snapshot you look at the position
and none of black's pieces can do
anything but only one white piece is not
helping in the current attack
it's actually this guy right here so
that idea inspired king h2 i remember
the first time i saw this game i
blew my mind the king starts moving
forward and when your opponent is
shuffling rook c8 rookie eight when
you're about to make the most epic king
march in the history of chess you know
that you have problems here uh and
bishop c8 eventually played but too
little too late white plays king to g5
of course you could take the brook that
would have allowed king to h6 and any
move on the board is met with queen to
g7 checkmate that's kind of cool how it
does that right there i like this
touchscreen camera i don't know what you
were complaining about this is awesome
i'm going to steal hammer time from now
on but okay this
is an incredible game look it up also
recommend john dunn's understanding
chess move by move there's a great
breakdown of the positional lessons of
this game a huge shout out to john nunn
for a great book i'm going to head back
over here because that was a lot of fun
well you stole hummer's thunder i did i
still i stole the bleep out of hammer's
thunder that was awesome
and i am happy about that that was that
was so much fun so um way to go team
pulling pulling up that game that's i
mean that's
that's is that not in everyone's like
top 10 favorite chess games like ever
that's it's a pretty awesome game
well you know the thing is like when you
look at the position and i i just i can
imagine young simon like of course his
position is uh hopeless but
when nigel short played king h2 i was
not sure he realized it's sort of like
okay you make a move you know you're
trying to improve
but king g3 then you understand then it
dawns and you know that's i think
uh i like brings
i always smile when i think about this
game because this is uh
well the aesthetical beauty is very
important to me so this is so beautiful
absolutely
an absolute masterpiece i love the point
you made like at what point did it dawn
on yon timmon right not maybe not on
king h2 but the moment the king goes to
g3 you're like
okay oh bleep right
um
yeah it's the great game i don't know
that ravport is is coming up with
anything here and and talk about a great
gift for ferocious birthday if he were
to hold this end game in spectacular
fashion with the very aggressive
approach he took
an approach we were critical of and and
kind of shocked to see but what an
amazing defensive setup it would be
unless rapport has another idea he's
repeated moves a couple times here so oh
wait a second like that's what i'm
trying to establish like rook g7 king f8
some king of fate
okay
i don't know now it's not a threefold
repetition yet but uh
he cannot well he can play
he cannot even play rook ages seven then
because then he will have to repeat and
then
that's what i'm saying the risk of this
is okay initially i was highlighting
that the king is attacking them
oh no he i think he is still hitting the
draw no he no he like took a nut he has
to play this rook the other rook would
have been he will probably take on g6
then i don't know like well okay well
king king is the only move so it'll be
played here in moments
and we'll find out if rapport has more
than
just a concession in his mind that that
we have peace
um
and you see eliza is looking at the
square
yes that's his nipples like he's doing
the same thing because like rotation the
seventh still yeah
does not offer him the possibility to
claim the threefold repetition but uh so
king of shades
and but and it's good that he checks
though because sometimes you make
mistakes right sometimes you think it's
not three move repetition if your rap
work right but you actually did mess up
and you know we can we can do a quick
discount double check
so so let's see so i checked to tolerate
this this so here we have this position
here
okay this is
what
it goes from two
two
and now two okay so so actually yeah
even even this position here and the d
he does take g6 okay we still have
action that makes me happy
um
[Music]
but again shout out to perugia right
because even though the game continues
it doesn't mean that he hasn't already
proven that he was correct that he took
a really aggressive defense
even if there was something better for
rapport that he missed we don't i mean
you know we can look at it later
um
well i don't know i find it insanely
difficult to play the rook and games
after having studied like maybe millions
of hours like i still don't know you
think i have this feeling so
which feeling specifically is it like
it's very difficult to play this with
something so i don't know like like
i feel like uh if i'm having an opponent
i will make a draw and then like if i'm
defending i will lose you know so it's
uh
it's a very unpleasant feeling so um
well he took a lot of time on that move
he's taken he's actually in hindsight
banished his time well even though he
was under time pressure elmira how
impressed have you been with his nerves
just at this point right i mean it's
only two games in
we may be applauding a rather brilliant
active defense which you were saying
earlier divoretsky always talks about
active defense versus passive but i mean
how impressed have you been with with
the young man's just poise at this point
actually like just uh
well active defense also
very often implies also sacrificing
something like when you activate your
pieces you usually give up a town or
something but it's like
sort of
much better defense than the passive
month so for for example they have a
material balance like until until now
and
i i feel that larissa
still has to be very precise here of
course so
after rook g6 i was thinking about style
my ideas but i cannot create two crazy
at the rooks time so uh
the point everybody elmira is saying if
you just took away all of black's pieces
it's a draw the king is still mated
but you can't get rid of everything at
once so you have to play a very precise
move here
and
okay moving the rook just let me just
make this makes because it makes sense
because we want to play d3
either either rookie 2 or rookie 1 both
make sense because you're threatening
rook f1 check first of all and d3
right so so i'm expecting him to move
his rook to either e2 or e1 they both
threaten kind of the same thing
um
and so the question is maybe rookie 2 is
a better option because you want also to
take the pawn oh okay so yeah so now we
have a reason to favor this one so we
favor rookie two because it has a third
threat one
two
three
well at least when you're weighing the
options probably this is the most
rational one i don't know if it loses on
the spot or not so
and then the question is where does the
rook
go to deal with this threat
yeah we're not considering lots of
checks here everyone because rapport has
a draw if you but if he wants that's not
what we're going for the question is is
there some other way for him to
coordinate what if i save my rook and
guard the b pawn at the same time okay
g3 that's my ram
oh man this is going to be so spicy
it's a spicy one
if you're not taking a draw here it
might be totally yeah exactly that's why
i said that i'm like uh
maybe now it's time for me to just check
my way into uh
okay let's try
no but we cannot like g2 is coming like
we
there's nothing we can do no i mean
seriously you might just you might just
take a draw with checks and note the
king
is held back by the invisible fence
electric fences
haunted me as a kid as many people know
you ever been shocked by an electric
fence no never like touched an electric
fence and like not known as unless you
can get shocked you know we are not
burying arms either
it was kind of an inside shout out to
fabiano and hess we talked about it at
the world championship
uh as a kid i have a scarring memory of
running away playing tag and jumping
onto a fence because i was gonna climb
it and get away and i jumped onto an
electric fence and was like blown off of
it
yeah it's a real thing it happens it
happens when you're trying to keep out
wild animals don't judge me we're moving
on from this conversation okay um
anyway a reminder everybody there are
still two games left
this one here
with ravport and ali reza faruja
but i really like your suggestion so
rookie 2 and then g3 so
there's nothing you can do against this
yeah i think rookie 2 is a great move
from from perugia and uh
he didn't play it yet it was like we
were supposing it yep i think so let's
back out real quick and take a look at
all four games as they were
oh i like i like this view this is my
favorite view this is fun
we got the players we got all four games
we got results on the board
ikaru nakamura
yeah this is this is all right so we
want to go over that game with ikaru
let's do it yes let's have a look
because um
knight f3 king of seven rook d8 happened
okay so
how does this improve the position all
right so i've made predictions that he
carved but now it's time for me to put
my money or my mouth this way
what is a plan for white exactly some
like like what how are you improving it
yeah java has really shown
how coordinated black's pieces are which
is kind of where i left it i was like oh
bishop guards everything
yeah and now this bishop on the door can
afford it prevents you from playing a4
and having the best phones
it keeps the knight in prison keeps the
king at bay prevents a4 guards the
bishop like this is
you know very you know well
planned maybe uh maybe he fell into it a
little bit who knows but either way
where java's
defensive setup is is looking genius at
this time well one idea behind rook d8
is of course to play with d4 and well
there is nothing you can do you cannot
exchange the rook so you would have to
to leave this e4 square so the fourth
rank so i think that uh that's what
hikaru wants to to do he might go for
that anyway that's why he played rookie
seven
i like that idea
okay and then
but now you're also threatening rook c7
maybe
and you will you're thinking rook d4
rook a7 just attack the pawn and also
you can't play a4 again because i've got
yeah you have both rook c7 and rook a7
as well so
i was not so
so concerned about through k7 because i
always had rook d2
but rook c7 rook d3 is a little bit
awkward already yeah that's another good
defensive threat it's really important
just like
macro of you to appreciate that how well
placed black's pieces are here because
if this pawn
were on a5 like if he if he had broken
through the barrier this is going to be
a winning end game
right but
everybody is perfectly preventing
any way for hikaru to use the extra pawn
although there is one move we haven't
talked a lot about yet and that's c4 yes
but i want to take with the piece on c4
you see that's like if i if i could play
yes
that's uh that's very important that's
why i wanted to play rogue d4 c4 but
you're always going you're you're going
to prevent me for doing so
that makes sense and maybe that's why
he's
going for something like this as slow as
it looks maybe this is the plan
actually
i think about that like how do you stop
that that's interesting it's a very slow
but so so amira's point everybody is
when c4 is played if you take with the
pawns you've given yourself split
targets right and the bishop is actually
still very perfectly placed to prevent
both but if you can take on c4 with the
rook for example you have two connected
past pawns and connected past pawns are
way more powerful than split because
they protect each other as they move up
the board and step by step they're
they're almost impossible to stop
without some sort of counter play or or
awkward awkward blockade so so as slow
as this is
threatening to play c4 and take with the
rook
and elmira like
if you get this
and i and i threaten it
can you actually trade brooks no no no
you can't trade
this is the last time you came out this
end game will definitely be winning for
white the extra pawn
you know you're activating the king is
too much so my the reason i was showing
that is because the point is
if you can't trade rooks on c4 how are
you stopping this idea you have to put
your bishop on f7 so then well
i force you to play to take with the
pawn so let's see does black have time
for that so king moves somewhere
somewhere let's see and and then rook c2
bishop f7 uh-huh very nice and this
would this would force me to take with
the pawn and then i can attack your
pawns yeah now we're back to a position
where
black is in a much
okay
but at least there's been weird progress
right because with the bishop on this
diagonal what have you left behind
this guy yes but your rook is on c2 now
of course i am adapting okay but but now
here i go
now now i might go for the race no
rookie five no no no no no no rookie
five first rookie five okay you're not
gonna let me go for the race yes we've
been there before
maybe rookie two
ah ricky two now rook c5 and rookie
three okay maybe you're gradually
improving yeah it's weird like i'm just
gradually pushing and once i'm here by
the way what did we highlight about the
rook on e8 kept the king out not anymore
right now the king is ready to get in or
even this way
so
hey karu
ikaro has found a plan i guess that's
the point
right i think hicaru has found a plan
to at least challenge rajabov's
perfect geometrical setup right we were
highlighting all the pros and cons of
where black's pieces were to hold things
but that was that was under the
circumstances where where white was
trying the other stuff we were looking
at you know 94 where the rook was behind
the pawn
so this is a new idea
i think for java sees
sees how hard this position is about to
be to hold
um
well this position is as hard as it is
you know
even if you feel like you found the
perfect perfect defensive setup yeah
always a way which was another reason
why it's like i was again
openly willingly acknowledging i'm
suffering from hiccaro bias itis you
know but it just i'm like looking at the
position
looking at the flexibility he has with
the with the piece dynamic knight versus
bishop the time on the clock and
it's just you know so maybe rajab spends
10 minutes here at elmira and comes up
with a new defensive setup and it might
exist right
but that doesn't mean white has
committed to anything right and now you
continue to like maybe there's another
way and so these positions are just so
much harder to hold than they are to
keep pressing yes because it takes you
so much time to find those subjects then
you have to come up with the third setup
and then the position will change
slightly let's say we create a past
mountain then you will have to calculate
uh in a time trouble yep as bees man 93
just said this is exactly when nikaru
is this good right
with this type of slight advantage to
convert where you can press and sort of
poke and prod
kind of play with his food a little bit
if you will right he's going to play
with his food didn't your mother ever
tell you not to play with your food
right but he's poking at it right he's
just playing with it moving it around
the plate he'll eat it when he's ready
well i've been traumatized in different
ways
[Laughter]
well i had to solve like i don't know
how many chess puzzles you know a day
otherwise i i didn't get to eat
well i don't know how many test puzzles
a day either but i do know we've had two
draws today thus far earlier the two
former winners from round one and two
former candidates winners drew their
game fabiano caruana and yonda panmashi
dina caught up with fabi for a few
minutes after that game
fabi thanks for joining
when you saw nepo took a pause in the
way god surprised
what was happening in your mind did you
have like some kind of confidence boost
well i knew that knight g4 would come as
a surprise um
i don't know if many people have
analyzed this move it's a novelty uh i
played the position myself against
wesley so in in a
blitz game or rapid game i forgot and i
played knight h7 which is a common move
and knight g4
is borderline losing
um it was a huge gamble it's not losing
it's probably not even very bad but it's
it's definitely a very dubious move um
but i was kind of counting on the
surprise factor
and i also thought that he would go for
what he did which which is the most
natural way uh putting his knight on g3
and everything and then he shocked me
with this rook a3 move i didn't didn't
see that one coming
so that was like a cold shower for you
uh well you expect at some point that
you're going to be surprised and that
was the moment when i had to start
thinking very hard
but i thought my position was very good
at some point i thought i was much
better
but i couldn't find the way to exactly
coordinate my pieces because i'm up a
lot of material but he has this very
lasting initiative my king is weak
i thought there should be some way to
prove an advantage but i just couldn't
find it
so now you're waiting until you get to
the room to find what was the right way
to finish him off
i don't think i'll check the game
pretty fascinating comments there from
favi fabian i mean
that was fascinating right he's like he
knows he played a bad move at the
candidates the most important tournament
in chess right and everything he said he
thought would happen happened that's
experience right there no it's also it
shows you exactly what i told you that
because this first place justifies
everything right so like you have to go
for it but what surprises me the most is
just that fabiano and even here in the
studio yesterday i felt that he was so
tired and that but he's like such a
darling you know when he talks to his
everything is like uh so soft and then
but when you sit across him like on a
chessboard no not funny sort of serial
killer yeah i mean he played knight g4
a dubious move then predicted how young
would respond and predicted kind of the
further response eventually said rook a3
kind of took him by surprise and of
course a huge shout out to napalm rashid
that's why he's also one of candidates
right because he was surprised but kept
his cool the game never got away from
him and ultimately it ended in peace as
you can see here on the boards before
you between the two tournament leaders
uh they will they will remain the two
tournament code leaders because no one
well okay rajava could win and catch
them but rajab isn't going to win this
game no but nobody else could catch them
to type her first even if hikaru
nakamura was to go on to win the zen
game he's much more likely to do so than
rajab would be to win so let's dive back
into that game hikaru
and rajabov
are uh
where it's at right rajab is still on
the clock
and uh
what's he thinking about
well we don't know who is helping to
timora job you know it's like we are
we are not even close you know to
finding out who are the seconds you know
the of the players during this
tournament that's true
i know a couple
but i don't know
is there something that we um
uh we like didn't find out the opening
ceremony like who who else
is there something new a new information
that's
no i didn't find anything new at the
opening ceremony but just like other
things i had
heard but oh you've got it
but uh
java did not have any
one at the opening ceremony with him no
it's always funny when a second is
revealed at an occasion at a party right
i mean i think maybe sometimes they they
bring their second because maybe people
already kind of know
but i think it would it's a funny story
when like you know someone is spotted on
the site for the first time right um and
before that you weren't sure who they're
who their seconds were right so there's
some funny stories there now we wanted
to say that uh i think the main uh
richard seconds is his wife giovanna yes
who is a very strong player like and i
actually had a question for him so
hopefully he will come to to study i
wanted to ask him if he shares you know
his preparation with his wife you know
like or he not only like when uh shares
like ask her for an advice right right
yes it's uh it's very interesting for me
like to find out be more than more than
capable of giving it so
of course all right
well uh we still have two more games
that are going um they will likely be
going here for some time as particular
players try to try to get a win we're
going to see of course how these matches
play out
don't go anywhere more from chess.com
coverage of the 2022 candidates we are
live in madrid when we come right back
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster
chess.com makes learning fun and easy
sharpen your tactics with puzzles and
enhance your strategy with our lessons
by top masters learn from your own games
with our easy to use analysis tool
chess.com has everything you need to
take your game to the next level signing
up is free and easy join chess.com today
[Music]
good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the opening ceremony of
the world chess championship candidates
tournament
[Music]
do
[Applause]
no stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlsen caruana came just one end game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
uh
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played quite very well
soon to be 30 karwana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 2844 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the feed-a-grand swiss
to qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vishy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates the
most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
champion of chess must come through
madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
almira
you talked about you talk about how i
would play in such a beautiful
scenic location how would you play in
such a beautiful place
well i would be looking at the ceilings
it's like you're in a sixteenth chapel
you know this is
absolutely um
well amazing and uh
how um
how privileged are we actually to
to cover the tournament in such
locations so
one of the i think one one of the most
important i think elements of the greek
strategies is like the settings you know
we have the the characters we have the
drama right but we have an absolute
perfect setting i think so like
let's see that's a that's a great point
because you said the character right the
plot yes right but then it's why like
when you see a movie the epic sword
fight happens you know and like a stormy
thing and like a you know castle or
whatever right it's like we've got we've
got a uh a scene that is worthy of the
gladiators who are here before us
playing some incredible chess this has
been
another amazing drama pack day here day
two uh no decisive results yet but still
a couple of games that maybe could be um
almira if you had to guess one of the
two games that would end decisively
which would it be well um
it's not that i have to guess i'm pretty
sure that hikaru is going to win okay
you you never said you agreed with me
when i said that oh it comes
but like i love to disagree just to like
for the pleasure of disagreeing with you
we do it's good it's better it's better
content when we disagree that's just the
truth no no but here i'm like um i'm
really confident that hip hop is going
to win this and it's
uh well we know that it is not easy yeah
but i think that hikaru is well is
greatly improving although now repeating
a little bit so he's like
shuffling shuffling
you can shuffle all day right
i could listen to that spanish jam all
day by the way
do you like the break music yes of
course
like off camera so you guys know we're
just like we're just sitting here like
playing air guitar because that's
awesome
the the span of the spanish riff on the
guitar is no but we need this because
you know while you're watching the five
sets you know on the tennis court you
know like sometimes thinking oh then
yeah sometimes you know exactly like
it's in baseball the american the boring
sport of american baseball oh my gosh i
said it okay i'm just kidding uh
invented like did they invent the weight
or no no
oh
i don't know actually but um
if we could get the fans downstairs to
do a wave at some point now that would
be interesting content for a chess
tournament first time ever but all right
we uh we know we have a couple games
going
i think i think we're going to head back
here to the nakamura job off game um
like you said i dare you to do this in
the plane hole you know it's like the
silence is like religious sounds you
know you're going there the arbiter is
watching you know like at every possible
suspect you know everyone is a criminal
there so you're going there and you're
doing something like like you're dancing
it's funny because when i was
when i was still playing i had i had i
had like fantasies of doing that at some
point like going to the top end of the
room because you know these like epic
ballrooms like the grandmasters are
always playing at the top of the room
right so it would be a long way to get
out right but getting all the way in
there and then like having like a boom
box exactly you know just like like
press play and just super loud music and
do something kind of crazy and funny but
it's like a flash mob if you could
organize a group of fans to get in the
playing home then everyone does the wave
at the same time no i mean yeah okay so
we'll figure out a tournament to someday
secretly organize the largest chess
flash mob of all time it will happen at
some point out of major tournament
hikaru nodding his head there i think he
thinks a victory is going to happen here
right he's like that was
so there's two there's two duck lips for
hikaru like one of them isn't quite one
of them is kind of just
kind of purse and then there's
like kind of like frowning on his
opponent's move and then there's
like i got this like that's that's the
very well-known one that's basically a
meme
um
for him so so let's have a look okay uh
timora jobless is down to 17 minutes
okay is this the moment where you know
where hikaru has to well to start
something concrete you know like very
concrete operations so probably
uh rook d4 now once again to kick this
rook to the seventh rank yeah and then
uh
[Music]
to proceed with c4 is this possible
because he
rook d4 rookie
he didn't go for it before could he
you can go for it right away could he
have gone for it no no no because the
request on the tour yeah
rookie for rook d5 okay so now there's
an opportunity
yeah let's
let's bring up an analysis board when we
can and just show this line real quick
because i think that it would be helpful
to show that again this whole plan we
established of rookie 2 is to come here
trade the b-pawn for the c-pawn in a way
that allows white to maintain the two
connected passers so rajab defends
against this with the mubrook e4
but that was my point is rook d4 could
have been played here but he didn't
instead he
he hits the h5 pawn forcing the king to
g6 and that's why i was skeptical i mean
what was going on because i don't see
what white gains in that scenario but
either way amira's point is true that
you can play rook d4
and the point is now if the rook avoids
the trade you can finally get the goal
we've been waiting for
which yes we have to be careful i was
thinking about the if you are not losing
the a2 bomb so that's maybe the point so
c4
uh maybe rookie
seven so a little and rook d2 and then
he forces you to take with the pawn okay
so that's um that's the idea
okay i mean that would make sense
then rook d4 rookie 7
once again so there is no
perfect way for us to
execute this
we cannot go knight d2 knight e4
because you simply play rook a7 once
again yeah you can't even defend the
apollo
okay you cannot improve the night
well again shout out to rijaba for
setting up
an
a deceptive way to defend so sometimes
we think of defense as like pure
blockade the other form of defense is
the best defense is a good offense
making threats right so rajab didn't
he couldn't defend the c4 push with an
ideal blockading setup of the rook and
bishop but he's preventing c4 because by
doing so you would allow counter play
against the weak pawn
and that's not something hikaru can
afford because having to defend it would
allow the split of the pawns and we've
already established and the eval bar
agrees with us this is not a recipe
to a victory so
no but now i have now i understand like
what is the idea also behind the move
rook g5 king just 16. i'm glad you do
because i don't so what is the idea
well because there are several ideas um
is that you need to exchange the rook so
you need to play rook g2 rookie two and
the bishop is not protected so that's
the idea behind the rogue d5 uh
like king g6 so now the thing is like
the moment you will play rogue d2 that's
why he carry played it he will go back
king of seven so that's sort of uh
it's funny he played a3 first which is
also an interesting little
way to put the pawn on a different
square i'm and you also the thing is
that
the key to this position is also that
the rook the black rook should stay on
the e file it's not like attacking the
h4 pounds like you cannot bring your
king to the to the queen side
that's a very important one
so is there any chance for us to play
rook well he played the three of course
but to to play rook d2 rookie two and
then kiki three but then probably uh
you will attack this like the c pawn
yeah that's why i'm confused about it
because from from d2 sorry yes from d2
and e2 the rook could establish the
threat you talked about
and defend
you can't do that now if black slides
the rook back to either e6 or e7 and
starts to
to renew this threat
hagar must have some other pl i think
he's changing plans again um
your idea of inducing the kenya g6 let's
let's bring back the analysis board
because again that was that was super
awesome i'm just going to show it rook
to d2
was the idea that almira had
and if the king had gone back
that's maybe why he didn't do it because
then what am i doing next i'm just
repeating no if the king would be on g6
left if the king makes some other moves
maybe now we can play this
given that the situation is
you'd have to although now the king's so
active maybe it doesn't work anymore i
sell the email bar slip and i'm like
it's probably because i'm just so super
active oh yeah right so like
actually maybe that's another reason why
but okay this is uh
fascinating stuff for ricardo to throw
in a3 i want to go back to the first
question you asked and then we got lost
in chess analysis which was
is now the time to strike because
speaking of time
where java is now down to 15 minutes
right and
at some point even if you haven't
established what the what the clear
winning plan is yet at some point you
have to cash in your chips if you're the
person if you're the aggressor right you
have to go for some sort of plan to
capitalize on your opponent's time
pressure where they might blunder
is now the time right is at some point
he gonna do something that objectively
might be a draw but forces forces for
jabba's hand look at this like he
glanced he at his opponent anymore you
know he
he glanced at hikaru
and he's well he
it's like
he's trying to
find out what is what's the idea because
he's confused about it
and i think that he might be genius by
carl exactly take a couple more minutes
off the clock
you know i know i know i'm not gonna win
i know i'm not objectively winning on
the board i've been unable as of yet to
prove i have a clear plan
so let me just let me just get you under
time pressure
that's why it's a game so once again
he's not going for anything concrete
because like he's maintaining the
pressure
and he's waiting for the time trouble
so 10 more moves to go
i like it i like it a lot
sometimes i slip in two and i'll show
you an accent and this is a sterling
sure should they say something in german
like what
something in german like the you know no
no because there's absolutely nothing's
about to go on a walk about
this no this is one wonderbar
this is wonderable this is wonderful
no wunderbar is like uh this is actually
one yam is using it in the song like but
they're saying like he is so dancing
wonderbar
i don't speak too many languages but i
do speak i am fluent in over 72
different accents so um
all right
wow well
um for
for those wondering
there's uh
there's still two games going there were
two games in the book sorry i was just
having a mental reset of where we are
where am i i'm in madrid hello everybody
uh two games have finished and uh two
games are still going while we wait for
java to make his next move and decide
how he's gonna deal with icarus a3 let's
take a look at the career he's had to
get here remind you in our chess.com
player profile of who the other boy from
baku is
the oldest player in madrid at age 35
timur rajab is competing for the third
time at the candidates and for the first
time in nine years
once ranked in the top five in the world
raja qualified for the candidates two
years ago but was unable to compete due
to covet concerns for this year's
tournament fide offered raja a wild card
which raja accepted
[Music]
born in the same azerbaijani city as
former world champion gary kasparov raja
beat gary kasparov at age 15.
in fact he has never lost to the former
world champion
one of the peak achievements of
rajabov's career was his victory at the
fide world cup
in that tournament he defeated the top
seed ding le ren in the final to qualify
for the 2020 candidates tournament
in madrid raja hopes that he can lean on
his experience at the candidates to post
some impressive performances even though
expectations for him here are not as
high as they once were
[Music]
you know it was a funny last comment in
the video that
dania says expectations on rojava are
maybe not as high as they once were but
you think he feels that way you think
rojava feels that way
well
i don't know like i'm not in like in
john malkovich's mind so not taymor's
mind but
i remember this game actually when he
was 15 and he beat gary kasparov and i
was so impressed because
to beat gary kasparov in linares you
know at this age you know first of all
it's like
you're
the mystic like you're killing the myth
yeah you know and showing your strengths
at the same time so
uh
so i believe this is also maybe a
question of motivation
because like what else is there to win
so they
the candidates tournaments once again uh
i've beat myself but i think that he is
um
trying really hard at this tournament
yeah
well it's interesting because we keep
talking about it you know he was a child
prodigy and i mentioned the other boy
from baku and no disrespect for jabba
but
literally gary kasparov is the boy the
boy from baku and rajaba was kind of
anointed as a young prodigy coming out
of also by john and
maybe the expectations are different
because he's just been around for so
long but we keep talking about the fact
that if not for the fact that he
stepped out because of covet he would be
the other player here like fabio caruana
competing in his fourth candidate's
tournament yes so this is his third
candidate he's third but it's his fourth
that he's qualified for i guess in a
weird way although i guess that's not
totally fair because he was given the
spot because he didn't play there
so
but it's funny because if he had played
half that tournament he'd be able to say
that oh my gosh we have a big change so
this is this is exciting all right we
have liftoff everybody the question
we've been asking
would hikaru nakamura at some point cash
in his chips
a3 you don't have rook h2 and rk2 ah
okay okay now and now he took the phone
of course that's the idea okay he
prepared everything to take the pawn on
b5 to transpose to a rope game just in
case and there is no rook h2o k2 and
here he goes now we're going to knight
back on d4 he's going to try to advance
the airplane and i really love this idea
because all right let's let's go full
screen here we'll be able to analyze it
in just a moment we've got
the point is
previously on mira we weren't liking
ideas where you took because there were
not just checks that won the pawn but
checks that got drawing chances but
notice the bishop is worse off here yes
exactly there's no there's no way to to
keep the king corral you could check him
into safety but that's a very different
story so this is
this is a fascinating change if if
everyone remembers the variations we
were looking at something like this
is not just gonna you know end in a draw
anymore oh okay actually lol i was
kidding i'm not gonna walk into that
but
but there are other ways to maybe get
out of the checks too and the bishop is
not in a super active spot that was my
point is that now this is going to
become a pure race position of some kind
although this still comes with risk at
risk right
uh
but what did we say
this is this is why hicary is doing it
now he could have done this exact same
thing when they both had more than 40
minutes on the clock now but what i
wanted just to point out that on
rook h2 you you might win a tempe by
playing king g3 and you don't you cannot
take the pawn on a2 yeah so there are
just king j3 here
no king j3
so that's
i think that's the
the point behind the move
so there is
the perpetual is not here well you just
still have to defend and you can't
attack the c2 pawn
because the bishop is no longer on the
h3c diagonal so you cannot give these
checks and
wow that's amazing if you go to a2 you
can play a4 if you go to b2 you're not
threatening anything because the knight
guards it and you can't go to c2 because
the knight prevents it
so
and once again uh hikaru has chosen this
moment
while timur is in the time trouble yep
yeah and again that's that's how you win
games that's why i made the comment it's
a game not a science right it's not a
perfect thing because even if a position
is objectively should be able
uh you should be able to hold holding it
is a whole nother
well another question especially when
you don't have a lot of time on the
clock
and try to hold it against hikari
against the karaoke war that's not
something i ever
want you know or get excited about so
here we've got uh roger's pawns have
momentum too okay actually that's an
interesting comment i'll mirror what
we'll come back to that from bozen
rosenberg
rogers pawns do have momentum too um
and we'll talk about why i don't think
they're gonna be as fast but uh what
were you about to say no no it's just
that there's a pure question like if you
were given a chance facing minotaur in
the labyrinth or defending this position
against hikar what are you choosing i
mean one of them maybe involves involves
death unless it's like a safe word
if there's like a safe word that i can
get out of the labyrinth then okay maybe
there's always a way
yeah but
the question
is coming in from chad and now my head
is kind of spinning with calculation
how can black's pawns compete and and so
i think
first of all just for the educational
takeaway
one of the biggest differences is that
white's king is in a position to deal
with blacks pawns black's king is not in
a position to deal with white spawn so
just quick high level snapshot why we
like white it's not even necessarily
because white has three pawns versus two
because in an end game like this it's
not how many pawns you have it's who's
going to get a queen first that matters
so
the the the quantity being greater is
not the deciding factor of white's
advantage but it's the fact that white's
king is in a position to slow down
blacks pawns white's knight and rook are
in a position to help that
whereas it's not the same for black
right black does not have any any sort
of ideal way
it's like black's position is this it's
just a matter of time it's not if but
when these pawns will get rolling
whereas with these pawns it's not
totally clear how to advance with the
king is that a fair reason why we would
well yes since then while uh i was
thinking rook h1 or rogue d2
and taymor yes played rock d2 because
he's uh
threatening the immediate rook d3 i'm
taking the pump so like i'm so sorry i
was calculating as well but even even
this is is now
possible but rook h1 on the other hand i
was keeping uh the option of playing h4
in the next move that's why i liked it
but i was not sure that would be better
actually
i was not sure because then your king is
on g6 night and now so yeah i could play
knight f5 knight h4
in case if i wanted to capture the spell
i'll just show that real quickly because
it's a it's a good example of backing up
what we were saying that white's king
and knight are coordinating so something
like this maybe could be met by this and
elmira's point is the knight and king
are preventing progress whereas there's
no coordination by the pieces happening
to prevent the progress here it's just a
question of can the pawns eventually get
rolling and here they go hey carlo plays
c4 that's the i was talking about rook
c5 but why not push it right this is the
most aggressive way to defend the pawn
rook d3 check no longer wins a pawn
because the knight defends it and c4
protects also the rook on d5 so like
yes you can move the knight and uh
maybe knight f3 knight h4s like you see
the king on g6 is actually very
vulnerable yeah it's actually
a bit of a
precarious spot not not a spot you're
happy about there there are concrete
threats now
white is starting to move this knight to
either one of these squares and exchange
of brooks probably is not good the
knight comes to f4 and hikaru might even
be targeting these pawns
okay well first of all how big would
this be for nakamura
right
i know i asked and that's thanks captain
obvious yeah it'd be big right it's
being big
but even more so because he lost the
first game right it would really show
whatever it is about his his
perseverance not just on the board we
talk a lot about that he's resourceful
he perseveres but perseverance off the
board right keeping your cool all right
i lost to fabiano i was black and bd bro
no big deal but did like
like i
i'm afraid to make the mistake to make a
mistake but i think he started with the
loss at the grand prix and he won it did
this like i have no idea like i know he
lost to
yeah didn't he lose to lavon in the
first game like i mix up now all the
results but i think that's uh that's a
clear probably example of how you're
winning the tournament there's been a
lot of chess this year so forgive us
but i know he did and
everyone knows he had to come from
behind he had to win on command which
was part of the drama of that day um
so yeah hicaro had to come from behind
in the grand prix he did so and uh in in
doing so he punched his ticket
to get here to the candidates
rook d3 is played we'll we'll come back
to this real quick we're going to
quickly get to
report versus ferruccia because even
though
wait something has happened here what
happened we left it and for ruja had
been
[Music]
he was close we thought to equality but
where did the game go so after rook f7
check yes he played rookie two
so this is what we predicted and by the
way
the computer also likes this for black
it was the best move e6
and here we were looking for d3 or oh he
did he played rookie eight
instead of d3 but okay computer says
you're still holding
so what was what was the mistake rook f
to f6 but on the other hand did well d3
e7 like
okay so just to have a look at this
position it's a christmas three
e seven seven
oh the idea i'm just i'm just looking at
the computer here shamelessly the idea
was this crazy rook d4 check and with
this like
because if you go up i can just perfect
no no but if i go king of three
now g2
ah okay so after rook f8 okay you
control and then d1 is going to be there
with check okay now i understand of
course we'll finish the line so no one
has to do it in their head if you go for
this in fact it's actually for ruja who
would go on to win
uh
with this so
so he
he must have calculated something
that he didn't like because what he
played in this position was not only not
d3 but he went for a very passive
blockading setup here with the move rook
to e7 and this is the one that the
computer is saying
uh no
what
oh
this happens even among the best players
in the world when they don't have the
benefit that we have not only of the
eval bar but the engine variations if we
even want to check them they're right
there
so report plays that why is it so clear
like after rookie 7 because i still want
to report plays b4 apparently the
winning move was king f5
so compared to the variation that we had
d3
okay let's calculate you know so it's
just
what do you do here
well
the first one that comes to mind is rook
f8
king h7
that doesn't look yeah this looks fine
so there's something else here
i think that one of the biggest issues
though is the mating net for the black
king so some sort of idea like rook g5
to come over
is interesting yeah but i can check you
maybe then book g5 or qf2
yeah rg5 rook f2 so i'm trying to create
a net
right
so again yeah something like this
actually
because now you stop the pawn and you
threaten me
okay now and yes and the rook of two
years
and okay and the e6 pawn is protected
yes of course you won is it like it's a
very beautiful move okay rook g1
threatening mates well or
not not rook f8 rook g1 threatens mate
it's not yet mate you still have rook h7
okay but then but then my king is close
simply closer and i'm keeping
and then we have a move from ali reza it
was d3 after b4 and
we're back to a position that the
computer says
should be held in fact what a critical
tempo that b4 is to lose because
the fact that the pawn is not protected
almira means you can't do any of that
stuff there is no rook down because you
lose the pawn
so so king f5 was a massively important
move
and
but on the other hand alvarez didn't
play d3 like for two moves yes for sure
no no it's hard to no reason to paint
the storyline like it was a one-sided
wrap work blew it but the point is he
did have a win there with that
interesting king of five idea but what
uh these positions are some of the
hardest in chess like from from my
perspective like the open board multiple
pass pawns with rooks these this is like
these positions are just impossible for
humans to calculate because it implies
so many variations like in a very direct
sequence of moves where the whole board
is like open once again so like opponent
games yeah
very difficult to calculate like rook
versus past pawn those positions where
you're trying to make a decision if you
can queen your opponent's going to give
up their rook for the queen and then are
you able to get back in time right of
course like these are the positions that
give chess players
anxiety because
the engine here will will make it look
easier than it is this is a super
difficult position to calculate and
obviously as we saw
um
in the open board with all kinds of
checks all types of racing going on
you're knee-deep in the weeds
and it's it's hard to see your way
through the forest so
i think it's going to be a draw now
i think the d3 is just in time i think
uh we don't be surprised if we see the
bailout meaning he he just he plays he
brings the rook back and we just get a
big exchange
there is there is one okay there's one
outside thing though
if the rooks are traded on e6 and white
wins d3
yes but
that end game
that end game is actually winning for
white yes but because the king is too
far from the b-pawn the thing is like
you have to deal with my defund like g2
d1 is a real threat of course
okay let's let's just show it real quick
so if rook to g3
[Music]
the move has to be d2 probably i i'll
show the line because if rook takes this
is the point if you take everything gets
taken and then you take
wow the table base says this is a draw
initially looking at this i would think
this is a winning end game for white
because you're putting the rook behind
the pawn and you're pushing
but i guess black black is just in time
if you try this stuff
the king gets to f6 and you blockade
okay so i was i was assuming it was
winning but the king is actually just in
time to shoulder the white king
okay wow
so that really says this is going to be
a draw then because if you can't go for
that
what are your winning chances if your
report
rapport report
rapport the colbert report
hi
i keep putting different emphasis on a
different level each time richard rezzy
you know so the rehearsal rehearsal
reports yes
i apologize
it's a it's a
well french you know they would say
richard
i i don't struggle with with like jinji
hashvily or the palm
um
but uh
anyway i don't know if i'm saying his
name right i'm just going to apologize
to all the rapport and also like i'm
like half ukrainian half armenian
yeah i did
yeah and now he's romanian that's right
well he's playing for romania no no i
mean me like yes yes like i'm this crazy
mix you know we put this like
for those who don't know it's not
officially represented in this event
because it fide would have to
acknowledge and approve the federation
application to change before it becomes
official but
uh reports
has uh requested to change federations
to romania rather than hungary so
interesting well i have a question like
because like i had some thoughts on this
uh do you think that the number of times
that the player should be allowed to
well switch federation should be limited
that's an interesting question because
life thinking that this is a very
important decision for me and uh and for
the players i suppose so uh probably
uh there is a moment in life where they
have to take this difficult decision and
to represent like another federation
that could be marriage you know you're
changing the country so but how many
times
could you do it because like i was
thinking maybe it should be limited to
two times
that would make sense you know you don't
want someone bouncing around and kind of
leaving
leaving a
a trail you know behind them and in turn
because there's a lot that goes into
that right especially for top players it
affects the olympia team it affects all
kinds of selections you you know when
you change federations you affect the
top players in that country if you're
you know there were there were all kinds
of controversies
that i won't speak of you know when when
certain players pitch to you switch to
us federations right young up and coming
talented americans
weren't totally thrilled about that in
some ways right denying them the
opportunity to maybe compete you know
for on olympic teams and these sort of
things so there's a lot to it i think
it's i don't think a player should be
denied the opportunity but i think it's
interesting i also think that we should
get back to the hikaru game
um let's have a look by the way it looks
like uh
okay rook g3 was played by ravport i
think we're going to have a draw very
soon so we need to switch back to the
hicaro game
as soon as we can because the advantage
has gotten bigger for nakamura
so he went with his king to h4 okay
yeah so after we left it it was rook d3
check
king h4
it's funny because if you can put the
bishop on this diagonal
checkmate anyway that's not a thing
bishop f7 rook d8 and now rook d1 and
again what do we have less than five
minutes
okay five minutes for how many moves
uh
yeah we should we should actually check
into the format of that i think it's it
is move 60 so it's two more moves two
more moves yeah so at two and two moves
he will get more time and we quickly
remind everybody that 60 minutes was
added after move 40 another 15 minutes
will be added plus we finally have an
increment
uh on the clock
at that at that benchmark so
reaching move 60 is a huge threshold for
java to hold this because once you start
getting 30 seconds back on the clock
with every move
you know not to say that the position
might be losing but at least the clock
is is way less of a stress to be honest
i find this uh this time control like
very logical especially like when you're
adding the 30 seconds only at the last
stage of the game so because like what
was the purpose of the increment
initially so like you wouldn't lose it
whether you're like clean up so we've
converted to minion end game so like
it's not to assure that you that would
be such a easy way through a time
trouble yeah so i think if you
if you see it
in this way so this for me this is very
logical yeah it makes it makes every one
of the time control moments the time
pressure moments more exciting and more
dramatic it obviously puts more pressure
on the players to manage their clocks
better as as our as our partner hammer
was saying right so i i agree i think
it's
i'm coming around to it it's it's
interesting and a little different than
what we've seen for the last two decades
of of or even three three decades of top
level feed hdfs but it makes sense and
again as d as not dina excuse me i'm
reading dina because we have an
interview coming with dean assume but
not right now so as elmira was saying um
the whole purpose of increment initially
was to kind of get away from the rule we
used to have of insufficient losing
chances right where a player
couldn't just get flagged right and that
was a big thing because before we had
digital clocks we had big analog clocks
i've been flagged before in a drawn
position it doesn't feel good right and
so increment was designed to ensure that
what was on the board would ultimately
be the deciding factor
and to avoid this kind of absurd
situation and probably not fair as well
and so
almer's point is great that it only
really makes sense that you have to have
increments should the game go to very
long extent like after move 60 when
you're in an end game i agree it makes a
lot of sense um
insufficient losing chances is a
a rule that is so unique to chess
um all right rook h1 check
the king quickly moves to g3 here comes
h4
shout out to our our twitch user who
said well what about black spawns well
here they go the problem is that now
we'll see king g2 i think with tempo or
do you just
you just go to f4 actually f4
i like king of four better because i
just want to point out something funny
that if you play king of four and black
plays h3 black isn't even really
threatening h2 because white can just
come back to g3
and black is stuck
right
yes yes i agree with it's like
i was considering king g2 of course
naturally so uh
king of four is probably
more active right
like if this works h3 king g3
but our chances of getting dimmer dinner
are slimmer
i'm normally the host who forces
unnecessary rhymes onto a show well i i
was not even sure that was rhyme before
it's like
how tired winner is slimmer that's
that's definitely a rhyme by today's
modern standards of the urban art form
known as hip-hop r b and rap um yes i
would believe that uh a winner and
slimmer rhyme no it was actually dinner
oh you said dinner dinner
dinner also rhymes with both um all
right well we've got
we've got these two games going by the
way i think we're probably moments away
from a handshake
in in for ruja rapport but while we wait
for these final moments we're going to
squeeze a few seconds and
we mentioned of course there was a draw
earlier between young chris of duda and
dingley ren we saw one interview uh with
john chris updudo let's see what dina
and dingley ren got up to earlier in the
afternoon
thank you for joining us please take us
through your emotions during the game
oh well it's a
it's quite game but
quite interesting
i think at some point i thought i was
better but
he played
a very good rook p1 i think that's a
very good idea he found
so
it looks mimo g5 is not that good but i
don't know where i went wrong
it turns out my position is slightly
worse in the
final vanilla station i think
but i don't know how to
process for white
at least comparing to yesterday
yesterday i played i think one of the
worst games
recently
but today i feel
much better i think
the joy is a quite good result for me so
you're going like between inc after a
loss it draws a good result
yeah especially after yesterday's
defeats
and do you think for your opponent draw
was also a good result judging that you
had three times repetition afterwards
at first i thought he is slightly better
since
maybe he can try for more but
i don't know
all right on another note
we were wondering
what were your first thoughts
when you realized you actually
could be the candidates that you
actually had a chance to
to be in the candidates what were the
first things you thought about
well at first
uh he told me that i only need to play
30 games
to
and to qualify
even if i lost all the games i can still
play candidates but then
somebody told me that it depends on the
average
ratings so i need i not not only
need to play 30 games but i need to get
quite good results
so i feel
not i'm not sure if i
i'm going to play these games but after
uh in the end
uh
they they convinced me that i had good
chance chance here so i just
so you didn't accept immediately but you
had a thought
yeah but in the end i
i take the challenge yes
do you
he sticks to the challenge he's so sweet
he is he's the sweetest right yes it's
at the same time once again he's one of
the strongest players in the world he's
the top seed in this tournament and i'm
actually glad he did yeah he was like so
he's he qualified for this tournament
and he has a chance
when you look at the rest of his
his match-ups and we know how strong he
is we know he's trying to write his own
ship right uh
what do you think the biggest challenges
ahead for him well i have to look at the
biggest uh the bigger screens so
oh that's disappeared i can barely see
the results yes a great score against
caruana
yes we already mentioned this yes
especially that it would be tough for
fabi he's a very tough opponent
for fabiano so i think
this is something that he should count
on
so uh
what what do you give to the uh speaking
of soviet chess school the the theory of
you never lose two games in a row
right and he talked with dina obviously
we all know he got off to a tough start
of course again we will update that
record as we go reflect that he lost
into palmishi but
how important do you think it was for
ding to come into this game and just
stop the bleeding no it was very
important of course if you can
probably he
if the position would allow this he
would play on but i think that's uh to
make a draw with black and this
tournament is very important and so you
uh focus on your preparation
yeah it's uh it's a very important
psychological moment as well
well he did it dingley wren delivered
with with the draw stopped the bleeding
right and then of course he remains in
the hunt
uh
we have ollie rosa faruja on camera here
we have a game that i believe is is
about to
about to end it a draw
table base
announces a draw
um
similarly to what we were looking at
although it was even a draw if the rook
was in front of the pawn typically this
is not the ideal spot for the brook but
as we saw even that was a draw here
ferruccia points out that he has a
different plan
this is the ideal setup for the black
rook of course where you can
stop the pawn from behind
and put the put the opponent's rook in a
bad spot to have to defend it so
well you want to bring your king of
course closer to the b-pound like with
black but your rook is also cutting the
white king so player combined in both
ideas so when the rook will leave the
d-file your king will come closer
so i think it's it's a very easy draw
yeah very easy draw sometimes when the
king has cut off
this many files right
you actually have very good winning
chances but the big problem
is this king has also cut off that many
files right uh if you took the white
king and just put it over here this is a
winning endgame for white because the
king and pawn can work together up the
board inch by inch and this excuse me
this rook this rook can't stop them by
himself right the the king would have to
get over there
so
the point is because this king has cut
off so many files
but whites is also cut off it makes this
makes this a pretty easy draw
well and you will have to defend the
people on in a way so you will have to
play either b2 or d4 or d6 or b6 and
then yeah so
yeah makes sense so i think ferrugia
knows it's a draw
i the only reason i'm like focused here
is i have i have this feeling we're
about to just see a draw offer and just
see the final moment you know but okay
it may not happen and the much the much
more exciting game for sure is the um
the nakamura battle with rajabov so
uh
i don't think we're about to see a final
result i don't know body language not
saying so so why don't we why don't we
head back over to the game that has a
lot of spice to it
hikaru did not play
hikar did not play king f4 he played
king to g2 yes but i told you that was
the first move i was considering it's
it's a very human move
like the much more human move for sure
so king chi-2
well what to do here rugby one rook d1
so let's just say you come over rook d1
mm-hmm let's say we continue he can't
play day four a5 now so
what can what can you do here
there is no way for you to stop the a
pound
and if you if you check me a whole bunch
you're just checking me back or actually
just h3
even better yes here i can play
the two king h3 of course so it's
actually a serious problem
right can you
bring your king for like king g5 for
example to play something like this or i
don't know native three sorry sorry
sorry
okay it was a bad try then maybe king h5
okay that's lebron square
oops so rook d1
king yes i want to bring the king to g4
and push a3 so that's my only chance of
course so
what can i do a6 of course
why hold back
okay now i have to play
okay then but then maybe not rook given
rookie one was the more stubborn
difference i don't know like uh you see
how difficult it is to defend this
position so
so you put the rook on a1 because at
least this slows down the pawns but now
we push the other pawn oh yes c5 is gone
okay
really important that this bishop cannot
get active
that all of white's pieces are perfectly
placed
okay then this is
this is a very easy win because yeah i
mean this is
you cannot advance yeah you can't stop
it
rajabov may have gotten
15 minutes back on the clock as they
reach move 60 but he hasn't gotten a
better position
and that's that's a problem
so he's
he is
facing a very uphill battle right now
in this game with nakamura what a huge
win it would be for the american and by
the way
we we do have a result as we can see
on the live screen the kings put on the
squares e5 and e4 that means we had a
peaceful peaceful result so
you know what would what what would you
be doing emotionally if you're in
richard richards camp right
do you look at this game and say
especially once you turn on the computer
that that i messed up that i i had a win
or do you feel like okay this was very
complicated unreasonable that i was
gonna solve this and a draw is a draw
well i i would certainly analyze but i
wouldn't draw
all these conclusions i think that okay
you you had some winning chances you
missed it but i think that it was uh
very complicated first of all
and
once again you have again you have a
game tomorrow yeah so it's very
important to focus your on your next
challenge so you have dinner with your
wife
much more important than to analyze the
computer yeah for sure for sure and uh
you know yeah it's just interesting
because for those who are tuning in
there was a very exciting moment in that
game where
varusha took this active defense that
was at the time looked like a decision
that might cost him the game and
ultimately it proved much more difficult
right to convert and so it's hard it's
hard to beat yourself up i i would agree
fuja is uh here with his family his
whole family came to madrid so now
probably they
well they they will have a well-deserved
celebration yeah well a great draw on a
great birthday so i guess this because
this might be our last chance to talk
about it happy birthday dolly razor
purusha a good present you gave yourself
defending would look to be a tough spot
uh in some moments so he is still
still in a great position with two draws
to start his first ever candidates
campaign so
all right let's uh well we're gonna have
one more game and that's where our full
focus is going to be let's give a quick
shout out to our chess kid team once
again here doing amazing stuff in madrid
if you can hear me downstairs but chess
kid is excited to announce the first
ever fide and chess kid unrated girls
only tournament girls only in this event
the tournament is free to attend and
takes place on july 10 2022 there will
be two editions of this event an eastern
edition and a western edition you can
join at chesskid.com visit our main
website for more information
and uh
sign up your your young lady chess
player today or if you are a young lady
watching this go go sign up yourself so
shout out to chess kid for that event
with fidei and shout out to this last
game remaining we uh
we got to get back to it i saw i saw you
you pointing what were you what were you
excited about there with
with king
no no no no i was i was actually uh
excited about the events i think it's a
wonderful initiative so but i wanted to
get the board uh yeah yeah we'll dive in
here to get back to the board sir what
kimber job offer do what are his last
chances
let's
let's dive in and and c so we have
king on g2 attacking the rook on h1 so
we have to find the way to sacrifice
this bishop
you know for at least two pounds and
maybe like it should be
we try drop d1 it's losing rookie one is
lost maybe rook b1 okay let's
is there any way we get the analysis
board here we uh we need to pull up the
big board so we can take a look
uh we've got
king g2 so now you're saying rook b1
well we tried it all so that's the only
move which is left
the nice thing about that move is i
guess if you play c5 i can take
maybe yes yes
that's exactly
what i was hoping for but you're
probably going to play a5 here
and also it allows me to bring my king
without being checked on f3 so maybe
that's like because we've tried all the
variations so maybe here i can play king
g5
yeah
what do you think penny
king g5
if knight f3 then i i still have king
chief
this this looks like you're getting
aggressive this is not what i want right
so i don't i don't like knight f3
and the pawn on b3 is like i just want
to push until i learn that i can't
um okay now you're forcing me to play
rook one
and now
now that my b-pawn is no longer attacked
my knight is free to do some but can you
push c5 here i know a6 is like hankin
wait wait wait well it's not totally
crazy because i mean it's not how many
points you have left it's i'm
threatening to take on a6
we forget
with the rook yes no but i i no i agree
they think i'm saying it's not a crazy
idea in the sense that in the end it's
not going to matter whether you have any
pawns left if you get a queen so
it's kind of a funny line like c5 takes
c6
you know that's all i
i agree with you i saw it was hanging
but it's interesting i think more likely
you should try to do something like
defend the pawn and then look to give
like some sort of check with the knight
or something
okay but now
that's what i wanted to achieve i will
play king g4 and i want to play to push
h3
that's the only chance i have in this
position
the hardest part of the situation is
it's easy for us to analyze you know two
brains
together an eval bar with it right
java only has eight minutes on the clock
and uh
it's not going to make this task easy at
all
here it is big moment and he he actually
where he uses rook to see one okay so ah
but now we know that uh now we already
know that a5 yes hikaru can play a5
wait a second but did we and
what was the difference between rook b1
a5 and
did we try like
we can still try rook c1 a5 king g5 here
what is the difference exactly
that the b pawn was hanging that you
couldn't play what is that nice
the b-ball was hanging before
this is not clear to me yes because king
chief is still a threat so i don't see
what is the difference
because we didn't try king g5 in this
variation yeah we did when the rook was
on d1 we tried it and then it was a
blunder of a check of course i was blind
so you're right this is uh
definitely not something we've totally
analyzed yet so
king g5 what does white do do you just
push it so what happens if i just push
a6 again just push until i learn that i
can't well i
okay one i have no other okay yeah we're
back to that same scenario
[Music]
so we don't want to push
push too far away
so maybe rook c1 also works so it's the
same the same idea yes it was the same
idea that you had with rook to b1 but
preventing the move c5 i guess made a
lot of sense and
ikaro is
he was about to move there it looked
like right
and now he's pulled back and he's
reconsidering
so what if i play check right away my
idea is that now you have to go to g4
because if you move
elsewhere i think i can take the pawn
now that your rook is in here i think
ah yes that was the difference of course
so
now if you play here i also have rook to
d4 right yeah okay so yeah i changed the
move order okay the knight of three king
of four of course
i'm probably
uh
who's in here anyway i'm giving this
phone but i'm coming with making so now
i simply check okay where'd you go yeah
i if i go here you win
it would be a very very good birthday
present
probably reservarujo
and where do you go now i run here oh
yes we are on here okay so
i have to attack i will have to
sacrifice my my bishop at some point i
you know i'm obsessed with this idea so
i can give up my bishop and but uh i
have to stop
okay rook a2 now
bishop c4 doesn't work i think because
you will have time okay okay two okay
two
[Music]
if you give some sort of check and you
walk this king up you're actually maybe
getting yourself in trouble 91 91 king
e3 there's no checkmate here with the
knight on e1 but it doesn't feel good to
be in this spot
well you can give you can still give
rook d3 check but it's well
it does not achieve you also
you cannot protect it like that
so i think i think if we back up i think
ankara is
this is not an ideal winning plan right
you go for this pawn
once again we're going for the active
defense we're like given away yeah
right
that's how you want to defend these
positions actively and
don't let your don't let your opponent
takara nakamura grind you down
to where you end up beating yourself on
the clock
okay eight minutes left
eight and a half minutes left 26 minutes
if you're just tuning in all three other
games
in round two of the 2022 fide candidates
tournament have ended in draws
uh which means that uh should this game
prove victorious for hikaru nakamura it
would be the only decisive game
of the day so
and it will be a long day what no no no
because i like when we know that this is
a new function where you can predict the
results now on the site so uh how many
people were right yesterday i wanted to
know do we have the statistics uh we'll
pull it up as we go i i don't have it we
do we do and and i know that our
community team shout out to everybody
working hard on that is gathering that
stuff so we will have standings and an
update of who's leading the
the the vote on the results thing
um as as we go so it's good that you are
not doing this for a living as well yes
i am not guessing i am not gambling or
guessing on chess results for a living
that is first because like you know
you're yeah my job is to be wrong on
camera that's my job so i just hey danny
go be go be wrong on camera okay um yeah
so
uh thankfully my job is not on the line
by about whether or not i predict the
results correctly but uh
okay
you see i'm feeling like third days we
will be even better we will be even
better at some point i do think you get
a little better when you're in the flow
of it you're no longer just guessing for
content in the beginning i'm kind of
just guessing for content like hey
although i did predict a hikara win here
today for the record
well
okay this
this is your lucky guess it is it is my
lucky guess i don't remember what i
predicted in the other games
um i predicted a win for the birthday
boy i was wrong about that so but i
think the other games i predicted to
draw some
all right
we know so many fans are tuning in from
all over the world to watch hikaru
nakamura throughout this entire event
and right now of course they'd all like
to see him get the dubs so while he
thinks about how he can continue to
maybe press his advantage let's remind
everybody of uh who hikaro nakamura is
his community doesn't need a reminder
but it's fun to see their star
highlighted in our next chess.com player
profile
[Music]
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believed nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him
that changed when this american grand
master leaned on his exceptional
calculating ability to win the fide
grand prix
the unexpected victory earned him a bid
into the candidates for the first time
in six years
a five-time u.s champion hikaru has
stayed sharp of late by dominating in
speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
i have definitely not ruled out
lightning in a bottle for a car not
converted to win this tournament for
sure i mean he's he's playing arguably
the best chess in his career right now
shocking as that might be for those who
who thought he literally didn't care
elmira he does care right and what would
be your thoughts on his chances
especially if he rebounds with a victory
here
well first of all i think that his
motivation is very different he wants to
win this tournament in order to like to
bring happiness you know this is
absolutely incredible so
it's uh it's something which
motivates him more than anything even
probably when he was the number two in
the world we should not forget this that
he has achieved everything so it's
probably and now he has
another show that like at the candidates
and probably like
the world title so
it's interesting and and you know
yesterday you talked about it and i
agree he has he's playing for more than
himself right and that's not a knock
before i mean chess is a very individual
game players for a long time are playing
for their own ambitions to prove to
themselves and get as good as you
individually can and that transition
that happens in anyone's life here it's
almost like having a family right
ricardo has this community he has a
family right and he feels like the the
love and joy that they have from his
success and i think that's what you're
saying he wants to bring that joy to
everybody who's cheering for him right
yeah it's this is something much greater
than well just just a game so
[Music]
i'm
well i'm looking forward you know to
to the end of this
one someone in chat asked do you think
he sees a5
i i think he does see a5 i think hikaru
at this point is using his clock as a
weapon
um shout out to john bartholomew who
often talks about that chess content uh
and streamers the point is when you have
a clock advantage
you manage it by
play quickly when you know it put
pressure on them think on the opponent's
clock that's the best way to get ahead
is you actually work hard on their turn
and then in the critical moment make
sure you pause and go as deeply as you
can before you commit to a line
of course no no i was just i was looking
at how much time does he have right now
so he has 20 minutes left
yeah well his opponent is down to eight
minutes but i was thinking
could he possibly bring it like to the
moment where
like
he has like
five minutes left so he like he would
play quickly as well
it's interesting right i think that
i would argue this i think he knows that
he doesn't want this game to slip into
forcing variations while raj still has
eight minutes he wants that to happen
when roger has four minutes right so i
think it's important that you don't just
play a5
a5 okay he played it but the point is if
he just played a5 fast and we get in
this bam bam bam forcing line and maybe
raja had already calculated it he did
himself a disservice right he needs to
make sure that
if you're going for a forcing line you
better be winning otherwise keep this
game going as long as you possibly can
to get your opponent into time trouble
but once we again like what did we did
we look at king g5 here yes yeah that
was our main thing uh black can play
king g5 because there is well there is
knight f3 but there's no knight of three
winning a rook like like one of the
first lines we looked at
um
i think i think kim g5 is
the most logical move you can also play
rookie one right away by the way
well you could but then uh
actually did we analyze no we didn't we
didn't
no we analyzed what happens on rookie
one right away because you can't you
can't play b4 without c4 falling
right the bishop is on it
no but i think we had
oh c5 then you take but you see you like
you you didn't i didn't analyze it it
was another sequence c5 c6 you know so
i don't i don't know that it works but
we can try okay we'll try it c5 oh the
computer likes it okay yeah that was
when you first suggested and you were
saying oh but the paul saying i was like
actually at some point that might be a
key point for white winning is you have
to give up your pawns because all that
matters is who gets a queen here
not not how many pawns you have left and
but wait now can i sacrifice the bishop
so bishop d5
check i will take the pawn and can i win
the b3 pawn
[Music]
no rook a3 or b8 or rogue d3 even yes
okay white spikes in time so so it
doesn't work yet
but okay rook a1
c5
rook a5
c6
bishop d5 is forced
is it can you play rook c5 or bishop d5
is forced well i want to
i want bishop d5 but i was i was trying
to do it without sound c5 uh b4
so i say that again b4 simply because i
want to play before anyway before b5 oh
okay that's that's very clear okay
you're right so yeah rook c5 would allow
b4 and again everybody note that there
isn't even a check here which means
you're moving the rook here comes b5 and
two pawns are too many for java so
so bishop d5
king to
[Music]
in fact i think that's important because
i think i made a blunder when i played
king h3 because now that i see it then
my rook c5 works yeah yeah because now
you actually are threatening to give up
the bishop and check and win the pawn
okay so like king h2 so you play king h2
to avoid that and if rook c5 now you can
still play b4 and go on to win so
so that's actually really key that the
king is on h2
so i will sacrifice but then if you're
keeping the b-bound you're completely
winning so
let's see uh can i uh play
something like
now rook c594
protecting the pawn yeah the point is
that white is just holding
and
remember everyone the reason we're
fighting so hard to keep that pawn is
because
rook and knight versus rook is not a
forced win it is actually a a draw um
which which is important so you you have
to make sure all these variations if
your hikaru end
with you keeping that pawn you can't
allow this bishop to give itself up for
two pawns
and i think that we have a move or king
h5 so he like he's using the same idea
like is king g5 king h5 he wants to play
king g4 and create something but i think
it's just way too slow no no not here
like we have the king h5 on the board
we're back we're back to the game you're
saying okay yes so he sorry i
misunderstood
king h5 was played just like king to g5
it has a threat
[Music]
and the variation that we analyzed
started with the a6 rook a1 like sort of
similar
and then c5 that you proposed
rk1 and c5 here that was the variation
that you proposed
yeah
oh
big moment for hikaru
still has a time advantage right up 10
minutes on the clock but
is he going to win
and quickly write his candidate's champ
what do you think chad
let's ask chad
you know on a rare occasion chat knows
all the answers no i'm kidding chat chat
there's a lot of people in chat so they
often come up with uh with good answers
and i'm curious so it's like this uh you
know
wonderfully big computer like where we
can ask him about the sense of life yes
the meaning of life the meaning what is
the meaning of life chad that's a
different show but okay seriously not
just whether hikaru wins this game but
i'm curious if if people have a feeling
about
whether you think he can catch lightning
in a bottle so to speak or maybe you
don't even think it's lightning in a
bottle uh we know we know how talented
hikaru is and and how much he wants it
so
let us know what you think about his his
potential to not just win this game and
turn things around but we'll read some
of your questions on air
so they got it they put fortune too oh
there's a lot of yeah we see a lot of
comments coming in give us a thoughtful
answer
get read on air who knows maybe i'll go
full oprah and start giving away diamond
memberships for good answers i do that
sometimes just like give away i just
like you get a diamond membership and
you get a diamond membership
because it's good to know yeah everyone
said do you want a diamond membership
i've always think i know if you'd like
another one just let me know um okay
what are the perks coming like with the
diamond
membership what perks
there's a lot of perks but you know that
we won't get into that now because then
then i'm chilling right now i'm having
fun but i don't i don't need to show you
should know the perks of a diamond
membership there are so many chat anyway
um
all right king h5
a6 allows rook a1
so we've been here before
and we keep playing a6 and the computer
keeps saying that that actually is not
helping our winning chances after rook
a1 not that not that you can't play it
but that means there must be something
else that the computer thinks is the
best move in this position that we
haven't found yet is it
there's no reason to check because you
don't want the king to go here
exactly so um
we got our first one right there amirah
no
i don't think that carl will win the
tournament but he seems to be in a great
space mentally
and that can do wonders i agree for your
physical health emotional health
spiritual health it's good to be in a
great space mentally i agree no but
jokes aside he does seem to be in a
great space
here comes the flower power
we had this from yesterday we love it
span the flower power
if you are a hikaru nakamura fan or a
subscriber to his channel you probably
have plenty of emotes to spam
hikaru had this i think hikaru has this
i think
it's a complex end game but i think the
time crunch is in his favor i agree i
think ikaro is going to get this one i i
will be
i will be surprised if it carter doesn't
win this game
the whole candidate's another question
right
rajabov will resign after hikaru's pawn
b pawn gets to b7 now that's calling
your shot that is an awkward call
because the b pawn is far away from b7
so let's let's if that
if rem remy za ends up being right that
somehow
raj above resigns after the b pawn
touches b7 you are getting a lifetime
diamond membership
okay
i just gave you like that's like a lot
of value depending on how old or young
you might be so because that is a babe
ruth call you're telling me for java for
zion's the moment hikaru plays the move
pawn to b7 if that happens you get a
lifetime diamond membership booyah
okay can we try it once again like just
leave the kink
on g4 so maybe a6 once again okay a6 yes
of course so now like how did we
continue here
c5 we played rook d6 one time the other
time yes c5
so but it doesn't work here
it's not because of rook a6 i think rook
a6 we get similar so like
it's because of this one and here we
come with h3 and rook h2 and if you're
not careful by the way
if you're not careful like you might
even you know okay apparently it says
why it's winning but i was thinking
maybe there's like a mating net here or
something no no you still have knight to
five okay so it's h3 check first h2
check first okay
sorry cg4 c6 h3 check
so basically this is a very um
brilliant defense you know we were
thinking about this like bringing the
king to g4 and well to threaten
h3 active defense pays out
it's like he created some difficulties
for hikaru to convert
well ikaro knows he's he's got to
be accurate here he's
he's focused and serious but this isn't
the same
kind of
frustration from yesterday yesterday's
game this is he feels poised i think
to get this one we got another good
comment here from danny mac
2794 hicaro should not be underestimated
in this tournament he has a knack of
going on winning streaks for sure we've
talked a lot about yonder palmer
shipping the streaky player almirah but
ikaro is also one of those guys who
it doesn't matter who he's playing he's
his own worst enemy and his own greatest
asset right he's either on a roll based
on whether he's in form or not in many
ways well i've seen people
making illegal moves against hikari like
basically there's so much tension and
pressure
so like
oh by the way hikaru plays this move
king of two which
oh my god this is such a great move
actually you know like first of all the
king is no longer on g2 because he's
anticipating this king g4 h3 he is not
uh well
defining
the position yet so but what if black
just by the way this clearly must have
been we stopped looking at the engine
move here we're using the eval bar i
want to see how it plays out but this
this is clearly better than what we kept
suggesting we kept suggesting a6 and the
engine kept saying
no this is not what you want then what
does he have in mind after king g4 so
it's the same like
yeah that's what i'm wondering like
what's the difference
if king g4 is played
so
[Music]
why is this better
so can we play oh i think
we no longer have the check with the
bishop d5 so maybe a6 is good now is it
is it possible so a6 a6 rook a1
and c5 here
boy doesn't win at all
i don't i had a different idea okay and
a weird idea that because the king on g4
isn't threatening a tempo and the king
has left the bishop behind you now have
ideas with rook f8
to go just win another pawn
ah we completely forgot about it
it's not a threat if the king's on h5
ah so now if king g4 after king gf2 you
simply play rook f8
and you're collecting another pawn
king of two sort of like
kind of like stops black in his tracks
so
hold on there power ranger
kingship four
rook fade bishop c4 can i sacrifice it
there
you're sacrificing you're obsessed with
this yes but i want to make a draw it's
okay it's dynamite on c4
you're allowed to sacrifice on c4
because it's explosive sorry i
i'm sorry chad i'll be here all week
okay yeah there you go explosive
sacrifices on c4 rook takes c4 but okay
this is this has got to be winning right
yeah say six okay yes yeah and you can
actually take and defend at the same
time exactly yes okay it doesn't work
wait
what
that didn't work
oh because the rook takes d4 yeah you
give me the knight
so what was what was the move
oh you have to play rook a8 but this is
not so this is hilarious and then you
play a7
this is not so obvious it's not so
obvious and the table base shocked me
back into my
shocked me back into my body here i was
i was you know it's a long day i'm kind
of leaving leaving it here and here we
go it's uh
that was a very very forcing line
wow of course it doesn't work but it is
like it's some sort of
um
psychotic you know sacrifice like yeah
but we we have a very critical moment
and a very nice idea from the car that
he found and now rajab
is down to four minutes we're gonna
we're gonna quickly sneak in a call a
call out here we haven't taken a break
in quite some time and we're not taking
a break because we're going to be here
with all of you to the end but
we had
an opportunity to remind you that you
can compete in the chess.com global
championship play alongside the world's
best players be a part of history
entering the largest tournament we've
ever done qualifiers have players have
hundreds and thousands of players every
saturday and sunday as people qualify
for their chance all the way through
july 31st you can compete in these
events also to take part in cash prizes
head to go.chess.com
cgc2022
um funny announcement uh
as we as we come back to the game sorry
head to
go.just.comcgc2022 for more info to sign
up today get verified and start
competing in
global championship but funny
announcement we have we've had these
great king walks today lots of king
action we actually showed on the on the
monitor if you missed it earlier the
legendary nigel short king walk up to h6
fun fact i'll just spoiler alert nigel
short accepted one of our wild card
invites so he's going to be playing in
the chess.com global championship we
actually made an effort and i won't
reveal all the names that have accepted
i am so excited to announce the field
when we get to the round of 64 because
32 players will qualify in the global
championship 32 are invited
and we didn't just do a 1-32 of the
current list we went to some of the
champions and some of the players the
people will be absolutely thrilled
kromnic is another player who's accepted
to play and there are many others and
i'm not going to reveal more but short
kramnik and many others are going to be
competing
it's going to be epic so seriously the
round of 64 is going to be bananas it's
not just a current list not to say
there's anything wrong with the world's
current 32. we like them
but i'm very pumped about where we're
headed with that so oh rook f8 was that
on the board
yep
okay so
well now he well he did it he did it so
he
he will win this game for sure
but what a nice i mean we couldn't solve
it we didn't like we kept trying a6
right we were beating our head against
the wall here and he plays this really
subtle king of two
what a trick right you get the king
to leave g6
and when you do and especially like you
like it's not under attack like h3 is
not coming with checks so king g4 and
now rook f8 this is very subtle and i i
really love this idea
super super instructive and and just
super accurate right this is where
hikaru thrives there was a comment
earlier from twitch chat that hikaru
thrives in these sort of slight edges
that he can grind get his excuse me get
his opponents under time pressure and
guess what
that's exactly what he did i just hope
that i will not be the last one standing
here like
we're losing people
we're losing people yeah well
well i don't know they promised robert
has to me you know you used it as a
talking you know too
yeah well we'll we'll talk about that in
a little bit there's obviously a lot
going on with with the players people
wondering where hammer is but uh
anyway we have we have a lot going on
here we have we have this final game
here who knows
whether i don't think we'll have an
interview with with either players i'm
being told no we won't have any any post
game interviews but either way we'll
definitely catch the final moments of
this game so
man what a bounce-back victory this is
going to be elmira for hikaru
i i'm super excited you know it's like
this is such an interesting tournament
from like
many
points like if i
is i was waiting for a move so he was
leaning towards the h pawn so h3 was
played
he plays h3 so he's just given giving up
the bishop
after rook takes bishop and h2
i guess hikaru will have to give up the
rook for the pawn but
no first of all i will give a check
maybe i can
do you have it do you have a square
because if you go to four then 92. oh
yeah 92. knight g3 maybe
yeah he takes the bishop
[Music]
after h2
he's going to play check on g7
and if the king touches down on f4
because you cannot go to the h file then
i will check you yeah yeah if you go
yeah just show that real quick yeah the
king goes to anywhere on the h file the
rook gets here with tempo and now you're
stopping the pawn because when the when
the king moves you simply simply go
corral it so indeed hikaru sees it
already he's given the check on the
board
and after king of f4 we will see 92
check
the knock a nod never a good sign to the
opponent agreed agreed
that is uh knocking nods
to himself
that he sees it knight to g3 comes this
protects the h1 square
black is obviously
would be happy to promote but not not if
the
queen is immediately taken what a game
you know how many difficult moves uh
hikaru found like a3 king f2 you know
what they even mentioned and you know
they like uh the um the opening phase of
this game so um
he he fully deserves not only this
victory but even like
well i mean yeah i mean you lose and you
bounce back
you get a win
right you are a half a point behind the
lead it doesn't matter how you got their
scoreboard as the kids say right all
that matters is what the score is
and it is still anybody's candidates and
what an entertaining first two rounds
we've had right
the show has delivered the chess has
delivered
and uh
will rejava resign or will he uh
play it out i don't quite know i mean at
this point
okay he's hoping for one trick there's
one way to go wrong here if you put the
king anywhere but g2 there was rook
takes g3
i'll just show it
right
and then you get a queen
and that's a problem
so
uh but hikaru of course already aware of
that puts the king on g2
and after the next check if it happens
oh he took b3 if he checked again the
king could put itself on h1
okay a6
even what we can even play e6 here
yeah a6 looks good enough hikaru agrees
with al mira
it's nice when the players agree with
you
from time to time from time to time
from time to time it feels like it's
it's so polite you know when they're
behind behind us you know yeah but
they're winning and they agree with the
moves you're suggesting it feels good
okay a6 is played i think i think we're
gonna get a resignation here from her
drop off uh in just moments
and you know
i i wanna i wanna highlight
one of the storylines to this game that
could be forgotten because it it
of course we'll probably get distracted
here moments with the resignation and
congratulations but before we let this
one go we should definitely highlight
that
we were talking about
rajab who've had this incredible career
as he has not won a classical chess game
in three years
he's drawn a lot of classical chess
games
it's really important when you consider
the fact that
in this game he might have had a chance
to put some pressure there was a moment
where hicarus slipped a little bit in
the middle game
and rather than going for the forcing
line he played not to lose right and we
were talking about the psychology how
you could almost classify every player
as those who love to win and those who
hate to lose
and you know obviously there's still
plenty ahead in this tournament but
almirah
how much do you think
rajab of his kicking is get has is going
to be kicking himself about that i mean
at some point
you have to push yourself in those
critical moments to take a risk as you
keep saying you have to bring it all to
the candidates right
and uh
what do you think about that
well
i'm pretty sure about this that
he will well he will of course analyze
this game but
he will regret this bishop c6
yeah
the moment where he could seize the
initiative probably like i'm not sure
like you know once again the we didn't
analyze it deeply so uh
maybe uh
the computer analysis will prove us
wrong
well i don't know i mean we were on the
position for a while there were many
other it wasn't just bishop c6 there was
also rook d5
there were three possibilities there
were three possible moves and and he
took he took
on a position willingly that only hikaru
could win
now he did so thinking he can hold
nobody goes for a position they think
they're going to lose right but you get
what i'm saying right he took on a
position that he thought he was going to
hold but he didn't have any chances to
win and it's just it's an interesting
decision right because there was a
moment where he could have been the
aggressor and he didn't take the
opportunity so but of course it would
have been unclear i'm not saying he's
winning right but it looked dangerous
for hikaru and certainly it would have
kept pieces on the board so
and hikaru once again is taking his time
so he's
he's completely winning
and he simply wants to be sure once
again
yeah you have to be because there is an
outside scenario of
horrific uh niss if you're hikara where
black wins this pawn and then suddenly
gets here
and then rook takes pawn as a draw
right so a car has to be accurate right
now so how do you win this elmira do you
get the knight into yes we need to have
the night we need to to bring the night
into place so
uh how to do it um
first of all
we have to secure that the king doesn't
come to b6 as well while our king is
guarding the h-bomb it's okay we can
always play king h1 so i'm gonna check
so
uh knight f5 for example
okay he he did it
same idea and after takes i think that
we cannot allow king b5 king b6 yeah
this is a draw if black can take the
pawn
so how do we do this so you could
actually play rook b7
and if king c5
knight to e7 and there's no way to get
king c6 so that's one way i don't know
how you went from there maybe it's
knight to c8 knight v6 or something uh
where eventually you try to get a queen
but when you play knight okay let's have
a look at this position it's a very
interesting end game
yes oh by the way he does so he does
play rook to b7
i don't want to take us away from the
live board so okay let's uh yes
we're waiting here but yeah we'll
analyze it real quick with with king
king
i think it was 97 okay yeah computer so
that stops king c6
you know black that can make some moves
you know you check and you know whatever
maybe king d6 but the point is i think
the knight eventually comes to c8
which guards the pawn and then you can
play rook v8 that's it
okay so that's the clear plan the knight
is going to complete its journey on the
c8 square where it protects the pond
and allows the rook to move forward what
you think you buy it
it's perfect perfect
okay our job here is done let's drop the
mic and get out of here there we go we
did it game over
game over ricardo has a plan he's as he
said like once said in an interview so
like finally you could have as many
seconds as you want but
the players are well playing the game
and they are working the magic
it's true and um this is purely
like this game
especially in the end game this is a
pure magic yeah like
king f2 is probably the most difficult
move in this game that was a that was a
brilliant move i agree king of two
and it was just a few moves back we have
the announcement i'll show this this was
the move of the game for sure
and i moved that we were we were really
struggling to come up with the right
the right way to approach it and he
found it and now we're back i'll i turn
on the engine indeed that was the engine
best move
and he took a lot of time and found it
what a crazy find
and while we're while we're bouncing
back and and have the analysis board up
i'm just gonna
leave us with that that thought that we
had again it was it was this position
here
the decision to play queen to d5
for rajab
rather than the engine suggested best
bishop to c6 so that was the suggestion
by the computer yeah
it's still unclear
but the computer now that we're here is
suggesting that white just has to give
back the pawn if you play it
and maybe that's what job up didn't like
was takes in queen to b7
but but here's the computer line is that
like
the back rank is guarded
and black has some some pressure with
this bishop and if you just look at it
from a practical point of view
this just doesn't look good for hikaru
so okay obviously we're just speculating
and certainly the
no but i don't like it at all you know
it's like i would be worried yeah i i
agree i it felt it felt scary and
because remember we were kind of
critical of the cars g6 rook d1 now that
we're here we can confirm was also the
engine's best move
so you were right elmira rook d1 was the
right move
and anyway so it's just you know that
critical decision
to for lack of a better way to summarize
it and you know our job is to edutain
educate and entertain and add a little
drama but it's a talking point for sure
that he played not to lose i mean that's
the truth yeah it would be also
interesting to well
to find out like what hikaru thinks
about like all these choices and um
well to have his insights
so jean is dinner going to
to have him for an interview
probably not and we'll we'll we'll
discuss that later yeah but the
situation we're not sure actually with
some with some different news going on
so whether we'll have an interview or
not uh if we can of course we will but
we uh
okay we finally get 97
and
will
when wilbur jabhoff realized that
there's no way to stop this plan that we
highlighted
of knight c8 and rook v8
oh right now can you resign i asked the
question asking you shall receive the
answer
both players smile
rajab has asked akara a question
here you are the arbiter is staying on
the other side by the way look at that
they got the cue so i i wasn't crazy to
say it out loud someone was watching the
show and maybe asked the arbiter
to go to the other side of the cameras
thank you
mythical person who was watching the
show and delivering messages downstairs
we appreciate your efforts
but
to come back to my question i think you
would have better chances against the
minotaur than hikaru it is
[Laughter]
that's an insult to my chest but i will
take it as a as a compliment to my
ability to run for my life from a
minotaur in a labyrinth to fight
well well um
huge win for hikaru we cannot understate
this moment right he lost game one in a
game that he played well right i mean he
played really well against fabiano at
one point was maybe even a little better
as black uh took a risky decision
ultimately lost but it didn't knock him
down he perseveres he's right back in it
tied for second with a number of other
players with plenty of chances to become
the candidate who competes for the world
chess championship so clean win for naca
as chat says completely agree
uh a start to finish victory naka is so
happy right now he should be
you should this is this is a
it's not to say you wanted to lose game
one elmira but how big is it to win
after you lose right
well first of all i really like the way
he played yesterday
we we talked about this game and uh how
complicated it was and once again like
the level
of
like what is he showing like
is uh really incredible yeah well anyone
can lose against fabiano with black you
know but he came right back well and he
was even better at some point once again
so wow well huge win for akara nakamura
you see he was the only decisive game
today in our four board view and now you
see it in the results table before your
eyes report and for russia drew that was
also a very interesting battle shout out
to the birthday boy for holding that end
game
nakamura beaver jaboth napan nashi and
caruana also had an interesting game
dude and dingley wren elmira your
thoughts the game of the day obviously
the decisive game but any other thoughts
here
well
i nurtured some regrets about the
results of
against uh caruana so i i really want to
have fabi's thoughts on this one so
he will certainly analyze it and so uh
maybe we can ask him if he was
considering the exchange sacrifice or
like what is the computer evaluation of
this position so um
for sure this was such an interesting
game and it's like
we didn't had
we didn't have a chance like to
well to go through it till then so i
feel like something something is clear
and missing yeah no and for those who
don't know the moment there was a very
interesting opportunity for that game to
not end in a draw ultimately they did
choose to repeat moves to pandashi and
caruana so sure surely we'll catch up
with them at some point about that game
but
uh we see the results from today what
does that do for the standings uh and
where do the players now sit let's move
over and take a look at our
co-tournament leaders jan napon mishi
and fabiana carwana but followed closely
by several players at one point elmira
including the only winner of today
hikaru nakamura
well anyone can win this tournament
still once again the race is open and
we are going to be here tomorrow we we
surely are going to be here tomorrow and
uh let's let's talk about talk about
sunday's matchups right i mean i think i
think at the standings it's weird to
have icaru as the one on the bottom of
all those tied for third just because he
was clearly the man of the day but again
the tie breaks at this point are
irrelevant
because what matters is that there are
plenty of players with chances to win
our head-to-head matchups for tomorrow
as well as their lifetime records
against each other are before your eyes
well all i have before in my eyes is
you know this is this is oh man you're
right
this is the game i think i think also
car wanted dude from the perspective of
look at that 3-0 score of course
but by the way
let's let this sink in real quick fans
watching all around the world from
twitch to youtube to everywhere you are
for ruja and nakamura have never played
a classical game of chess
i
i knew that coming in and it was one of
the talking points but seeing it now
before it's like dawning on me because i
have commentated on farugia versus
nakamura games so many times right over
the last several years these these are
arguably
the two best bullet players on the
planet okay all due respect to magnus
carlson right they've had incredible
matches
uh you know at one point during the peak
of like the the chess movement pogchamps
i mean hikaru was just streaming random
matches with farouza on a wednesday to
36 000 viewers it was like people love
to watch these two throw down ferrugia
and nakamura is is the epic battle of
titans and we have never seen them
playing classical chess i want to go to
bed right now so i can wake up and
tomorrow comes faster i'm like a kid a
kid on christmas here that is going to
be epic cannot wait
so
are we done i think we are elmira you
did an amazing amazing job uh we'll
remind everybody real quick of when it
will be of course it is three o'clock
local time here in madrid six a.m on the
west coast
almost midnight if you're in sydney
australia down under i only slipped i
only slipped into that accident a couple
times today i want to have a few
countries so i added some dismemberment
okay let us know if you have a few of
countries you'd like us to add we
definitely will
for sure moldova like the country where
i was born yeah okay okay so we will
we'll add some countries but either way
right now just mark whatever time zone
you are closest to
and for my for my partner here almira
scripchenko for myself international
master danny ranch and everyone working
super hard here every day we're going to
continue the coverage
round three for the madrid 2022
candidates tournament we'll be here
tomorrow and we will see you then
[Music]
do
you